Und die Welt hat ein tolles Mensch verloren.
Diejenigen, die mit Steve arbeiten und wissen, haben einen lieben Freund und einen inspirierenden Mentor verloren.
Der Visionär Steve Jobs wurde nur 56 Jahre alt.
Steve Jobs war wohl einer der größten Pioniere unserer Zeit. US-Präsident Obama erklärte, die Welt habe einen großen Visionär verloren.
Steve lässt eine Firma hinter, die er nur erbaut hätte.
Was von anderen CEOs, also Firmenchefs, bleibt, sind reiche Erben, aber keine trauernden Kunden.
Am Morgen, nach meiner Apparazität im Gramm, habe ich diese sehr persönliche E-Mail von dem Mann bekommen.
Er hat eine gute Reputation für einen starken Leader und einen brashen, aber er war für mich immer so nett, so ein guter Freund. Und ich werde ihn vermissen.
Auch Menschen, die in den Himmel gehen wollen, wollen nicht sterben, um dort zu kommen. Denn Tod ist sehr wahrscheinlich die beste Einstellung der Leben. Es ist der Geheimtätige des Lebens.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
So Leute, also ich hatte Sorge, dass wir so gute Laune haben.
Ja, musst du jetzt ja echt so diese Emo-Schublade wieder aufmachen. Ich hab jetzt zwei, wie lange ist das jetzt schon her?
Zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen hier zu tun gehabt, das wegzufiltern und jetzt kommst du hier mit so einer Emo-Schiene nochmal an.
Tja, ignorieren können wir das natürlich jetzt nicht.
Oh, ich war so froh, dass wir das nicht während der Sendung erfahren haben.
Ich auch.
Er war da schon tot, ne?
Nee, nee, nee. Doch. Nee, nee, aber es ging drei Uhr nachts.
Da kam die Nachrichten. Da hat er geschrieben, dass er am Morgen gestorben ist.
Nee, drei Uhr nachmittags oder so.
Nee, im frühen Morgen stand er, oder? Hat er doch gerade noch mal gesagt.
Oder this morning?
Keine Ahnung, welche Zeit. Ich weiß es nicht. Ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal. Ich bin froh, dass wir das nicht direkt noch in die Sendung reingereicht haben. Das weiß ich noch so nach vier Stunden irgendwie so als letztes. Das wär's ja gewesen. Ich bin auch froh, dass es mich auch, also ich muss die Nachricht auch gerade so verpasst haben, weil ich saß halt hier eigentlich noch eine Weile und hab so die Sendung verpasst. Das hab ich schon fertig gemacht und man kommt ja dann auch nicht so schnell runter und hab dann aber irgendwie wohl nicht mehr Twitter gelesen. Chet meint, Dennis hat recht, na hat er halt recht. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, ich weiß auch, ich hab auch irgendwie die zwei Wochen gebraucht.
Ja, das war eigentlich gerade wieder gut und jetzt... Toll.
Naja, ich meine, was sollen wir noch dazu sagen? Ist nicht schon alles gesagt?
Weiß ja jeder selber.
Ist eigentlich die Webseite, die Webseite ist... Also das finde ich ja wirklich so bemerkenswert. Ich hätte ja jetzt also am Anfang gesagt...
Eine Woche.
Eine Woche, ne? Genau so. Dann kommt irgendwie das iPhone 4S und so und dann fühlt alles gut und das wäre ja auch in seinem Sinne und lalala. Aber offensichtlich, mann, seht's mal wieder ernst.
Das bleibt jetzt so.
Wir ziehen jetzt um auf iphone.com und das bleibt jetzt so.
Das geht dann direkt am 24. Oktober wird da ein Buchcover draus von seiner Autobiografie, die du da kaufen kannst.
Ja, also mal ehrlich, mir fällt's ja wirklich schon schwer drauf wetten, abzuschließen, wie lange dieses Bild da noch stehen bleibt. Ich meine, seit heute, glaube ich, haben sie jetzt diese ganzen E-Mails, die sie eingesammelt haben, da noch mit draufgepackt und die werden sie jetzt sicherlich auch nicht in zwei Tagen gleich wieder einstellen.
Wo haben sie die mit draufgepackt?
Na, wenn du jetzt hier draufklickerst, dann war ja vorher nur dieses Schicken und noch mal eine Mail und jetzt sind halt auch die Mails da.
Und die scrollen auch durch live oder was?
Nee, nicht live, aber sie cyclen so ein bisschen.
Ja, jedes Mal, wenn du drauf gehst, hast du was anderes.
Ah, verstehe.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ist doch live. Nee, die ändern sich auch. Doch, kommen auch welche nach.
Genau, scrollt durch. Kannst du dir einfach jetzt angucken.
Dann können wir mal chatten, wie auf dem Kongress damals.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das live ist. Geht dann auch aus dem Grund.
Nein, live ist das bestimmt nicht. Weißt du, wie das ist? Aber die werden da schon ihre Auswahl gemacht haben. Auf jeden Fall haben sie wohl erstmal ein Team drauf angesetzt, was sich einfach genau erstmal so um diesen Teil kümmert.
Kann das nicht Siri?
Weil es mich ja so umgehauen hat, dass ja bei der iPhone 4S-Präsentation, die haben das ja bestimmt alle gewusst, dass es ihm nicht gut geht, dass es jetzt zu dem Ende zugeht.
Ist gut vorstellbar.
Und ich wette, wenn er irgendwie noch in der Lage dazu war, Das war den Abend davor, richtig? Genau, dann hat er es auch noch geguckt.
Oder den Tag davor, das war bei denen ja auch morgens. Genau, es war nur noch ein, 24 Stunden vorher.
Und wenn es ihm irgendwie ging, dann hat er sich das definitiv auch angeguckt.
Das, was ja keinem aufgefallen ist irgendwie in der ganzen Berichterstattung, als sie da am Anfang da so auf die Bühne schwenken, war ja auch so ein Kameraschnitt, auf den Reserv zieht.
Haben wir alle gesehen.
Ich hab den Schwenk nicht gesehen.
Ich hab den Schwenk gesehen, aber ich hab ihn irgendwie nicht so.
Umzackrittern.
Ich bin dann so aufgewacht. Und wie das so ist, man startet natürlich, bevor man auch nur das Bett verlässt, scrollt man schon mal durch irgendwelche Nachrichten durch. Wir sind ja alle süchtig. Und dann sprangst du einfach gleich ins Gesicht.
Das geile war bei mir, ich hab ja diese Obama-Meldungen als erstes gelesen. Und dann stand da drin so, dass hier einer der, blablabla, dass die Leute halt davon auf ihrem Gerät erfahren, also auf einem dieser Geräte erfahren, weil ich lag halt gerade im Bett und scrollte auf dem iPhone und dachte mir.
Ja, das ist wirklich. Also ich hatte echt, echt Schwierigkeiten so und war, war echt traurig. Und mitten rein hat mich dann irgendwie N24 angerufen.
Und wollte von dem jahrzehntelangen Vorzeige-Fanboy und Evangelisten...
Ja, die haben da halt irgendwie einen Themen-Tag draus gemacht und haben dann den ganzen Tag da durchgecycelt.
Die haben auch nichts besseres zu tun, ne?
Nö, die haben nichts besseres zu tun. Ich meine, so funktioniert der Apparat, die suchen sich irgendwie ein, zwei Themen raus und das war halt irgendwie Fußball, Nationalmannschaft spielt demnächst und das... Das im Wesentlichen, ich hab jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag vor dem Fernseher gehangen, deswegen. Warum auch? Dachte ich mir auch nur so, oh man, ruft mich jetzt hier an. Sie haben sicherlich noch geschlafen, meinte sie zu mir. Head in the clouds. Dennis, sag mal was. Wie ging es dir denn?
Na ich war gerade wie am Display basteln, war noch nicht fertig, stand da auf der Leiter und dann meinte jemand, hier ist Steve tot. Ich überleg so, weil ich mich jetzt wieder ärgern, oder stimmt das? Ich bin runtergestiegen von der Leiter, Spiegel angeklickt und da stammt's schon. So, hot news ohne Text, weiß, wie wir das bei Spiegel immer machen. Dann wird's wohl stimmen, wenn's da steht, da macht man keine Witze.
Also hast du das noch richtig in der Nacht erfahren, oder wie?
Ich hab ja auch gleich gezwittert.
Ja, der ist bestimmt ähnlich wie andere berühmte Persönlichkeiten mit dem U-Boot nach Argentinien und so.
Ich glaub auch, der ist ja mit neben Elvis irgendwie im Liegestuhl. Und baut da die I-Watch. In der Sonnenlege und liegt am Strand und trinkt Pina Coladas.
Vielleicht zieht er sich auch einfach nur in so eine Höhle zurück, um einfach in Ruhe das iPhone X.
Hab ich doch vor ein paar Sendungen schon gesagt. Der wusste, Höhepunkt so, iPhone 4, 4S Wahlung. Haben wir ja gesehen, war jetzt nicht so doll. Börsenberichte waren auch enttäuschend. Da hat er sich gedacht, ich tret hier mal vorher ab und so besser geht nicht. Und macht jetzt einen schönen Lebensabend. Also als Milliardär kann man sich das schon finanzieren, ich meine.
Meinst du, die haben in Wirklichkeit doch irgendwie ein bisschen Staub hinter dem Kühlschrank vergraben?
Deswegen auch hier, die wollten ja auch nicht, dass man bei der Beerdigung und so, da war ja auch keiner dabei, war ja alles abgegriegelt. Also wenn man die Verschwörungstheorien ein bisschen anfeuern will.
Also im Nachhinein macht das ja alles Sinn.
Dass er abgetreten ist?
Nein, also dass er, der Zeitpunkt seines Abtretens und dann sein Tod, also dieses Unfortunately this day has come, wo viele diese Todes, bevorstehende Todesnachricht hineininterpretiert haben, das hat auch gestimmt.
Ja, hab ich auch schon mal gesagt, dass der nicht abtritt, ohne dich trifftigen Grund und das wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr nicht mehr macht.
Ich wollte es nicht wahrhaben.
Ja, wahrhaben will immer keiner, was aber ich hab mir auch so schnell geht, hatte ich nicht mitgerechnet.
Hätten sie den nicht einfrieren können, verdammte Scheiße, und dann in 25 Jahren nochmal aufhauen und dann irgendwie dann mal kurz was reinreplizieren?
Hey, sie haben Krebs und wir haben immer noch kein Mittel dagegen.
Hätte dann halt nochmal Deep Fried Steve. Nee, gab ja auch geil den Rumor gleich, dass Steve sich ja ums 4S und so gar nicht mehr gekümmert hat, sondern gleich ums iPhone 5 jetzt eigentlich nur noch die ganze Zeit. Und deswegen ist das jetzt auch so unspektakulär.
Ein iPhone 4S ist so ein typischer Speed Bump, oder?
Also ehrlich gesagt, dieser Todeszeitpunkt hat mich ja gerade doch massiv erschreckt. Weil ich dachte ja auch so, naja, der ist jetzt da raus im Wesentlichen und tritt jetzt nochmal ein bisschen hier, macht nochmal einen entspannten und sowas. Aber der war ja offensichtlich, also ich meine, der ist... Also es gibt ja so dieses Phänomen, dass Leute gerne mal nach hohen Feiertagen, also ältere Leute oder wenn sie geschwächt sind, nach höheren Feiertagen sterben oder nach Geburtstagen oder sowas. Und der stirbt einen Tag nachdem das neue Telefon vorgestellt worden ist. Und ich finde, dass... Ich glaube nicht, dass das ein Zufall ist. Also ich glaube, dass der sich wirklich so lange noch quasi hingeschleppt hat und da auch noch voll involviert war.
Und dann, weil alle von der Enttäuschung geredet haben, haben sie uns alle in den Kot geschickt.
Wahrscheinlich eher im Gegenteil so, okay, jetzt auch gut. Das hab ich noch gemacht, fertig.
Und seine Mannschaft hat die Show gerissen, ja. Aber was auch immer. Also, naja.
Schwer zu sagen.
Aber wann war jetzt zum letzten Mal auf der Bühne? Irgendwann im Sommer, oder?
Im Juni.
So einklaut.
Also vor vier Monate vorher.
Und da war er schon...
Wir sehen, wie er sich da noch so durchgeschleppt hat. Also, ich glaub, der hatte wirklich nichts anderes auch am Kopf als irgendwie Apple.
Ja, ich mein, es wird auch total klar, dass es einfach schon immer, dass er es schon immer so gesagt hat, wie er es gemeint hat und schon immer so gemeint hat, wie er es gesagt hat. Das ist irgendwie echt erstaunlich. Ja, und vor allem, man hat irgendwie echt das Gefühl, dass da irgendwie so ein Familienmitglied entschwindet. Das klingt so ein bisschen albern, aber das war ja der total Michael Jackson, Lady Diana-Moment der IT-Szene.
Na, nicht nur der IT-Szene. Ich meine, das ist ein Popstar unserer Zeit gestanden.
Alle fucking deutschen Zeitungen, also am nächsten Tag am Kiosk, wirklich alle Berliner Zeitungen, Morgenpost, FAZ, Berliner Kurier, WZ, Bild, alle.
Ja, weil die sich alle ein iPhone gekauft haben und ein Mac in den letzten Jahren. Ich meine, das wäre doch vor zehn Jahren nicht... Na gut, ich meine, die Situation lässt sie eh nicht vergleichen, aber ja, das ist schon erstaunlich. Das ist schon erstaunlich, dass sie sich da so haben drauf einigen können. Das ist irgendwie auch keiner so richtig davon abgewichten, oder?
Hier, Richard Stolman. Der Typ, ey.
Der Typ, der geht echt überhaupt nicht. Wahrscheinlich hat er sich nebenbei noch irgendwie in der Nase gebohrt und seine Zehennägel geschnitten, wie das sonst auch Mama. Keiner will sich geströlen bleiben. Das ist wirklich ein Vertreter einer Szene. Dafür kann man sich echt nur schämen, oder?
Ja, aber selbst die Linux-er finden, also die Gnul, also die meisten da aus der Ecke, die finden ja den Stolman auch und cool.
Sogar die Linux-er!
Also ich glaube, den so richtig toll findet, den keiner mehr. Da gibt es bestimmt so ein paar Die Hard Gnu-Fanboys, keine Ahnung, was die auch noch auf das was, wie hieß ein...
Ja, aber Widerspruch kriegt ja auch keinen.
Nee, ich glaube die...
Aber da kann man auch schon dran sehen, dass den keiner ernst nimmt.
Also ich hab mal, ich nenne jetzt keine Namen von jemanden, da hat er bei jemanden für ein paar Tage gewohnt und dessen Beziehung wäre fast daran zerbrochen.
Ja, das glaube ich sofort. So Geschichten höre ich nur.
Ja, der muss wirklich komplett unerträglich sein. Der hat wohl im Taxi schon den Fahrer irgendwie angeschrieben.
Ich hab mal so Veranstalter getroffen, wo er auch so ein paar Tage war und der meinte einfach nur so, hätte mich nicht irgendjemand warnen können?
Also, das müsst ihr doch gewusst haben.
Sollen wir aber nicht über den reden?
Nein, wir reden nicht über Stolman, aber der Typ hat echt mal wieder bewiesen, dass er einfach mal überhaupt nichts schnallt, was das betrifft. Und klar, viele haben sich natürlich wieder aufgeregt. Blablabla, das wär jetzt auch alles überhöht. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich finde, das wird überhaupt nicht maßlos übertrieben.
Hängt sicherlich immer von der Perspektive ab.
Ja, sicher, klar. Aber ich meine, es ist so offensichtlich geworden in den letzten Jahren, dass er was wirklich Außergewöhnliches geschafft hat. Dass das das wirklich das erste Mal Qualität siegen kann. Das finde ich...
Zumindest in der Branche.
Ja, oder in irgendeiner Branche.
Dann kenne ich mich nicht so gut aus. Also es stimmt schon, ich hab irgendwie getwittert, weil irgendwie auch so irgendwie Klos im Hals. Man kannte ja eigentlich, oder man kannte gar nicht und nur mal ein paar mal gesehen und sowas, aber irgendwie schon... Scheiße, das ist doof. Und ich hab auch wirklich diverse Abende vor dem Einschlafen darüber nachgedacht, wie das so ist mit dem Tod und so diesem ganzen Zeug und sowas. Es nag ja sowieso ein bisschen dazu. Und hab dann irgendwie so getwittert, dass ich keine Person... Also ich hab wirklich eine Weile darüber nachgedacht, mir fällt keine Person ein, die ich nicht persönlich kenne, die mein Leben so nachhaltig beeinflusst hat wie Steve Jobs. Und da kam dann so ein Wort, naja, Henry Ford oder Newton oder wer ist der Teufel was? Die haben jetzt auch alle. Das sind alles tolle Leute gewesen.
Aber...
Das hätte sich alles verwachsen, sage ich jetzt mal. Also das ist die...
Oder waren es nur die Erfindungen als solche, oder? Das war ja jetzt nicht unbedingt die Persönlichkeit.
Aber ich glaube auch bei Newton so, was weiß ich, was Energiehaltungssatz, den hätte es auch, wäre zur Not 100 Jahre später, hätte den jemand entdeckt. Da hätte ich jetzt, für mich hätte das jetzt persönlich keinen Unterschied mehr gemacht. Aber so dieses... Bei Apple reingehen und diese Firma wieder retten und auf die Beine stellen und dann die gesamte Industrie umdrehen.
Das ist...
Ich sehe wirklich nie... Das hätte kein anderer gemacht. Das wäre einfach nicht passiert. Und wenn es 20 Jahre später passiert wäre, dann wäre es... Dann wäre es doof gewesen. Weil keiner von uns hätte jetzt irgendwie ein Touch-Telefon in seiner Tasse. Vermutlich wäre die Firma, die diese Rechner herstellt, hier pleite. Also, ich hätte meinen Job nicht. Ich hätte wirklich ein komplett anderes Leben. Und das ist echt krass.
Ja, oder überhaupt so Personal Computer. Ich meine, auch die Dinge, die wir jetzt Apple zuschreiben werden, jetzt komplett ohne Apple, vielleicht auch auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise irgendwann dann auch mal Realität geworden. Ich denke, die Menschheit erfindet sich am Ende des Tages schon dann so die Sachen, die sie braucht und will. Und das ist dann auch ein kollektiver Prozess.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Aber er war natürlich auf jeden Fall, wie sagt man so schön, transformativ. Also er war einfach derjenige, der es dann auch wirklich ausgelöst hat, angeführt hat, begleitet hat.
Der sich halt nicht von den Technikern vorschreiben hat lassen, was geht und was nicht geht, sondern gesagt hat, ihr machtet jetzt und so weiter.
Und er war ein fucking Hippie. Ich meine, er hat eine deutliche Menge Storys gelesen. Habt ihr diese Story gelesen, wo er irgendwie Atari Employee Number 40, wo sie ihn dann irgendwie nach Deutschland geschickt haben, wo es ihm nicht gefiel, weil irgendwie zu viel Fleisch und Kartoffeln am Start sind.
Ja und die mit ihm überhaupt nicht klar gekommen sind.
Das ist erst mal für ein paar Monate nach Indien verschwunden und hat wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag nur am Strand getrippt.
Ja, die Story war doch irgendwie so, dass...
Bluebox-Bauer, LSD-Nehmer, revolutioniert die Welt.
Studienabbrecher sowieso.
Ja, genau. Adoptiv-Kind.
Na, da hole ich Enchilada.
Ja, das ging eigentlich gar nicht. Vielleicht ist das so die Voraussetzung.
Ja, also ich...
Ich weiß jetzt auch, was die große Transition war. Steve hat sich Transitioned.
Also was ich jetzt noch...
Und du meinst, da kommt jetzt noch was?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt immer noch keine Ahnung, wovon sie gesprochen haben. Sogar der alte iPod ist noch da.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das schiebt das mit ins Grab genommen, das Geheimnis.
Was ich ja noch mal getan habe, im Zuge dieser ganzen Emo-Wochen, hab ich mir ja noch mal diese WWDC-Q&A von 97 angeguckt. Das ist halt auch echt immer wieder krass, dass er halt auch vor, wie viel? 15 Jahren? Irgendwie, was der da alles so rausgehauen hat und so einfach extrem viel damals schon gesagt hat, was jetzt halt alles so passiert ist. Und einfach so viel Recht dieser 1 Stunde Q&A hat, wie manche Menschen im ganzen Leben nicht so.
Das war auch das, wo er auch so bei NFS und so weiter redet. Das ist ja alles irgendwie ein Netzwerk.
Und vom Server.
Eigentlich so iCloud und alles schon.
Also ich pack hier mal den Link ins YouTube, weil das ist eigentlich so für alle, die noch mal wissen wollen, dass er wirklich irgendwie krasse Checkungen hatte. Kann man diesen Link da mal klicken. Auch die Introduction ist eigentlich voll die rührende Geschichte, wo der Typ ihn da anmoderiert. Und das war halt 1997.
Ja, auch ein seltener Moment, wie er sich da gegeben hat. Dass er da... also Q und A, nicht nur A. Sonst gab es kein Q mehr.
Vor allen Dingen hat ihn ja der eine da so ein bisschen angeflaumt. Und auch da ist er echt zu beruhigen geblieben.
Äh, weswegen nochmal? Ach so, weil er den Newton...
Nee, weil er Opendoc scheiße findet oder nicht wollte und so.
Ja, und wie recht hat er behalten. Opendoc war nämlich in der Hinsicht auch wirklich scheiße.
Weiß man's?
Also im Nachhinein, wenn es weg ist, weiß man nicht, was draus geworden wäre.
Na ja, aber herzlichen Dank erst mal auf das konzentriert, was wirklich wichtig war, das Produktart-Fix.
Opendoc war schon... also ich hab ja auch lange dran glauben wollen. Hieß ja so, dass es toll ist. Und wir glauben ja alles, was unsere Führer sagen.
Ich glaube, Ragtime hat... Wie hießen die, die das hergestellt haben?
Die haben mal versucht, irgendwie Ragtime auf Opendoc zu bringen.
Die haben komplett alles umgeschrieben auf Opendoc und in dem man fertig war, ein Zeichen weg.
Er hat einfach so viel Recht da und auch diese ganzen Eigenentwicklungen, sowieso, Protokoll und was nicht alles, wo er dann irgendwie sagt, ist ja alles gut und schön und ist vielleicht auch superior, aber braucht halt keiner nach dem Motto, die Welt da draußen hat schon TCP, dann müssen wir jetzt auch TCP machen, sonst spreche man nur mit uns alleine.
Du hast ja eine der schwierigen Entscheidungen, dass man auf der einen Seite sieht, wo gibt es wirklich Standards, die relevant sind und wo ist es notwendig, selber irgendwas zu machen, weil die Standards nichts taugen oder weil sie in die falsche Richtung weisen.
Also ich fand die Stelle gut, wo einer meint, wir müssten different sein und der meinte, wir müssen halt besser sein. Der andere meinte dann, lass uns doch einigen auf irgendwie anders und besser und Steve so, nee, nee, lass uns einigen auf viel besser.
Ja, es war ja auch irgendwie so dieses eine Town Hall Speech Zitat, wo irgendwie auf Michael Dales Shareholder Zitat angesprochen wird und dann irgendwie meinte, dass er auch total Recht hat, weil wenn Apple jetzt auch irgendwie ein Yet another PC Maker ist mit beige Boxen und den gleichen Features wie alle anderen und so weiter, dann kann man es auch sein lassen. Kann man es auch gleich sein lassen, genau.
Ach, der hat gesagt, fuck Michael Dales.
Ja, das war bei irgendwie noch eine andere Gelegenheit oder so. Da wurde wahrscheinlich ein paar Mal drauf angesprochen, kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich bin mir ja immer auf die Biografie gespannt, was da noch so alles drin stehen wird. Das werde ich gleich an dem Tag dann noch geklickt.
Hast du schon? Als Buch oder als E-Buch?
Ich hab ja erst als Buch geklickt, weil ich muss nur auf diesen Monat fette Abrechnungen warten, um nicht mehr den Kindle shoppen kann.
Das ist noch gar nicht. Weil wir in der letzten Sendung über diese Amazon Keynote gesprochen haben, hab ich mir mal diese Kindle Keynote nochmal angeguckt. Einer der Hörer hat die netterweise verlinkt. Und direkt danach musste ich mir nochmal die Macworld von 2007 angucken, mit dem iPhone Macworld. Und das war so ein Unterschied. Ich glaube, auch da wird es wirklich auch bei Apple jetzt echt schwer werden.
Ein harter Vergleich, ne?
Ich glaube, die iPhone Keynote wird so in die Geschichte eingehen als The Keynote.
Ja, aber dieser Chef Bezos, der hat auch so viel falsch gemacht. Das war so eine schlechte Keynote. Ich würde gern, aber ich krieg's nicht hin. Das war von A bis Z so.
Ja, das ist bei allen so. Das haut mich immer wieder um. Also kriegt der nicht einer mal irgendeine Präsentation auf die Reihe, die ihm was taucht?
Die von Tim Cook war ja nicht schlecht.
Nein, ich meine jetzt außer Apples Präsentationen.
Ja, und das ist wirklich eigentlich relativ simples Handwerk. Also dieser Chef Bezos, der hat zum Beispiel offensichtlich seine Anleger angesprochen, nicht die User. Das ist bei Apple immer ganz wichtig. Wir erzählen eine Story, wir wollen was für die User schaffen. Und das ist das, warum du dieses Produkt brauchst. Chef Bezos hat nur noch jedem Satz gesagt, we will sell millions of these.
Das sagt natürlich eine Menge darüber aus, wer die Kunden sind bei Amazon.
Ja, und über dieses Amazon Kindle Fire hat er eingeführt mit. Hat so alle Services, die Amazon bietet, an die Wand geschrieben und dann so, wir haben uns überlegt, ob wir ein Produkt schaffen können, was all diese Services unter einem Hut bringt. Und dieses, and the answer is, und dann Pause lassen, so, oh, Spannung!
Bestimmt sagt er jetzt nein!
Wirklich, das hat er mehrfach gebracht, dieses yes. Das ist so unerträglich. Und diese, okay, die iPhone keynote. Aber es ist auch, wenn man sich das jetzt nochmal anguckt, dann sieht man auch mal so, wenn so alle mal tun, so ja, das hätte es auch so gegeben, das hätte, hä? Bei dieser ersten keynote, wie die Leute da da sitzen, als sie diesen blöden Lockscreen wegmacht. Dieses Slide to Unlock und wie wirklich alle so, fucking hell, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das möglich ist. Und ich weiß auch, dass ich es nicht für möglich hielt, bis zu dem Moment, wo ich es in den Fingern hielt. Und heute, klar, sind jetzt vier Jahre später, für uns ist alles selbstverständlich geworden. Aber das war eigentlich...
Ja, auch bei dem iPod eigentlich genauso. Ich fand die iPod-Präsentation auch so krass, die war in so einem kleineren Rahmen und so vor der Industrie, mehr oder weniger. Dann irgendwie so alle so die dachten, naja, wer braucht denn jetzt noch einen Musikplayer? Und er die halt auch irgendwie so komplett um den Finger wickelt und irgendwie, die einfach mit diesem scheiß iPod einmal die Welt erobert haben, quasi. Bis zu so einem Punkt, wo irgendwie echt einfach keine Sau was anderes mehr hatte, gefühlt. Und das ist irgendwie auch echt beeindruckend, weil jeder andere, der jetzt, wenn der Jeff Bezos jetzt von so einem Festplatten-MP3-Player erzählt hätte, wär wahrscheinlich irgendwie alle so, ja, okay.
Bei Jeff Bezos soll es ja wohl so sein, dass er tatsächlich auch so ein extremer Kontrollfreak ist. Aber ich glaube, was Steve Jobs wirklich, der konnte das und der hatte die Autorität, das muss man ja auch erstmal haben innerhalb dieser Firma, so ein Produkt zu sagen, ja wir machen das. Und dann halt auch diesen Kontrollwahn, das bis ins Letzte durchzudrücken, dass es dann auch wirklich gemacht wird. Also er konnte sich auf die Bühne stellen, konnte genau sagen, warum dieses Produkt gebraucht wird und konnte dir jedes Detail erklären. Und Jeff Bezos, der wusste nicht, wofür ein Kindle Touch braucht. Das hat man ihm angemerkt. Weil er hat nämlich danach erzählt, dass sie ja noch den anderen Kindle haben, der keinen Touch hat. Und warum keinen Touch zu haben, ja total toll ist. Und direkt drei Sekunden vorher hat er sich einen neuen Kindle Touch vorgestellt. Also Aussage wäre eigentlich gewesen, warum stellt er denn das Ding vor?
Als es einfach rauskam, da gab es aber noch nicht so wirklich Touch, oder?
Da gab es auch keinen Klick.
Genau, und Stift auch noch.
Also Klick gab es aber keinen Touch.
Also, ja, iPad und die Sony Ericsson-Fones, die hatten alle so einen Plastik-Netzel-Stift und so, und Palmen, genau, ja. Aber es war halt nicht so Krabbel. Nicht Krabbel-Touch.
Es war vor allen Dingen auch so, Microsoft hat damals dieses Windows für Telefone, das sie beworben haben, dass es genauso aussieht wie auf dem Desktop.
Es sah ja aus wie Windows 3.11 oder so, am Anfang, ja.
Ja, irgendwie sowas in die Richtung. Aber eben auch keine Sekunde dran gedacht, dass man ja eventuell auf dem Telefon was anderes brauchen könnte als auf dem Desktop. Und ich glaube, wir würden heute noch der Desktop-Metapher auf dem Telefon hinterherrennen, wenn es das iPhone nicht gegeben hätte.
Für die Desktop-Metapher ist das sowieso scheiße.
Ja, wir brauchen nur ein Terminal, oder?
Das sieht ja mal an wie es hier aussieht auf meinem Desktop. So sieht es auch auf jedem Computerdesktop aus. Alles durcheinander, finde ich nichts.
Terminal only, ich sag's euch.
Für die Hörer, auf Tims Schreibtisch sieht es sehr unordentlich aus.
Das Terminal ist sowieso das beste User-Interface von allen. Du tippst, einen Befehl eindrückst, enter und der Computer macht, führt den Befehl aus. So, genau so, besser geht's doch gar nicht eigentlich.
Körser hoch und gleich nochmal.
Dann sag ich mal hier, gebe ich mal einen Kommando ein.
Der musste, glaube ich...
Musste Siri sagen.
Oder mit C minus V, LX. Steve, sende deinen Kollegen da aus dem Jenseits noch die richtigen Impulse. Wir beten, dass die Apple University wirkt, dass du deinen Manager und Untergebenen ordentlich DNA eingeimpft hast. Also bis auf die Karzinogene DNA, aber...
Ja, plötzlich, das hat ein paar Jahre so aus wie bei FX Twin Videos.
Wer wird jetzt alle abnehmen, plötzlich?
Alle mit so einem Steve-Grenzen.
Und hoffentlich hast du dein iPhone 5 nochmal richtig geil gemacht, auf die letzten Tage. Und dann ist es vorbei, dann können wir abschalten auch.
Ja, das wird jetzt wirklich spannend. Und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt in keinem der aktuellen Protagonisten... Also mir ist nicht klar, wer jetzt so die Meinungsführerschaft hat.
Na meine Befürchtung ist, dass denen das auch noch nicht klar ist. Dass ich das jetzt erstmal rausfinden wird. Und dass das auch nicht unbedingt nett wird. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass da...
Ein Hauen und Stechen?
Ich hoffe nicht drauf, aber ich meine...
Guck mal, wie wir irgendwie auf das Ding abgehen. Und was wir so alles reflektieren. Ich möchte überhaupt nicht wissen, was innerhalb von Apple los war in den letzten zwei Wochen. Das muss doch ein einziges Geheule gewesen sein, dass die überhaupt noch in der Lage waren, eine Webseite zu aktualisieren.
Genau, die Seite war schon da, aber die Rückstahlseite auch nicht.
Das dauert jetzt nur mal zwei Wochen allein. Deshalb so, oh nee, wir können doch nicht.
Aber wenn der Tim Cook jetzt die weiteren Geräte vorstellt, ich denke schon, dass das einen Unterschied ausmacht, dass diese Begeisterung nicht mehr so rüberkommt. Der hat es ja schon drauf, die Massen für jeden kleinsten Scheiß zu begeistern.
Aber er wird es nicht tun. Er wird die Geräte nicht vorstellen. Weil wenn er es tun würde, dann hätte er es bereits getan.
Der hat doch das iPhone 4S vorgestellt?
Nein.
Sondern?
Er hat angefangen, hat so diesen Marktoverview gemacht, so wie geht es uns, tralala, was sind die Geilsten. Was eigentlich so CEO-Kram ist.
Aber Phil Schiller hat es aber auch nicht drauf.
Ja, der ist aber okay, finde ich. Der ist noch locker genug und lange genug dabei.
Ja, aber da renne ich nicht in den Laden und sage, ich brauche direkt so ein Ding.
Also die können alle incredible und amazing sagen.
Das hast du überwiesen, ja.
Aber sie können incredible nicht so incredible sagen wie Steve. Und sie können amazing nicht so amazing sagen wie Steve. Und ich denke, das macht schon aus, wie viel von dem Zeug verkauft wird auch am Ende.
Na, ich glaube, also mittlerweile ist es halt so...
4 Millionen Geräte irgendwie in 3 Tagen oder so?
Das Ding ist halt, die meisten gucken jetzt auch nicht die Keynotes mehr. Also der Großteil der Apple-Käufer schafft, glaube ich, guckt nicht diese Keynotes. Das sind halt die Fanboys so halt, ne? Und die haben das schon immer gemacht. Ja, aber trotzdem Keynote. Ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht live so. Das heißt, es kommt ein paar Tage später und ich glaube, so viele Leute klicken dann jetzt, also von ihrer neuen Kundschaft, von 75 Prozent klicken dann nicht nochmal auf das Video. Ist ja auch nicht translated so, ist nur auf Englisch.
Immer wenn eine Keynote ist, ist dieser Apple Podcast, wo die Keynotes kommen, überholt sogar Mobamex. Ja, es gibt so einen Podcast-Feed, wo die Keynotes rausfallen. Und der überholt sogar Mobamex.
Das kann nicht sein.
Selbst uns?
Also, das wird es dir jetzt langsam. Klar.
Apropos.
Aber das bleibt ja immer noch in dem Tausenderbereich. Ich meine, Apple-Kunden gibt es jetzt eher schon Millionen, Milliarden.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es, also ich glaube nicht, dass dem 95 Prozent der Kundschaft mindestens es total egal, ob Steve Jobs an diesem iPhone mitgebaut hat oder nicht.
Was dem nicht egal ist, wenn es sich anfühlt wie Windows, verdammte Scheiße.
Also ich denke, wir werden jetzt, also ich wäre wirklich extrem überrascht, wenn es jetzt sehr schnell gehen würde mit einer Degradation der Qualität.
Ich glaube, womit es relativ schnell gehen könnte, im Zweifelsfall sind so diese ganzen, worin Steve glaube ich extrem gut war, Rechte auszuhandeln. Also zu Musiklabel zu gehen und zu Plattenlabel und zu Filmfirmen und den allen zu sagen, so guck mal, wir machen das jetzt so. Und ihr haltet jetzt mal kurz den Mund und wir machen das jetzt so.
Habt ihr diese Story gelesen, die ich die Gruber gestern oder heute verlinkt hat mit dem Fox-Videoschäft? Der hat so die Story berichtet, er wollte halt diesen Video-Deal machen, als sie irgendwie angefangen haben, Filme und TV-Shows und so weiter zu bringen. Und dann irgendwie so war das so ein Monat vor der Keynote und der Typ war schon im Urlaub und so. Eigentlich hatten sie sich nicht geeinigt und dann so, I'm coming to Paros, wo in Griechenland auf so einer Insel macht Urlaub und so, sag mir mal, wo ich dich finde, wenn ich da am Flughafen ankomme, einfach gnadenlos auch. Der muss den so aus Schweigen gegangen sein.
Und ich glaube, das kann keiner sonst bei Apple. So eine Deals, den aus dem Kreuz leiern.
Ja, wie soll man jetzt auch so eine persönliche Geschichte kopieren? Man kann jetzt gar nicht mehr jemand sein, der mal das mit den Personalkomputern erfunden hat. Also so in die Welt gebracht.
Ja, aber es kann von so einer Firma nicht mal ebenso jemand geben, der so ein Zweiter ist. Weil jemand so ein Zweiter, der hatte seine eigene Firma.
Vielleicht ist das auch ganz gut so, dass es jetzt erstmal niemanden gibt, der jetzt so eine dominante Rolle hat. Weil ich denke, was eine Fehlwahrnehmung ist, der Öffentlichkeit und sicherlich auch von uns häufig, ist so dieses Steve macht alles.
Nee, das ist so.
Klar, der spielt eine wichtige Rolle und der mag dann auch in kritischen Momenten immer der Katalysator sein. Und am Ende ist es auch seine Meinung, die entscheidet. Wobei ich nicht immer sagen würde, er liegt richtig. Weil es gab auch irgendwie den Cube und es gab auch den iPod 4. Generation. Und es gab Mobile Me. Es gab Mobile Me und es gab immer wieder so Sachen, die wirklich scheiße gelaufen sind. Also so richtig scheiße, wo auch das Produktdesign scheiße war. Ich meine, dieser iPod mit diesen vier Tasten, das ging einfach mal gar nicht. Das war ein ganz großer Fehler.
Aber da hat er sich schon ums iPhone gekäuert bestimmt.
Und es sind immer diese Touch-Tasten, wo es schief geht. Hier beim Cube war es genau das Gleiche. Weißt du noch, der Cube, der irgendwie oben immer so geleuchtet hat, und dann kamen immer alle so, oh ein Cube, was leuchtet denn da? Dann fasst man da drauf und schaltet den Rechner aus. Und dann mussten sie erstmal ins OS in der nächsten Dot Dot Release, gab es dann irgendwie so einen Fleck, wo du sagen konntest, Computer nicht ausschalten, wenn man diese Taste anfasst. Nee, der Cube war einfach mal Dreck.
Na ja, so von der Sache her, weil...
Der sah aus der Ferne ganz gut aus, aber hast du noch versucht, da ein Kabel reinzustecken?
Aber es war auch cool, den mal aufzumachen. Das war schon so vom Industrial Engine...
Ja, ein Griff zum Wegschmeißen.
Dieser Griff, den man dann so in diesen Würfel rauszuholen, das war schon cool.
Das war schon... Ja, vielleicht aber die Kabel angeschlossen. Doch, doch, klar.
Vor allem noch mit Mac OS 9, wenn man dann noch die Reset-Taste ran musste.
Das war ja auch noch so...
Aber vielleicht hätte Steve dann auch jetzt in sein Testament geschrieben, dass alle bei Apple jetzt mal sich dann im neuen Campus eine Prise LSD auf die Butterstrolle streuen sollen, um mal... Aufs Sushi streuen sollen, damit es dann noch mal den visionären Weitblick, den Glow und die shiny, shiny Weltblick-Variante gibt für alle.
Ich hätte ihm ja noch gegönnt, da in diesem Ring zu thronen. Weißt du, dann hätten sie ihn auch nach Mitte begraben können.
Haben wir in dieser Sendung schon das Wort creepy gesagt?
Sollte halt nicht sein, ne?
Gutes Thema.
Ja doch, das wollte ich vorhin auf der Plätze nicht noch mit anbringen. Zwei Sachen haben wir rausgelassen. Next und Pixar. Na gut, bei Disney hat er ja in dem Sinne nichts getan. Da hat er nur was bewirkt.
Da saß er auch im Board.
Ja, er sitzt im Board, aber er hat jetzt keine exekutive Entscheidung übernommen für Disney. Der einzige Beitrag zur Exekutive war, dass er halt Pixar da rein verkauft hat und dann glaubt der Pixar-Chef hier, der Lasseter, war das der Chef eigentlich oder war der Creative Director? Ich weiß nicht, auf jeden Fall war er danach auch der Chef bei Disney. Das hat mich extrem an die Situation erinnert, als Apple Next gekauft hat, aber es eigentlich andersrum war. Weil danach irgendwie alle Spitzenpositionen bei Apple nur noch von Next-Mitarbeitern besetzt wurden. Also zumindest erinnere ich mich jetzt nicht an irgendeinen führenden Mitarbeiter, der danach noch von Apple war. Also der Job war, der CEO war Jobs, der Software-Chef war Tevanjan, der Hardware-Chef war hier...
Rubenstein nicht, aber...
Doch war das nicht Rubenstein, der kam später. Hardware, Software etc. alles wurde quasi von Next übernommen. Und ich meine, der Next-Rechner war irre. Also in gewisser Hinsicht, ich meine, ich bereue zutiefst, dass ich mir damals keinen gekauft habe. Das finde ich wirklich schlimm von mir.
Soll ich dich auspeitschen?
Du musstest dir unbedingt eine Bebox kaufen.
Ja...
Das ist eine Bebox?
Die hat die immer noch.
Ich habe meinen Arbeitgeber damals genötigt, zwei zu kaufen. Die gibt es auch noch, die Bebox.
Hat sie ja länger durchgehalten als die Hersteller. Um einiges länger.
Angeblich gibt es das OS immer noch. Naja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall dieser Cube. Irre! Ich meine, die Maschine war... Wann kam die raus? Wann kam der Next Cube raus? 90 kam der Cube raus.
90 schon?
Na gut, ich meine, 91, 92 ist ja auch das WöWöWö darauf erfunden worden. Von daher muss es ja dann auch irgendwann mal kommen. Und das ist schonmal extrem bemerkenswert. Das war ein Unix-Computer. Das war damals wahrscheinlich der einzige Unix-Computer, auf dem du ordentliches Application Development machen konntest. Also wo auch was ordentliches bei rauskam. Aber davon abgesehen, das Ding war designmäßig ganz weit vorne. Und was ich am geilsten fand war, du kauftest halt diesen Laserdrucker und es war halt wirklich, du druckst auf diesem Laserdrucker und das ganze Rendering wurde schon im Computer gemacht. Und es war halt das Versprechen Visivic, wurde auf dem Next das erste Mal eingelöst. Weil das hier alles aus einem Guss war.
Display Postscript schon gearbeitet hat, was heute wir hier Display PDF haben oder wie auch immer man das nennen kann.
Genau.
Weiß man ja auch irgendwie alles nicht mehr. Und da haben die direkt das Postscript zum Drucker geschickt.
Und es ist mega visionär und das irgendwie alles auf Unix basieren zu lassen etc. Und er hat eigentlich damals schon alles vorweggenommen, was mit MechOS 10 dann die Realität wurde. Zehn Jahre vorher. Im Prinzip. Also vor 20 Jahren wurde schon das angelegt, was wir jetzt so als Alltagssystem haben und was derzeit so das Trending OS ist auf dem Markt.
Wir benutzen ja immer noch NS-Dring und NS...
NS-Dictionary, NS-Alles, NS-Object.
Genau. NS-Objekte von unserem Führer.
Wie ist das Einstein und Elvis of our time? Der sitzt mit Einstein und Elvis am Strand.
Ich sag's euch.
Mit den Skeletten von Einstein und Elvis.
Elvis.
Na gut, also so viel zur Steve-Enttäuschung. Schade, dass du das nicht länger mit uns ausgehalten hast. Ich find's wirklich schlimm, dass ich jetzt den Rest meines Lebens ohne seinen Einfluss bestreiten muss. Ich fand ihn immer sehr herausfordernd.
Was ich halt ein bisschen für ihn schade finde, ist, dass er nicht so wenigstens als kranker Mann sagt, okay, Jungs, hier beim Arbeiten klappt nicht mehr, das von zu Hause beobachtet und ab und zu mal so Statements abgibt. Und dass er halt auch nicht, sagen wir mal, bei einem Autounfall so zack, boom, returntot ist, sondern dass er wirklich irgendwie die letzten Jahre, wie lange es auch immer gedauert hat, bis es abwärts ging, dass er weiß, ich hab hier die große Firma im Staat, hab noch irgendwie iPhone 5, 6, 7 und weiß ich nicht, was für Geräte noch im Kopf und er kann es nicht mehr umsetzen und weiß, schaff ich alles nicht mehr. Ich glaub, das hat ihn bestimmt auch am meisten geärgert. Der hat bestimmt noch ein paar Sachen im Hut.
Ich glaube auch, dass er nicht gern gestorben ist.
Voss meinte, er wäre wohl glücklich gestorben.
Aber... Aber woher soll Voss das wissen?
Gut, kommen wir zu den anderen Enttäuschungen. Wir haben eine Sendung voller Enttäuschungen vorbereitet. Die Kindle-Enttäuschung hatten wir schon.
Die Kindle-Kino-Enttäuschung.
Ich würde sagen, kommen wir zur... Welche Enttäuschung wollen wir zuerst nehmen? Die 4S.
Nehmen wir mal die Frische von gestern Abend. Dann kommen wir gleich zum 4S. Übergehen wir uns ja ein und dasselbe.
Die von gestern Abend. Ach so, die Quartals-Enttäuschung.
Genau. Die sind eigentlich die Kursescheiße.
Schwer gebrochen.
Also kaum ist Steve Tod schon.
Oh Gott, ich bin pleite.
Jetzt er ist recht. Erst sind Bitcoins nicht mehr wert.
Das tut weh, 15 Euro und es ist miese.
Oh, ist ja ein harter Katzer.
Ja, guter Zeitpunkt.
Du bist aber so weit oben, weil das ja nicht im Verhältnis zeigen, du musst es so betrachten.
Was macht ihr hier gerade für Sachen?
Aktienkurse angucken.
Ja, in einem Audio-Podcast.
Wenn man diese Woche guckt, dann sinkt er halt ein um 15 Euro. Wenn man aber über zwei Jahre guckt, dann ist es einfach nur ein Mount Everest-Anstieg.
So wie Dennis lacht, während er den Aktienkurs sieht, scheint er Apple-Aktien zu besitzen. Dann kannst du uns ja sponsoren.
Ich meine, es ist erstaunlich so.
Das erste Mal hat Apple es nicht geschafft, die sogenannten Erwartungen der Analysten zu übertreffen. Wohl aber ihre eigenen Ankündigungen, ihre Guidance.
Was ich ja gemacht hab, es gab ja immer den Unterschied zwischen den Profi-Analytikern hier so, von, keine Ahnung, welche Leute das machen, diese morgen Stanley oder diese komischen Buden, die immer diese Voraussahllung machen, die immer daneben liegen. Dann gibt es ja diese privaten, die Blogger, so nennen sie die, diesen Horace Dedio zum Beispiel und noch irgendwie andere. Und dann wollte ich mal gucken, ob die jetzt denn wenigstens richtig lagen und nur diese Profi-Analytiker falsch lagen, aber ich hab da nicht so richtig was gefunden. Eigentlich hieß es immer, dass diese Blogger, dass die immer besser lagen als die Profi-Jungs.
Wie heißt der Vogel, der immer so goldrichtig lag in den letzten Jahren? Nein, nein, nein, der war das nicht.
Ich glaub schon.
Nein, der macht viel Analyse, aber der hat jetzt nicht den Ruf, immer am nächsten dran zu sein. Das ist dieser Chet. Wie heißt dieser Typ, der immer so hervorragend, der auch so aus der Blogger-Analystenecke kommt und der immer...
Das ist unser Serie-Ersatz, der Chet.
Und der ist ein bisschen langsam.
Genau, ich sollte das bei Wolfram Alpha eingeben.
Aber es ist auch in der Cloud.
Der sagt auch.
Nein, das ist nicht der Horus.
Die Deiro hieß er nicht, da ist De-Diu.
Marco Armit.
Ja, ist jetzt auch... Kommt schon noch.
Wie komm ich denn da nicht drauf?
Ich lese Fefer eigentlich nur wegen einer tollen Mac-Berichtestattung.
Das haben wir an der letzten WMR erfunden. Das hat MS-Pro rausgehauen. Ich lese Fefer nur, wenn ich ihn auf der Straßenbahn finde. Wenn er in der Straßenbahn liegt.
Also wir wissen nicht, wie der Typ heißt, aber ich meine, das ist der Horus De-Diu.
Nein, weiß es nicht.
Find da mal raus, wer es ist.
Ja, ich bin ja schon am Suchen.
Was sollen wir jetzt in den Apple-Quartals sein? Die haben unglaublich viele Telefone und irgendwas verkauft.
Ja, wieder alles mehr als beim letzten Mal und so weiter und so fort.
Wobei die iPhone-Zahlen sind besser als im letzten Jahr. Also im Vorjahresquartal. Aber im Vergleich zum letzten Quartal sind sie doch ganz schön.
Ist ja auch klar. War erstens immer so, dass die Suche eines Weihnachtsquartals auch immer höher ist. Und danach geht es wieder bergab, weil Weihnachten verkaufen die Vier und natürlich kurz bevor das iPhone 5, was alle dachten, rauskommt, klar verkaufen die dann weniger Vierer.
Na ja, nun haben aber diverse, also hier John Gruber zum Beispiel war ganz vorne, hat gesagt, das iPhone ist mittlerweile so weit im Mainstream angekommen, die Kunden wissen nicht mal, dass das theoretisch irgendwann nochmal später ein Bestes ist. Es hat sich ja, klar.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass es keiner kauft. Es ist immer noch das meistverkaufte Smartphone.
Das wird doch auch sicherlich nach einer Weile bleiben, oder?
Ja, aber auch nach einem anderthalb Jahr auf dem Markt war es immer noch das sich am besten verkaufende Smartphone in Konkurrenz zu anderen Phones, die unter Umständen brandneu sind und mit dem neuesten Bells and Whistles und Doppelcore und was nicht allem geworben haben.
Und iPads haben sie auch verkaufsfähig mit dem roten Bein?
Ja, eigentlich ist alles super. Ich meine, sie sind jetzt auf...
Außer, dass alle ganz furchtbar enttäuscht sind.
17 Millionen iPhones, das sind 21% mehr als letztes Jahr. 11 Millionen iPads im Quartal.
Wobei, das wird dann wahrscheinlich letztes Jahr schon wirklich... Das wären dann letztes Jahr, wären es schon die iPhone 4 gewesen sein. Und jetzt sind es noch die iPhone 4 gewesen. Das selbe Telefon hat sich nochmal... Zum selben Preis hat sich nochmal dramatisch besser verkauft als vor einem Jahr. Das ist wirklich eigentlich beeindruckend, muss man ja mal sagen.
Richtig, wobei man sagen muss, es ist ja nicht nur das normale iPhone, sondern es ist ja auch das iPhone 3GS.
Also Nextcube verkauft sich auf eBay auch noch für 810 Dollar.
Das gibt welche.
Auf ebay.com kriegst du einen mit Maus und Keyboard für 1399.
Die sind jetzt auch eher noch teurer.
Wahrscheinlich.
Dass die Leute das überhaupt verkaufen.
Auf ebay.de gibt es keine. Und das sind jetzt auch nur drei. Also die einzigen drei, die es gab.
Dann sollten wir uns lieber eine Liza holen.
Ja, ich glaube in Deutschland gibt es auch eine.
Wer mal gucken will, wie das damals so gewesen ist.
Wollen wir jetzt bei den Quartalszahlen oder wollen wir wieder bei Nextcube reden?
Nextcube, nein.
Die Zahl, die ich am interessantesten finde, ist 4,89 Millionen Max. Ich glaube, vor zwei Quartalen kratzten sie so kurz über vier. Jetzt sind sie fast bei fünf. Nächstes Quartal sind sie bei fünf.
Aber locker, das ist Weihnachtsquartal, da geht es ab. Haben sie auch selber gesagt, das nächste Quartal wird Record-Breaking sein.
Ja gut, aber es bezieht sich halt auch auf die... Also wie geht es konkret jetzt um die Max?
Dieses MacBook Air, das muss ich so selbst verkaufen. Da gibt es ja mal wieder bei den MacBook Airs Liefer-Schwierigkeiten. Wann gab es das letzte Mal bei Apple?
Bei Produkten, die schon ein paar Monate draußen sind?
Also es gibt immer noch Liefer-Schwierigkeiten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt noch welche gibt, aber am Anfang gab es ziemlich massive Liefer-Schwierigkeiten. Und es ist ein Laptop. Also es ist jetzt nicht das neue iPhone oder das neue iPad, sondern es ist ein Laptop und die zweite Generation. Also es ist jetzt...
Ja, was sagen sie, bist du hier sofort?
Ja, vor allem das Intel jetzt auch hier anfängt mit dieser...
In Stock alles hier.
Im Chat ist gerade ein RT von Tarnit. Analysten, die von Apples 54% Gewinnsteigerungen enttäuscht sind, schlagen bestimmt auch ihre Kinder, wenn sie eins nach Hause bringen.
Naja, aber ich meine, mit Apple ist jetzt auch jetzt... Man hat irgendwann langsam die positiven News irgendwie...
Satt.
Satt und man will auch mal aufs Maul hauen und dann wird halt alles...
Ja, die warten alle nur drauf, genau.
Das ist jetzt der Grund, warum die Presse so schön immer... Ich meine, wenn jemand dir die Erwartung überfüllt, dann willst du ja klar, dann willst du nicht Fresse hauen.
Ja gut, aber ich frage mich ja was anderes. Ich frage mich ja, was kann man aus diesen Zahlen rauslesen? Außer, dass es jetzt ein Erfolg ist. Und ich finde halt tatsächlich diese MAC-Zahl am interessantesten. Ich meine, bei den iPads entwickelt es sich so, wie es glaube ich seit einiger Zeit auch schon zu erwarten gewesen war. Dieser Markt steigt und Tim Cook hat ja auch selber gesagt, da wäre ja noch mehr zu holen, als sie selbst geglaubt hätten. Da frage ich mich, worauf sich, auf welchen Zeitraum sich dieser Kommentar bezieht. Ja, also ob sie noch, was sie noch vor einem Monat gedacht haben, vor einem Quartal gedacht haben oder was sie, bevor sie die Dinger überhaupt in den Handel gebracht haben, gedacht haben. Keine Ahnung, sagt ihr nicht. Tatsache ist, dass mit diesen iPads wird, also sie meinten ja, der Tablettmarkt, haben sie es so formuliert? Tablett? Haben sie das gesagt? Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall dieser Markt.
Wäre größer als der PC-Markt.
Könnte größer sein als der PC-Markt.
Ja, ist schon eine deutliche Ansage.
Ziemlich groß, aber.
Zehn Kilometer Durchmesser oder?
Ich meine da, ich glaube...
In Stückzahlen waren es glaube ich pro Quartal.
Also ich glaube sogar, er hat Recht, dass es größer werden könnte als der PC-Markt. Und der PC-Markt ist ja scheiße groß. Es hört sich erstmal an so, die können nicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 200 Millionen iPads verkaufen. Aber ich denke mal, auf 10, 20 Jahre betrachtet schon. Weil irgendwann desktops gibt's ja eh schon nicht mehr so richtig. Laptops musst du auch irgendwie aufklappen, hinstellen wie auch immer. Aber diese Tablets, die kannst du ja in der Küche, auf dem Klo, im Schlafzimmer, also das kannst du ja überall so ein Ding rumliegen haben. Das wird wahrscheinlich in 20, 30 Jahren rumliegen wie Tageszeitung irgendwo in einer Kneipe. Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, man wird einfach mal sein Tablet dabei haben. Ich glaube, das pro-sch sozusagen. Dass die Durchdringung an Geräten noch höher sein wird als bei PCs. Weil willst du da in einem Café, an einem fremden iPad rumkrabbeln?
Ey, du, die Leute schieben heute ihre Zeug in die Cloud, wo sie nicht wissen, wo das landet. Dann werden die auch irgendwann sich auf so einem Tablet irgendwie mit so einem Barcode, den sie irgendwie an sich dran haben, wie auch immer, irgendwie ihr Profil auf das Ding automatisch laden und legen dann los. Und wenn sie gehen, melden sie sich ab oder wie auch immer und das Ding ist wieder leer. Und dann wird den Leuten erzählt, da ist halt ein OS drauf, wo halt alles gelöscht wird, wenn du dich wieder abmeldest oder wie auch immer. Oder du siehst es halt. Keine Ahnung. Also ich denke, die Leute interessiert das doch eh alle nicht. Oder wenn du nur surfen willst und ein bisschen chatten willst, ist dir das da auch alles Schnuppel.
Ich glaube, die Leute werden ihr persönliches Gerät dabei haben.
Tablets, die vom Bundestag verwendet werden, Laptops nicht?
Ja, das gab doch. Da gab es doch so einen kleinen... War das jetzt schon wieder? Da gab es irgendwann mal so einen kleinen Aufstand als... Ich glaube, das war einer von der FDP, der sein Manuskript quasi bei der Bundestagsrede vom iPad abgelesen hat. Und Laptops sind ja verboten im Hohen Haus. WLAN gibt es ja auch nicht.
WLAN gibt es auch nicht?
Nee, da gibt es keinen WLAN. Also gab es zumindest, als ich da mal...
Ich kann das schon verstehen. Du willst nicht... Das hatten wir ja im Club hier im Plenum auch. Laptopverbot. Also hatten wir mal früher, dass die Leute nicht die ganze Zeit dann nur irgendwie tippern und texten und gar nicht...
Ja, so tippern sie halt alle auf ihren iPhones rum.
Ja, aber da wirst du jetzt nicht so stundenlang Texte schreiben oder so. Also es ist schon...
Also ich hab da oben drinnen gesessen, wie die da alle ihren Blackberries sitzen.
Ob die nun Zeitung lesen oder in ihrem Gerät da rumsurfen, das ist dann auch egal. Wenn einer so rumtippt, das nervt dann eventuell schon.
Ja, aber WLAN könnten sie ja schon mal hinmachen.
Ja klar.
Also das wär schon heutzutage, finde ich das angemessen. Bundes-WLAN.
Jetzt machen alle GSM da durch, richtig?
Ja klar.
Ja, die haben eh alle bestimmt so einen Standardvertrag über, ja, for free bestimmt, die Scheiße.
Oh, glaub ich nicht.
Na ja, wenn schon Journalisten kriegen, doch alle so for free Verträge.
Ich glaub, wenn du nicht nachfragst, dann kannst du es haben, aber es gibt ja noch so, meine Freundin, die arbeitet bei einer Bundestagsabgeordneten und die müssen höllisch drauf achten, um Himmels willen keine Geschenke von irgendjemandem anzunehmen. Weil es ist ja dann bis hier mal sofort bestechlich und so was.
Aber dürfen erste Klasse fliegen bei Air Berlin?
For free, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kriegen einen Auto-Upgrade auf die erste.
Also ich glaub, wenn man sagt, ja, ich hätte das gern, dann kriegt man garantiert einen kostenlosen Telefonvertrag, aber ich glaub, dass das viele auch einfach nicht machen.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier Worldwide PC Shipments, Top 5 Wenders mal hochrechne, 2. Quartal, 11 pro Quartal 84 Millionen Boxen. Pro Quartal.
84 Millionen, ok.
Gesamter PC-Markt weltweit 84 Millionen Geräte.
Pro Quartal.
Und das iPad hat jetzt 11 Millionen?
11 Millionen pro Quartal. Der Tabletmarkt ist natürlich insgesamt noch kleiner, also es hat noch nicht so diese Durchdringung. Durchaus vorstellbar, dass einerseits diese Zahl hier noch sinkt, mit diesen PCs, weil ich glaube einfach für viele Leute ist ein PC jetzt nicht mehr so interessant.
Wobei ich gehe mal nicht davon aus, dass Tim Cook jetzt die Zahlen von irgendwie in fünf Jahren im PC-Markt meint, dass der Tabletmarkt irgendwann mal den PC-Markt überholen könnte quasi, sondern schon so groß wie PC-Markt jetzt oder vielleicht sogar zu seinen besten Zeiten so groß schätzen wir den Tabletmarkt ein.
Ich glaube, die schätzen ihn größer ein.
Oder größer. Also auf jeden Fall nehmen die nicht als Vergleichszahl jetzt irgendwie einen schlechten Wert von in fünf Jahren ran.
Nee, nee, klar. Aber was weiß ich, mit was für Zahlen, die da intern arbeiten, die schauen da bestimmt ganz anders in die Zukunft, als wir das so machen. Also nicht so nachhaltig und so. Die so gut informiert.
Meinst du, die sind noch besser informierter als wir?
Ach, die sitzen doch da die ganze Zeit nur an Bord und hören Podcasts und dann gehen sie raus auf die Bühne.
Und es gibt jetzt eine Viertelmilliarde IOS-Devices, die verkauft wurden.
Die Zahlen haben sie genannt?
Nö, wo war da was? 250 Millionen.
Also das iPhone 4S war echt eine Enttäuschung, das muss man mal sagen.
Ja, kommen wir zu den weiteren Enttäuschungen, nachdem die Quartalszahlen schon so niederschmetternd waren. Die iPhone 4S-Enttäuschung scheint auch sehr nachhaltig zu sein. Also die Leute haben geradezu aus Protest das Gerät gekauft.
Ich hab mir ja keins geholt, weil es war mir ja zu schlecht.
War dir zu schlecht? Weil du halt so die Zielgruppe bist, die der Meinung ist, für sie wär's ja nix.
Nee, weil das iPhone 4 schon so geil ist.
Siehst du, Google macht das besser. Bei Google ist das immer so, wenn es eine neue Android-Version gibt, dann gibt es die immer nur für die neuesten Telefone. Upgrade gibt es da nicht.
Unsere Hörer erwarten natürlich jetzt, dass wir ein informiertes Statement abgeben. Deswegen haben wir uns auch zwei Experten eingeladen. Huckel hat ein iPhone 4S schon mal kurz ausprobiert.
Ganz so Experte bin ich nicht.
Max Vater hat ein iPhone 4S. Von daher hören wir jetzt. Was ist dran an der Enttäuschung? Enttäuscht warst du denn, als du es in der Hand gehabt hast?
Na, erstmal war natürlich die Enttäuschung insofern gegeben, als dass ich das ja überhaupt gar nicht realisiert hatte, dass es nicht bei meinem iPhone 4S handelte, denn es sieht ja erstmal auf dem ersten Blick genauso aus wie bei meinem iPhone 4.
Man sieht doch den Unterschied.
Moment, also so von mal vorbeigehen, habe ich halt den Kollegen mit diesem Telefon in der Hand gesehen und der hatte halt auch vorher schon vier und deswegen war mir das nicht so beklagend. Aber dann habe ich so realisiert, so im Laufe des Arbeitstages kamen und kamen immer mal wieder so ein Ding Ding und dann hat er irgendwie so komisch gestellte Sätze formuliert und irgendwie dann hat er wieder Ding Ding gemacht und irgendwie kam so eine gestellte Frauenstimme zurück oder so. Ich glaube in Deutsch ist es ja glaube ich sogar eine Frauenstimme. Und dann war mir klar, alter Schwede, der Kollege hat jetzt schon einen 4S, das war auch der erste in der Firma. Der Ole Begemann ist auch glaube ich ein Twitter-Bekannter oder Blogosphären-Bekannter iOS-Developer. Naja und dann habe ich es natürlich auch mal in die Hand nehmen dürfen.
Das war schon ein ganz besonderer Moment.
Und dann habe ich mit Siri eine SMS an einen weiteren Kollegen verschickt und habe zum Diktat gesagt, ich hab dich lieb und habe es einem anderen Kollegen in seinem Namen geschickt. Das hat auch wunderbar funktioniert.
Du meinst, er hatte dich dann auch lieb?
Ach, was weiß ich, das hat er auf jeden Fall. Der kam rein, der Kollege meinte, was schreibst du mir denn für eine SMS? Nein, aber dann haben wir natürlich ein bisschen rumprobiert. Also das mit dem SMS enden, das ging straight forward. Da musste man sich auch gar nicht...
Was hast du denn gesagt?
Irgendwie Schicke Christoph Hänselmann... Oh, ist der Name... Können wir das mal kurz rausholen? Schicke Christoph Fuber, eine SMS.
Wir benutzen die Macht. Ihr habt diesen Namen nicht gehört.
Genau, Schicke Christoph Fuber, eine SMS. Und dann hat er irgendwie gesagt, ding ding, ja, hier SMS. Und jetzt sag mal deinen Text. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ich hab dich lieb. War jetzt auch nicht sonderlich komplex, aber... Kam dann halt so straight rein. Dann hat er gesagt, jutt, hab ich. Und dann hab ich gesagt, senden. Und dann hat er das nochmal bestätigt. Und schwuppdiwupp, Kartoffelsupp, war's draußen. Sag jetzt nicht, ob er das mit SMS oder iMessage versendet, aber es kam halt auf jeden Fall an. Und dann haben wir halt so ein bisschen noch rumprobiert. Und halt... Also es ist jetzt nicht so wie damals, so mit Open My Browser und Open My Mail, wo man wirklich so 23 mal probieren musste, bis man dann die Tonlage und den Tonfall getroffen hatte, damit es dann Voice-Control schnallt und so. Aber so bestimmte... Also man muss schon sehr Hochdeutsch sprechen, damit es funktioniert. Also so ein bisschen...
Wie...
Was hat er gefragt? Wie warm ist es draußen? Hat halt einer gefragt. Ja, ist es so? Und dann ging es halt nicht. Und dann muss man sagen, wie warm ist es draußen? Also man muss schon ein bisschen deutlich und Hochdeutsch sprechen, aber dann klappt es eigentlich auch in der Regel ganz gut. Und dann haben auch so ein paar reported, dass bei bestimmten Sachen, so Kalender oder so war es glaube ich, dass da sind so die Formulierungen, in welcher Reihenfolge da die Wörter reinprasseln, schon auch wichtig. Und das war dann auch so. Also auch so Zeitformen. Also man hat so das Gefühl mit Deutsch und dann so diesen grammatikalischen Spezialfällen und so weiter, da geht nicht alles. Also man muss es schon irgendwie noch so ein bisschen simpel halten.
Also man hat immer noch das Gefühl, man redet mit Idioten.
Naja, nicht ganz. Also wie gesagt, dieses SMS verschicken, das war schon wirklich ziemlich gut. Aber so mit Kalender zum Beispiel interagieren, das war wiederum so ein bisschen... Aber das war ja auch schon vorher zu lesen. Also das haben ja auch schon ein paar andere gesagt. Aber so wenn du halt so ein paar Fragen hier und da stellst und einfach drauf loslegst oder diktierst, also das ist schon erstaunlich gut gewesen.
Also für Diktieren würde ich... Also das sehe ich auch für mich als eine mögliche Anwendung. Aber I'm not running out of the house now.
Ich finde es krass, was diese Serie schon innerhalb von so kurzer Zeit geschafft hat, quasi an Mindshare zu gewinnen. Kultstatus oder wie auch immer man das jetzt nennen will. Also ich glaube, das wird so ein extremer Running Gag bei irgendwelchen Comedy-Serien und Summzeug werden.
Naja oder hier diese iPhone-Auto-Korrektur-Sammelseiten die kriegen, dann wird es gleich ganz viele Audio-Samples wahrscheinlich.
Na, die gibt es doch jetzt. Shit Series says, dieses Tumblr-Blog hier. Und bei uns im Büro war das so, da hat irgendjemand, ich weiß gar nicht wer, ich hab dann aus Knatz, weil meins noch nicht da ist, bin ich auch nicht hingegangen. Aber das war den halben Nachmittag lang, hörte man irgendwie so, man hörte dieses Ding Ding, dann so eine Männerstimme, die irgendwas sagt, das war zu weit weg, um dass man es verstehen konnte. Und dann hat man diese Frauenstimme Antworten gehört, dann so, hü hü, das ist eine Männerrunde, die gelacht hatten, das ging so in den halben Nachmittag. Also die haben da auch offensichtlich einige dieser diversen Sprüche ausprobiert.
Ach, es gibt sirisagt.de auch noch als deutsche Variante oder was? Tim, das musst du dann in die Show-Notes aber mit reinkun.
Bestimmt, jetzt gerade gekauft und die Seite jetzt erst aufgesucht.
Sirisagt, was?
Na, das ist jetzt sozusagen das deutsche Pendant zu diesem Tumblr-Blog, was es sozusagen für Easter eggs.
Auf Tumblr auch, oder was?
Nee, sirisagt.de da.
Aber auf Deutsch wirkt das irgendwie nicht so, ne?
Ich liebe dich, ich schwebe vor dir.
Das wird genauso auf Englisch, also es ist genau dasselbe wie auf Englisch.
Ja, und mein Vater, der ist...
Die zweite Expertenmeinung.
Der hat sich zum Geburtstag ein iPhone gewünscht. Ich hab ihm gesagt, er hatte Anfang September Geburtstag. Ich hab gesagt, hol jetzt noch keins, warte lieber noch. Darum haben wir auch keins vorher besorgt. Und dann ist es prompt Freitag auch gekommen. Also hat er echt, obwohl er erst nachmittags bestellt hat. Und der ist hellauf begeistert. Also er hat auch erst mal angefangen zu diktieren. Er hat mir wahrscheinlich die erste SMS damit oder iMessage, die er mir geschickt hat. Und die kann man auch lesen. Es ist mir nur daran aufgefallen, dass er vergessen hat, Satzzeichen anzusagen. Weil das muss man offensichtlich schon tun, so Ausrufezeichen und Fragezeichen hinten dran sagen. Und er meinte, es wäre in vielen Situationen einfach genial. Was für meinen Vater eine Aussage ist, die er so nicht allzu oft tätigt. Aber es wäre auch extrem frustrierend manchmal. Siri, call me an ambulance. Die deutsche Siri hat wesentlich weniger Humor. Ja, irgendwie hab ich auch so das Gefühl, dass die Witze nicht ganz so gut kommt.
Das ist ja dann auch auf Deutsch.
Da wirkt es halt nicht so.
Da hat man auch weniger Humor zu haben. Aber hier in Deutschland gibt es einfach Humor.
Das ist hier verboten von Computern.
Aber hier bei Siri gibt es zum Beispiel ein Beispiel Fischers Fritz fischt frische Fische und so weiter und so fort. Das scheint auch zu verstehen und antwortet auch mit einem anderen Zungenbrecher. Die Spracherkennung ist schon an sich ziemlich gut. Nur eben wenn man halt so mit Kalender und irgendwelchen Dialogen, also irgendwelchen Modus wechseln und so interagierst, da wird es dann so ein bisschen hackelig. Aber so Text aufnehmen scheint echt ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Die Frage ist, ob es diesen Vertrauenslevel durchschreitet, dass man wirklich sagt, okay, so jetzt arbeite ich nur noch damit.
Ja, Alter, bestell mir eine Pizza.
Das ist mein bevorzugtes Kommunikationsmännchen. Ich hab mir eine Menge Podcasts und Gespräche zu dem Thema Siri so angehört und fand so ein paar Einschätzungen ganz interessant. Wobei ich jetzt mir erstmal eine eigene Meinung bilden muss und noch keine Gelegenheit hatte, das zu tun. Aber es ist natürlich schon so, wenn man sich mal genau anschaut, was es ist, diese Idee, dieses Personal Assistant oder wie auch immer man das so nennen möchte, man lässt, man redet mit dem Computer, um Dinge zu suchen. Und man redet mit dem Computer, um Dinge zu veranlassen etc. Das heißt, theoretisch besteht hier die Chance für Apple, wenn es ihnen gelingt, das wirklich auf eine Art zum Spielen zu bringen, dass die Leute das auch akzeptieren, dass sie es vermissen, wenn es nicht da ist etc. Die Alternative ist, ins Google Fenster eingeben. Also derzeit ist für die Leute das Internet Google. Und wenn das Internet Siri ist für sie, dann...
Also das Fenster zum Internet, Siri ist das Fenster zum Netz.
Genau, beziehungsweise einfach Netz oder wie man es auch immer so zu allem. Das ist quasi das bevorzugte Interface, was sie so verwenden wollen. Und das wäre natürlich eine echt interessante Implikation. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das wird stattfinden oder dass das ist irgendwie sicher, aber diese Rolle spielt das Teil natürlich an der Stelle, so wie es auch platziert ist. Es ist so dieser primäre Einstieg in dein Telefon. Und das Telefon hat natürlich gegenüber einem normalen Computer irre Vorteile, weil es einfach viel mehr über dich weiß. Also es weiß viel mehr über deinen Kontext. Es weiß, wo du bist.
Na und ich hab's wirklich immer dabei.
Ja, es hat Sensoren. Es weiß, ob du es gerade ans Ohr hältst oder nicht. Und ist es nicht sogar so, dass das Siri sich automatisch aktiviert, wenn du einfach das Telefon nur ans Ohr nimmst?
Nee, ich glaube, das ist einfach, dass es dann leise spricht. Also es ist halt dann so ein Telefonmodus.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Also wenn du es liegen hast, dann labert es über den Lautsprecher, wenn du es ans Ohr hältst, labert es über den, also da an.
Ja gut, aber du musst dann erst eine Tastedruckung zu aktivieren.
Ich glaube schon.
Und aktiviert es sich nicht automatisch, wenn du es ans Ohr nimmst?
Ich glaube, wenn es in diesem Modus ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wenn es in diesem Modus ist quasi.
Home einmal und ans Ohr.
Genau. Und ansonsten musst du halt auf diese Mikrofon-Taste da unten, auf diese Siri-Taste nochmal drücken, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Siri, Siri, Siri.
Beim nächsten Mal bringe ich hoffentlich mein iPhone 4S mit und dann können wir es alle gerne ausprobieren.
Ja, also ich meine, ich mach ja auch hier mit meinem Alfred ab. Und so mach ich ja auch immer so Sachen wie hier, sag mir mal, weiß nicht, irgendwie 15 Gigabit per second over 24 hours at 29 cents per Gigabyte. Und dann sagt halt mir Wolfram Alpha, eins, zwei, fix, was ich da so berechnet haben wollte. Wenn sowas zum Beispiel auch mit Siri geht, das könnte ich mir auch ganz gut vorstellen.
Da im Englischen schon zu gehen.
Ja, eben, ne, also genau. Aber eigentlich gibt es ja auch keinen Grund, warum es dann nicht irgendwann auf dem Markt funktionieren sollte. So statt Spotlight einfach so, bing, open my...
Ich bin nicht mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Ihr wisst ja, dass Siri so eine Auskopplung ist von so einem künstlichen Intelligenzladen.
Ja, die haben sie gekauft.
Die ist selber nicht als Intelligenz bezeichnet im Übrigen.
Nicht?
Ja, es gab da so ein längeres Posting von dem Typen, der ursprünglich mal diese AI, entschuldigung, der ursprünglich die iPhone abentwickelt hat, der aber nicht mit zu Apple gegangen ist, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Und ja, der hat da so lange erzählt, wie so ihr Ansatz gewesen ist, um was hier so verschiedene Entwicklungsstufen durchgegangen sind und dass sie dann selber sehr überrascht waren, welchen Erfolg sie mit ihrer Applikation hatten. Und...
Die haben wahrscheinlich das Potential immer wieder nicht erkannt, oder?
Ich meine, die haben es entwickelt, also von daher haben sie schon die richtige Idee.
Na, wenn er meint, er hat nicht gedacht, wie gut es so ankommt.
Aber Xerox hat halt auch irgendwie die Maus und war doch immer entwickelt.
Das Beispiel war in dem Moment, dass Walt Mossberg es als The Next Cool Shit bezeichnet hat. Damit haben sie jetzt nicht unbedingt gerechnet. Na ja, gut so. So kam es in gewisser Hinsicht auch.
Aber diese Siri ist doch, ich hab da ein bisschen letztens was gelesen, dass es ein US, ja, keine Ahnung, Unternehmen nicht, aber so eine Gruppe gibt, die SRI heißt.
Genau. Die haben da eine Firma ausgegründet.
Sie haben da Buchstaben dran gehängt, nämlich das i, wie das Typische.
Also wie sie halt SRI so meinen zu sprechen.
Und das ist ja auch, da stand auch wieder was von DARPA, also dass die halt da ordentlich Kohle reinschieben und an künstlicher Intelligenz forschen. Dass das SRI auch irgendwie weltweit der größte Laden ist, der sich da um künstliche Intelligenz kümmert. Und dann wollen sie mir sagen, in diesem SRI ist keine KI drin?
Nee, wahrscheinlich sitzt da ein Data Center voll mit...
Ja, weil sie es... weil sie... also er schrieb, dass sie es nicht als KI bezeichnen, in dem Sinne, oder auch nicht als KI sehen, sondern die eigentliche, er hat da eine Formulierung, benutze ich jetzt nicht genau erinnere, aber im Wesentlichen ist es so, die Kunst liegt da drin, den Kontext zu erfassen.
Kontext-aware oder so, ne?
Ja, ich kann es auch gerne noch mal rausnommen, ich fände jetzt irgendwie den Link nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist das quasi die wesentliche Arbeit, diesen Kontext zu verfeinern etc. Klar, das kann man jetzt künstliche Intelligenz nennen, kannst du nennen, wie du willst. Ich sage nur, sie haben es selber nicht so genannt.
Die Frage ist zum Beispiel, ob jetzt Siri, weil es wird ja schon alles hochgeladen, auch richtig. Also das iPhone beantwortet ja nicht von selbst das Wetter.
Genau, ich denke die Tokenisierung, die findet halt auf dem Telefon statt. Bis zu einem bestimmten Grad, weiß ich nicht, wie weit. Und das schicken sie dann halt zur eigentlichen semantischen Analyse dahin. Das bedeutet wiederum auch, dass ein kompletter Dialog und deine komplette Kontexte somit... Ja, du sagst irgendwie, schreib eine SMS an meine Schwester. So, dann musst du schon mal wissen, wer die Schwester ist.
Das haben wir ja schon gelernt. Wenn du das nicht weißt, dann fragt er dich.
Ja genau, aber er merkt es sich dann halt auch. Und er merkt es halt nicht auf dem Telefon, sondern er merkt es halt auf deinem...
Wobei, das könnte er sich auch auf dem Telefon merken.
Auf dem NSA-Rechner.
Das könnte er sich da merken.
Naja, ich meine, er könnte...
Er merkt es sich aber dann nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Doch, der Witz ist bei Siri, dass das halt diese gesamte Kontextualität... Also diese gesamte... Siri funktioniert nicht ohne Internet.
Jaja, das weiß ich. Aber ich meine, du könntest jetzt sagen, alles klar, Call, also was kommt zurück an das Telefon? Du schickst eine Audiodatei oder eben ein umgearbeiteter Audiodatei hoch auf deren Server, da wird dann die Spracherkennung gemacht. Es wird gesagt, alles klar, es geht um ein Telefonat mit einer Schwester. Und dann könnte er das wieder zurückgeben. Also entweder er guckt da direkt in der Datenbank nach. Er könnte es da in der Datenbank nachgucken. Aha, ich weiß, wer seine Schwester ist. Oder er schickt die Information wieder ans Telefon zurück und sagt, ruf mal seine Schwester an. Und das Telefon guckt dann selbstständig im Adressbuch nach, wer denn die Schwester ist.
Also der Chat meint, das ergänzt sogar das Adressbuch. So oder so, diese Information liegt halt in der Wolke. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass er die Audiodatei hochlädt. Das würde zu lange dauern.
Na ja, es wird irgendwie eine Komprimierung davon sein, eine extrem starke oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist einfach die reine phonetische...
Zwei, drei Sekunden bei wenig Kilobit, das ist doch in 0, X hochgeladen.
Ja, aber eine phonetische Analyse kannst du in 0, X... Auf so einem Telefon ist Pipifax. Ich meine, das gibt es schon seit Langem und das ist nicht so das Ding. Das heißt, du kannst es in deine eigene phonetische Sprache überführen. Was für Worte das dann sind, das überlässt du dann der Cloud. Aber du tust die Dinge, die du schnell machen kannst und die dir halt auch noch Zeit in der Kommunikation sparen. Klar, wenn du 3G hast und alles ist super, logisch. Aber was ist, wenn du da mit GPRS rumhängst?
Dann würdest du mal ausprobieren.
Dann würdest du nicht 50 Kilobyte hochladen.
Das sind keine 50 Kilobyte.
Ja, was denn sonst?
2-3 Sekunden Audio von Sprachbereich, das ist doch nix.
Ja, das geht doch.
Also in 2-3 Sekunden, das ist fast schon lange.
Was du da sagst, ist doch... Es sind fast mehrere Kilobyte.
Ja, aber das haben wir bisher über GSM auch übertragen. Das muss ja eher eine schlechtere Qualität als bei GSM sein.
GSM ist aber auch an der Stelle dann Lossi und...
Also ich vermute ja ehrlich gesagt auch, dass sie ja so ein bisschen Foyer-Transformations-Foo machen und dann schon irgendwelche Waveforms und so in... Also in so einem anderen Format darüber schicken.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber...
Ja, hier kommt so der Hinweis, Diktieren würde dann auch offline gehen, geht aber nicht. Nee, das stimmt nicht, weil ich mal sage ja, also eine phonetische Aufspaltung, also so eine Vorbearbeitung und dann die Auswertung, was das bedeutet. Das sind zwei Sachen. Das eine ist, du hast einfach Klang-Silben und dann musst du eben versuchen, rauszukriegen, was könnte das jetzt bedeuten? Und dann legt sich Siria auch mehrere Varianten zurecht. Also es gibt dann so vielleicht acht verschiedene Bedeutungen, die so es sein könnten. Und dann wird das eben gewichtet, je nachdem, was der Kontext dieses Users so meint, was vorher gesagt wurde, was die sonstigen Daten darüber denken.
Naja, wir werden es wahrscheinlich noch irgendwann genau rauskriegen. Es gibt ja schon jemanden, der hat Siria schon auf dem iPhone 4 nachgerüstet. Also per Jailbike freigeschaltet. Aber es funktioniert dann natürlich an sich nicht.
Das habe ich auch schon gelesen. Mehr oder weniger funktioniert da gar nichts. Außer, dass die App startet.
Genau, und dann können die Daten halt nicht zu Apple, die können zu Apple geschickt werden, aber werden halt von Apple nicht verarbeitet, weil falsches Telefon.
Interessant ist jetzt zu sehen, ob irgendwie die Siris demnächst durch das Ganze hochladen, ob die jetzt da ordentlich ihre Datenbank irgendwie anlernen, also ob Siri schlauer wird allein durch die Nutzung, also ob die schon noch was dahinter haben, was irgendwie auch sich jetzt Auto-Learning macht oder Maschinen-Learning.
Die kriegen auf jeden Fall genug Inputs aus.
Aber ob die jetzt, sie haben ja gesagt, dass Siri quasi eine Beta wäre bisher, dachte ich jetzt, wird wahrscheinlich ein iOS-Update irgendwann mal kommen, aber das brauchen sie eigentlich wahrscheinlich gar nicht, sondern das wird wahrscheinlich so laufen, dass oben irgendwo bei Apple die neue Siri-Version installiert wird und wir kriegen das gar nicht mit. Wahrscheinlich wird da das Backend sowieso jeden Tag dran rumgeschraubt.
Ja, da ist viel Lernen und Verbesserung gesagt.
Ja und bei Millionen von Leuten, da kannst du auch richtig was machen.
Das Datacenter war also nur für Siri.
Ja, kann sein, es ist nicht nur, es ist für alles. Es ist halt the cloud. The truth is in the cloud.
Bis der Blitzer entschlägt.
Genau. Ja, also eine totale Enttäuschung kann man auf jeden Fall zusammenfassen. Das will niemand haben und ich finde die 4 Millionen...
Auch die bessere Kamera interessiert eigentlich keine Laune.
Die 4 Millionen kann man eigentlich ignorieren. Das sind alles Fehlgeleitete, die kaufen es auch nur wegen Steve.
Ja, und weil das Logo drauf ist.
Das hat tatsächlich irgendeine Analystin herausgehauen, dass das iPhone 4S total scheiße wäre und dass das alle nur aus Trauer kaufen. Ja, das ist 4 Millionen mal.
So groß ist die Trauer.
Und ihr habt noch keins bestellt, ja? Wer sind hier die Apple-Fanboys?
Mein Telekom-Berater war noch nicht am Start. Ich wollte ihn ja fragen. Meine Mama will nämlich meinen 4er haben und würde mir das Upgrade zum 4S sozusagen finanzieren.
Das heißt, du kannst das gar nicht machen, weil du noch, vielleicht gibst du mir die Nummer von deiner Mama, ich bin vielleicht schneller als du.
Frag Siri.
Das wär's, dann kann Siri, weil Huckel ja auch da connected ist, haben die vielleicht noch keine Firewall zwischen den Adressbüchern und dann holt er die einfach.
Bestimmt.
Und dann sagt Siri, darfst du dauernd nicht, Huckel ist doch ein Freund von mir, jetzt gib mal. Und dann guckt er so bei mir nach Tatsache.
Siri, ich mache dir ein Angebot, dass du mich ausschlagen kannst.
So, ich hab hier noch einen kleinen Anwurf.
Work.
Eleven.
Come, I don't understand.
Work.
Aber sie hat länger an dir.
Ist noch nicht so richtig an Japaner angepasst, ne?
Tja, aber es wird nicht so wie mit diesem Fahrstuhl, da muss...
Eleven. Nein.
Echt nicht?
Das ist so großartig. Zwei Schotten im Fahrstuhl, das hatte ich vorhin bei NSFW.
Aber das können die Schotten nicht mit Eleven aussprechen? Die können kein Englisch.
Soll ich das zur allgemeinen Belustigung noch mal einspielen? Das ist wirklich großartig. Das gönnen wir uns jetzt mal. Ein bisschen Spaß muss ja auch sein bei all der Enttäuschung.
Voice Recognition Technologie?
In der Lüfte?
In Schottland? Habt ihr noch Voice Recognition Technologie probiert?
Welche Idee ist das?
Eleven!
Das ist irisch, nicht amerikanisch.
In Dublin?
Ein englischer Akzent probieren.
Eleven!
Du bist für die gleiche englische Partie wie Dick Van Dyke.
Wenn Sie nicht die Lingo verstehen, ist das eine Weile zurück in deinem Land.
Ist das eine Weile zurück in deinem Land?
Oh, nicht starten, Mr. Bleedinger.
Eleven! Sie sagen es nur die selbe Weile. Sie sagen es immer, bis sie es verstehen. Eleven!
Gibst du ein Video auch für die alte Speech Recognition von Apple?
Ja, aber für Siri wird es das bestimmt bald geben.
Ja, ja, jede Bitte.
So eine Lernenvariante.
Na, er war ja jetzt schon fast mit Walk.
I don't understand fuck.
Hast du jetzt gerade mit dem schottischen Akzent ausgesprochen?
So ein bisschen, ja. Ich würde nicht behaupten, dass ich schottischen Akzent kenne, aber ich find die total lustig.
Schottisch, genau so.
Das war noch nicht so falsch.
Eleven.
Ja eben.
Na, dass sie die ganze Zeit mit schottischem Akzent sprechen.
Ich hab es 11 noch nicht.
Eleven.
Na ja gut, haben wir ein bisschen gelacht. Muss ja auch mal sein. Bei all der Enttäuschung. Kommen wir zur nächsten Enttäuschung. Die Lion und iOS 5 Enttäuschung.
Das Tal der Tränen heißt die Sendung.
Ja, das Tal der Tränen, genau.
Geht nur noch abwärts jetzt. It's downhill from here.
Also entweder die Sendung heißt Tal der Tränen oder Verkaufen.
Das schließt sich ja nicht an. Ja, also ich muss sagen, das geilste Mac OS X Update ever ist nur der Bart. Also da werd ich noch lange in meinen Sessel weinweinen.
Also wenn wir Glück haben, kommt da noch ein Schnee-Leo.
Das war's einfach.
Ein Schnee-Tiger.
Schnee-Leon.
Schnee-Löwe.
Schnee-Löwe, ja.
Snow-Lion. Snow-Lion.
Schön, warum heißt der Löwe eigentlich Leo, wenn es doch den Leopard gibt? Ist ja blöd. Aber der wird auch Leo genannt, oder? Der Löwe? Okay, also den Schnee-Lion, so ja, Snow-Lion. Das wär noch was. Also Snow Leopard war schon irgendwie cool.
Ja, da waren keine neuen Features drin.
Klar waren da neue Features drin.
Ja, aber sie haben nicht behauptet, also es waren halt richtige Features, weil sie nicht behauptet haben, es wären nicht die Features.
Ja, ich glaub, die wollten nur mal ein bisschen gegen Vista anschränken.
Also ich bin jetzt zum Beispiel noch nicht auf iCloud migriert. Weil ich einfach Angst habe und die schien auch berechtigt zu sein, weil es mir zwischendurch mal partiell passiert ist, so ein bisschen in Richtung iCloud zu gehen. Auf jeden Fall hat dieses Gerät auf einmal angefangen, alle meine Synkereien mit, also Adressbuch und Kalender war dann auf einmal mit iCloud gesynkt.
Ja, aber der fragt da gleich mal nach dem Buten. Wir reden jetzt von 10.7.2 übrigens, um den geneigten River nochmal.
Ja, wir reden von 10.7.2 und ich kann ja ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, wie es auf meinem Mac zu diesem Setting kommen konnte so recht, weil ich eigentlich nur, jetzt muss ich gerade mal nachdenken, also ich hab mir schon iCloud schon irgendwie aktiviert, aber eben mit diesen ganzen anderen Apps, die eben nur mit iCloud funktionieren. Was weiß ich hier, dieses Find my friends und was war noch das andere?
Schon allein das Aussehen, dieses Schweinchenroser-Leder-Look.
Da musst du mal hier deinen Telefonfarb korrigieren, also bei mir ist da nichts rosa.
Naja, so dieser Farbton, dieses Kunstleder.
Diese Lederscheiße, die können sich schon mal so langsam wieder klemmen, aber naja, anyway.
Können sie nicht machen.
Na, mit Brushed Metal war es auch plötzlich vorbei.
Ja, aber wo sind denn hier eure Freundanfragen? Also, ich hab hier euch, sind wir keine Freunde mehr?
Ich weiß doch, wo du bist.
Nie keine mehr, waren wir schon mal welche?
Nein, noch nicht hier in der Cloud, nicht in der iCloud, ich hab hier gerade mal einen Freund.
Da, sieh mal an!
Mehr als 99 Kilometer entfernt. Und das natürlich, sagen wir mal jetzt, nicht so der Rock.
Schick mal alle Tim Freundschaftsanfragen, da freut er sich.
Auf Deutsch darf man das wahrscheinlich wieder alles nicht benutzen, ne?
Friend my friends?
Keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nicht probiert.
Hab mit Huckel schon ausprobiert.
Parada.
Aber, ja, kann man ja auch mit time limited offer machen quasi.
Genau, das ist voll geil. Kann man sagen, hier so, wir sind ja heute in Disneyland, bis heute Abend darfst du mich finden. Das funktioniert, haben wir schon gemacht, ne?
Also ihr wollt nur, dass ich, also nur bei der Mobemax-Sendung, wo ihr so hier rumsitzt.
Ja, kurz vorher, damit du sehen kannst, wie lange wir noch brauchen.
Ja, das fände ich ja schon ganz gut.
Das kann man mal machen, ja?
Wir haben neulich einen Kollegen überwacht, Per. So, wollen wir noch mit dem Stand-up warten? Oder, ah ja, er ist gerade an der U-Bahn.
Womit warten? Mit dem?
Mit dem Stand-up. Meeting. Meeting, hinstellen, sagen, was man gestern gemacht hat. Machen wir ihn morgen um 10.30 Uhr. Manchmal, äh, und dann haben wir halt überlegt, so, warten wir jetzt noch? Oder dann hat jemand nachgeguckt, äh, wo ist denn Gernot? Ist grad, ist grad.
Und da steht man.
Genau, das ist so.
Damit nicht so lange dauert.
Stand-up, das ist so ein schnelles, kurzes Meeting, wo man nur so ein kurzes Update gibt und darum steht man.
Die stehen ja nicht wirklich.
Doch. Klar.
Doch, manchmal stehen sie.
Bei einem Stand-up steht man. Das ist kein Stand-up.
Das ist doch schon der Name. Hast du das nicht verstanden? Eleven!
Ich dachte, das wäre so symbolisch, dass es nicht so lange dauert.
Na ja, wir können ja mal ein bisschen Freunde sein.
Hier, dann bin ich hier nicht so einsam.
Aber wer schickt dir denn Hersheys? Also ich meine, das ist doch eigentlich die letzte Schokolade des Planeten, die man essen will.
Jura.
Das ist auch amerikanische Kapitalisten-Schokolade, die irgendwie überhaupt nach nichts schmeckt.
Es kommt noch besser, da war Cherry Coke dabei.
Hat das aus Amerika geschickt?
Na das ist so Teil der not safe for work internationale Flavors einsammeln Projektierungen.
Aber können die da nicht was aus der Schweiz schicken?
Ich hab auch Schokolade von der Schweiz.
Moment.
Da gibt er uns ja diese amerikanische Schokolade, Duder.
Das versteht er bestimmt nicht.
Ich muss ja zu dem Siri noch was sagen, ja. Ich glaub, er ist...
Du musst zu Siri noch ne Menge sagen.
Steeves eigentlich sein Traum ist ja... Also, man hat mal gesehen, die Maustaste ist ja mehr oder weniger abgeschafft. Die Tastatur mit dem Touch hat er ja auch abgeschafft. Und ich glaub, er will alle Eingabedinge abschaffen, weil er... also eigentlich will Steeve den Kommunikator bauen, so ein Star Trek.
Ja, aber auch bei Star Trek sitzt man mal am Terminal.
Ja, aber nur so Profis. Alle anderen kriegen so einen Kommunikator.
Aber mit dem Kommunikator haben sie auch noch mit anderen Leuten gesprochen, oder?
Nee, nee, nee.
Aber man hat nie eine Antwort gehört.
Dann sagt er irgendwie, Computer, sag mir mal, jetzt hier die Dichte von irgendwas auf dem Planeten zu der Uhrzeit. Und dann?
Computer, wie wird das Wetter morgen in Miami?
Ja, nee, doch, da gab es schon Antworten. Und vor allen Dingen, manchmal hat er dann, auch so wie bei Siri irgendwie, präzisieren sie, präzisieren mal deine Eingabe hier, was soll denn das? Meintest du vielleicht Bob Drive?
Ja, aber meistens hat die...
Ich verstehe nicht Walk.
Schon, was hätte man mit VHS der Chekhov machen können?
Du hast eine Schalikola von Pepsi.
Ja, ist geil, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist The American Dream, man.
Die kannst du ja aber echt auch in die Vitrine stellen.
Ich trinke die jetzt einfach mal.
So krass.
Ich bin so hardcore.
Wieder back zu Scully, ja?
So, dafür gibt es aber jetzt hier...
Edelstes...
Ja, gib mal gleich.
Du kannst die amerikanische Kapitalistenschokolade essen. Wir sterben.
So, jetzt wird hier auch wieder geschmatzt, wie sich das gehört.
Boah, ist das ein Klopper von Schokolade.
Und geknistert wird auch noch.
Ui, was ist denn da alles drinne, Menschenskinder?
Nüsse.
Die ist ja bedruckt.
Wir schmatzen mal wieder. Haben wir ja schon seit Jahren nicht mehr gemacht. Unsere Hörer stehen ja noch nicht so drauf.
Das ist für die Scheiße.
Eigentlich hätten wir heute mal hier so die ganzen Abend über Whisky trinken müssen und dazu ein bisschen heulen.
Also bei welcher Enttäuschung waren wir jetzt gerade? Lion und iCloud und iOS, ne?
Also dieses 10...
Ja, AOS 5 haben wir noch nicht so richtig.
Die Enttäuschung hat sie noch nicht so richtig.
Wir sind ja noch bei 10.7.2. Also ich muss jetzt sagen, dass ich seit Monaten auf dieses Update gewartet hab, weil zum Beispiel Huckel berichtet hat hier, dass du ja deinen SSH-Ki da retten konntest. Und ich wollte letztens auch mal was retten, bin in dieses Time Machine View gegangen und auf der linken Seite war einfach gar nichts. Und wenn ich rechts irgendwas geklickt hab, dann hat er das Time Machine wieder sofort verlassen und ich war wieder bei der Version, wo ich sowieso die ganze Zeit war. Es hat einfach überhaupt gar nicht funktioniert. Und das ist jetzt mit 10.7.2 besser geworden. Also ganz viele Sachen waren bei Lion einfach mal voll im Arsch. Und 10.7.2 hat echt ne Menge gefixt.
Es gibt da übrigens auch immer noch diese geilen Rospa-Tasten.
Nee, dann kommt hier wieder diese komische Echo- und Leise-Mach-Effekt und so.
Nee, nicht wenn du aufs A drückst. Aber jetzt geht das Teil gerade überhaupt mir an. Hier ist direkt auch derzeit echt der Wurm drin. Ich hab bloß gerade keine Zeit für Debugging. Ahja, hier.
Eigentlich musst du noch...
Das Studio ist gerade in der Line-Konfiguration.
Da müsste so eine Kamera...
Das war bei mir leise.
Ich hab ne Patentidee.
Was denn, Max? Drück ruhig drauf. Wir wollen das gar nicht hören, das dazwischen.
Da müsste ne Kamera, Mikro sein, die sieht, dass man den Mund bewegt, ohne dass er offen ist. Das heißt, man spricht nicht. Das heißt, man kaut und dann blendet er automatisch aus. Das wär's.
Ach, echt krass. Das hab ich noch nicht gewusst.
So ein Knickedetektor sozusagen. So ein Bad Behaviour Masking.
Die mit Pistazie und so, die ist echt super.
Naja, ich kann diesen Eindruck auf jeden Fall bestätigen, dass da ganz viele kleine Bugs und so gefixt wurden. Aber, ich sag das böse Wort, Eikall haben sie nicht gefixt.
Nicht über Kalender.
Doch, über Kalender muss einfach gesprochen werden. Wieso denn nicht?
Das ist ja hier Mobile Kalender.
Naja, aber ich meine, darum geht es doch oder nicht?
Okay, erzähl über Kalender.
So gucke ich dann, wenn du über Android 4 redest, dann freu ich dich.
Dann machst du ja eh.
Nee, Tim freut sich über die Einladung, das verschenkst du dran.
Hast du dieses Problem nicht? Ich meine, bist du mit iCal glücklich? Das ist doch wohl nicht dein Ernst.
Ich benutze die iCal quasi gar nicht.
Aha, benutzt du überhaupt Kalender?
Ja klar, ich benutze den auf dem iPhone. Ich benutze, also da habe ich den VKAL. Dann habe ich hier oben diesen kleinen Menü-Leisten-Kalender, dieses Fantastical. Und das reicht für meine Terminbedürfnisse.
Ich habe mir das Scheiß-Cherry-Cooker erstmal hier auf das T-Shirt gekippt. Die wollte nicht in meinen... Also es schmeckt so schon scheiße.
Also das schon aufs T-Shirt kippen schmeckt scheiße.
Ich habe auch so Geschmackssensoren auf der Brust.
Ich will keine Details.
Aber du kriegst sie trotzdem, genauso wie die Kalender-Diskussion.
Ich habe ja erfrischend viel Tweets und E-Mails bekommen zu dieser ganzen Kalender-Geschichte über die letzte Zeit, über die ich jetzt vor allem, weil ich immer so zickig hab mit dem Thema, hab ich mich ein bisschen zurückgehalten, aber mir wurde viel zugeschickt. Unter anderem sogar auch diverse iOS-Apps, leider nur iOS-Apps, die ernsthaft Änderungen vorgenommen haben, um da mitzuhalten. Bisher ist noch nichts dabei, wo ich sagen würde, ja, Jule, da hab das jetzt mal so richtig gelöst bekommen. Nur eine einzige App hat das Kernproblem verstanden, von dem ich eigentlich geredet habe. Viele Leute schicken, also ich kriege alle zwei Tage, kriege so einen Hinweis auf dieses Setting in iCal, wo man sagen kann, dass wochenweise auch einen Tag weiter scrollen kann. Das ist überhaupt nicht mein Punkt. Klar, jetzt kannst du es auch...
Um zu wissen, was der Punkt ist, hört einfach die letzten vier Folgen.
Und nehmt euch Zeit. Tragt ein paar Termine in eurem Kalender vorher für ein.
Ihr braucht dafür Zeit.
Eine Software, dessen User Interface ich immer noch nicht richtig gelungen finde, die aber zumindest... Warte mal, jetzt lass ich mal kurz hier mal ein bisschen hinterher scrollern. Die zumindest in einem View das hinbekommen hat, die sich auch danach benannt hat, die heißt nämlich einfach Continuous. Kalender ab fürs iPhone, die heißt Continuous. Und da kannst du halt einfach... So hab ich mir das immer gedacht. Du hast ein Monats-View und du scrollst einfach die Wochen wochenweise einfach nach oben und nach unten. Also wirklich easy, peasy. Und du siehst halt hier auch gleich, wo irgendwas belegt ist und so weiter. Ich finde das Hin- und Her-Schalten zwischen den Views finde ich nicht so gelungen. Unten haben sie dann so die Kalender zum An- und Ausklingen. Da muss ich auch noch mal eine Mail schreiben, aber so grundsätzlich tut sich das da was. Es gab auch noch irgendeine andere App.
Roddy hat mir mal deinen Fluchen gehört und hat mir mal seinen Entwurf zugeschickt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn dir zeigen sollte, weil ich habe so ein bisschen Angst davor, dass er... Also er hat zwei Ansichten. Zum einen hat er hier so Tag, ganz groß, dann die Woche ein bisschen kleiner und dann so das ganze Rest... Ich probiere es ja auch für die Hörer zu beschreiben. Und dann so das restliche Zeug dann so ganz klein hinten dran. Ich glaube, dass ist eher so nicht erkennen können. Soll ich es mal ein bisschen heller machen?
Was ist das jetzt? Ein einziger View oder einer von mehreren?
Das ist einer von mehreren und der zweite, der da ist, das ist der Flow-View, wo man hier so mit zwei Fingern, also das ist auch so eine Wochenansicht, man kann so mit zwei Fingern durchscrollen. Das ist jetzt natürlich nach unten noch nicht unendlich und so was, aber das ist so sein Stand bisher.
Genau, so was, wo man auch die Wochenenden erkennen kann und so.
Genau, das hat er mir noch nicht mal zugeschickt.
Wieso schenkt er mir so was nicht?
Ich glaube, er hatte Angst davor, dass du ihm keine Angst haben.
Roddy hat keine Angst vor mir.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung, er hat mir geschrieben so. Ich kann ja noch mal die Mail dazu suchen.
Roddy, du hast doch keine Angst vor mir, oder? Tatsache ist, eigentlich habe ich immer vom Mac geredet und gar nicht von iOS. Ich finde es natürlich auch interessant, dass dann auch versucht wird, unter iOS da eine Antwort zu finden, aber auf Mac tut sich bislang einfach gar nichts.
Sollten wir das Screenshot pasten.
Außer, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz überlegen, wie hieß diese? Ich habe gerade noch eine andere ab. Verdammte Scheiße, wie hieß sie denn? Wie hieß? Auf dem Mac. Die hat es auch probiert. Ich habe mir das jetzt vorher nicht notiert. Ich war jetzt nicht gerüstet für die Kalenderenttäuschung.
Wie kriegt man denn hier mit diesem Link-Kinos mal so einen Screenshot hoch?
Kalender heißt das Ding, glaube ich.
Wenn ich einen Kalender schreibe, dann heißt der Kalimero.
Schreibt mal.
Einen User, was soll ich denn damit?
Kalender oder irgendwie sowas war das.
Nee, da gibt es schon mehr.
Aber einen User, der dich eine Menge Support kostet?
Wie heißt das Ding? Es heißt irgendwie sowas wie ähnliches wie Kalender. Kalimari.
Tja, also, äh, genau, skip, skip, skip. Das kann man dann vielleicht gegen Ende der Sendung werden, du deine Cherry Coke...
Ich fäng fest, ich komm nicht vorwärts.
Genau, wir machen mal weiter mit...
Das war ja quasi Kalendereintäuschung.
Genau, also jetzt haben wir die iOS 5, die nächste Enttäuschung. Ich finde ja iOS 5 eigentlich überraschenderweise doch gar nicht so schlecht. iMessage, top.
iMessage ist super, ne?
Kamera vom Homescreen und es startet auf dem...
Was ist jetzt an iMessage so top?
Macht was es soll.
Ja, macht was es soll.
Gut ist das?
Schon ausprobiert.
Ja, wie?
Na, indem man Nachricht lönet. Nachricht reinschreibt, gucken, ob die beiden Personen ankommt.
Und du siehst ja, ob es iMessage ist oder nicht. Also...
An der Farbe.
Und dass du siehst, ob der andere schreibt oder nicht und so.
Und dass da steht iMessage oder SMS.
Mit mir hast du noch nicht geschrieben.
Ich kenne nicht so viele Leute, die einen Alphorn haben.
Wir haben dir noch keine Freundschaftsfragen geschickt. Wir haben dir noch keine iMessage geschrieben. Langsam solltest du das Thema erkennen.
Ähm, aber es funktioniert. Was auch mir aufgefallen ist, der Homescreen-Kamera-Button, die Kamera geht schneller an Start. Also man kann jetzt tatsächlich mal ein bisschen...
Aber warte mal, woher weiß ich denn jetzt...
Wenn der Send-Button blau ist, ist es iMessage.
Und außerdem steht da, da steht iMessage.
Und erst bist du grün, dann bist du blau.
Und was macht der da in dem Moment?
Ob die Telefonnummer und so?
Hinterlegt das.
Das ist quasi FaceTime.
Genau.
So ähnlicher Mechanismus auf jeden Fall. Wenn ich sogar der gleiche...
Ja, derselbe würde ich fast sagen.
Oh, das legt dich schon mal nicht zu weit.
Jetzt sagt er auch iMessage. Okay, dann sag ich jetzt mal Foo.
Ich hab mein Telefon noch in der Jacke.
Und jetzt kann ich auch ein Foto schicken. Ich hab das echt noch nicht ausgesucht, Leute.
Da kann man auch...
Ich schick dir jetzt so ein schönes Tim beim Podcasten.
Dann hol ich jetzt noch mein Telefon, Moment.
Dennis hat mir schon Positionen hier geschickt und so ein Zeug. Also da geht echt eine Menge. Also alles nur, ums auszuprobieren. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass mir Dennis irgendwelche Positionen schicken würde.
Das war halt in Reihen für die Wissenschaft.
Ah, jetzt kommt hier wieder...
Force Science! Was hast du denn jetzt?
Ich, ich, ich, ich wollte... Autokorrekt.me hat mich hier gerade erwischt.
Also unser Hörerzeiger ist schon deutlich nach unten gegangen seitdem. Das war iCal-Thema am Start.
Oh, wir sind bald kein Rundfunk mehr, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Ah, jetzt hab ich das gesendet.
Die haben einfach alle Kernnehmerqualität.
Die App ist gecrasht.
Ne, echt?
Ja. Und dann startet sie wieder. Und ich krieg zwei neue Nachrichten, die ich vorher noch nicht gesehen habe, die wochenalt sind. Oder? Ach nee, du hast mir die gerade geschickt. Oh, und weitere Leute schicken mir Nachrichten. Die hören wohl zu. So, so.
Haben wir etwa Hörer?
Genau, die sind jetzt alle aus dem Chat raus.
Genau, unter anderem derjenige, dem ich dieses Teil da zu verdanken habe, zum Teil, wenn du nämlich mal so ein bisschen, man sieht es leider nicht so gut, aber wenn du mal ein bisschen nimmst, schaffst du mal das Licht und beleuchtest du mal diesen Rahmen.
Soll ich das mal twittern?
Und jetzt musst du sagen...
Ui, was ist das denn unten?
Unten, da ist eingeätzt, ist das? Kann ich das?
Das ist Glaser.
Mit Twitter-Integration direkt aus der Kamera ab raus.
Ja, vielleicht nicht die SSID von meinem Mählern gleich noch mitfotografieren.
So, hast du noch deine Visa-Karten geheim noch mal?
Hast du sie jetzt getittert?
Ich versuch's jetzt aus der Foto ab mal, ich weiß ja nicht, ob's da auch...
Dann bist du ja doch gar nicht so ein Post-Privacy-Spacko. Spackeria-Dingens.
Was bin ich? Wer ist das denn behauptet?
Vielleicht war das Tim, der Post-Privacy.
Ich dachte mal, du auch bist einer von der Sorte, dass du mal alles raushaunst, sowieso alles im Netz.
Tims Hörer-Meter.
Ne, das hab ich so nie gesagt.
Ja, wir sollten vielleicht mal über dieses Gerät hier erzählen, ne?
Genau.
Wie nennen wir das Hörer-Meter?
Na eigentlich ist es das Megabit-Meter.
Das Hörer per Second.
Megabit-Meter als Berät. Ich will jetzt nicht die ganze Geschichte nochmal erzählen, weil ich hab die schon mal bei NSFW erzählt, auf jeden Fall.
Die Hörer überschneiden sich doch überhaupt gar nicht.
Zwischen sprachlos und fassungslos, denn jetzt gibt es auch einen kleinen Unterschied.
Also Tatsache ist, das Teil funktioniert jetzt anders. Und zwar kriege ich immer die aktuelle Hörerzahl, also was wir jetzt live an Hörern haben.
Also das sind Dings, wie man früher so bei...
Hast du das schon getittert? Dann werd ich das mal re-retittern.
Mit Zeiger und so. So ein Meter.
Ich retilte das gerade mal hier.
So ein Zeigermeter. Was zeigt jetzt eigentlich, wie viele Hörer wir jetzt gerade haben? Dann kommen wir jetzt so einen Hebelwetter schön vor die Hörer voraus.
Jaja, da könnte man sich so einiges vorstellen.
Oh, jetzt retilte Tim mich. Das wird der neue Follower Scharen mir zutreiben, bestimmt.
Nein, Mobile Max.
Tim hat ja schon über 20.000 Follower, ne?
Das kann ich so nicht retwitten. Tim ist mit Apostroph.
Das hat der iPhone gemacht. Ich hab das auf Englisch.
Mist.
Mach schon mal retweet mit Comment und dann kannst du das ja editieren.
Mit Comment? Auch das noch? Nee. Dann mach ich mir das ja auch noch zu eigen.
Soll ich es nochmal löschen und nochmal twittern?
Ja, bitte. Ich guck mir erstmal das Foto an. Das ist nicht scharf, mein Freund.
Das war auch das iPhone.
Da steht jetzt auch noch...
Ah, jetzt ist wieder das iPhone-Show.
Schreib dazu, dass es nur ein iPhone 4 war.
Warte, ich hab noch die HDR-Variante.
Und dann steht das auch noch auf diesem scheiß Acer und diesem Drobo. Wie peinlich.
Ja, Tim, mach dir mal Gedanken hier.
Ja, ja, es ist wirklich schlimm.
Was du hier uns auch als Kulisse zumutest.
Na ja, aber dich lesen ja wahrscheinlich auch schon alle. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben wir jetzt immer so eine kleine Nadel, die uns anzeigt, wie viel Hörer wir haben. Und wir sind jetzt... Ich seh es jetzt gerade nicht so gut wie Max.
Kannst du mal kurz sagen. Knapp über 500.
Knapp über 500 sollte das sein. Die Nadel vibriert an den 500.
Genau.
Scheiße, jetzt bin ich hier auf...
Oh, wer hat mir jetzt hier wieder das GSM angemacht?
Ja, sonst hätte das mit dem Einmessage nicht funktioniert.
Natürlich, das funktioniert darüber.
Ja, echt?
Ja klar, darum geht's doch.
Aber, aber...
Ich bin ja gar nicht im Chat, fällt mir gerade ein. Seitdem es da auf dem Beamer ist, bräuchte ich ja nicht mehr hier.
Seitdem Steve tot ist, geht's echt ab mit der Sendung.
Na gut, also die iOS-Enttäuschung.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein schönes Gadget. Und danke an Sascha für das Gläser. Und danke an SkyTi für die Hacker-Assistence heute.
Also doch nicht selber gemacht.
Doch nicht selber, hier ist Skriptet.
Doch, das Skriptet hab ich so zusammengefummelt. Aber trotzdem gab's hier Assistenz. Weil die beiden haben das ja mal so ausgehackt.
Aber iOS finde ich jetzt eigentlich alles andere als enttäuschend.
Na ja, also ich hab, gut, das ist jetzt nicht dramatisch, aber ich hab schon noch Probleme damit. Also vor allem mit den Ups.
Also das Einzige, womit ich jetzt...
Ich hab immer öfter crashende Apps, also vor allem die von Apple, crashen. Und zwar, ähm, ja, das Update, der App Store crasht öfter beim Starten. Kommst du hoch und poppest gleich sofort direkt. Dann starte ich nochmal und dann geht's.
Also ich hab mit einem App Store, hab ich auf dem iPad das Problem, dass ich manchmal auf dem Start-Screen bin und nichts antippen kann.
Wumm, schon wieder gerade.
Du musst dringend upgraden.
Ich starte den App Store, der lädt kurz, dann macht's Peng, und dann ist er wieder weg. Und jetzt beim zweiten Mal geht's dann. Haltest schon sehr oft. Ich glaub immer dann, wenn der irgendwie aus dem Speicher rausgeploppt wurde. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Bei mir ist bisher alles super gewesen, aber da hatte ich so einen Schiss.
Ich muss dich ja erst mal reden, dass du es überhaupt anmachst. Damit ich mit dir jetzt iMessagen kann, was wir ja schon ganz oft gemacht haben.
Ich wollte ja mal Glassboard ausprobieren. Hab mir mehrere Nachrichten geschickt, die hab ich nie geantwortet.
Klar, ich hab dir letzte Woche geschickt. Bei Huckel ja wahrscheinlich nicht kommt, dass ich dann nach Hawaii nehme, hab ich dir letzte Woche geschickt. Du hast ja nicht reagiert.
Ach, da schreibst du das hin.
Ja, wo sonst?
Habt ihr keine Nachrichten bekommen.
Da hatte ich noch kein iMessage mit dir. Da dachte ich, ich schick dir ein Glassboard for free. Ich bin ja so ein Cheapskater.
Ich guck mal jetzt.
Guck mal. Das heißt, du hast keine Notification bekommen?
Ja, wir haben doch jetzt hier ein iMessage.
Ja, du hast kein Bild.
Wie Bild und?
Du bist nur so ein grauer Avatar.
Und ohne Bild kommst du da nicht durch.
Ich bin halt anonym.
Max hat eine Katze als Bild.
Ich hab da ein Bild rangepackt.
Cat Lover.
Was ist denn das für ein Bild?
Wieder erscheinen es im Chat noch mehr zu geben, den der App Store irgendwie wegbombt.
Da gibt es wohl gerade Probleme generell so.
Ist ja wahrscheinlich voll überlastet.
Ich hab Dinge... Überlastet ist ein gutes Thema. Überlastet waren sie ja wieder. Ich dachte schon wieder, das wird jetzt wieder so ein Mobile-Me-Moment. Mit ihrer iCloud Aktivierung.
Na jetzt wo es die weg ist, können wir ja dann machen, was wir wollen. Ist eine Katze aus dem Haus, tanzen die Mäuse auf den Tisch, so sagt man es.
So, jetzt krieg ich hier ganz viel iMessage. Das ist auch schön hier.
Also mein persönlicher Favorite bei iOS 5 ist glaube ich diese Reader-Funktion.
Oh, 501 ist da.
Die mag ich total gern.
Hier war nur ein Spaß, ich wollte noch ein bisschen schocken, ob noch alle wach sind. Bestimmt sind jetzt so 100 Leute zu Hause vom Stuhl gefallen.
Ja und wenn man es zum richtigen Zeitpunkt macht, dann kommt dann stimmt es sogar.
Genau, wenn die die Sendung hören, vielleicht ist das schon da.
So lange die Sendung hören, immer in Loop, bis es stimmt. Das ist jetzt der Fluch, das ist der Update-Fluch. Ich mag dieses Freader-Feature total aus Safari.
Ja, ich finde das Feature an sich ganz gut. Einmal habe ich es getestet, da hat es leider nicht so verlässlich. Ich habe die nächsten Seiten angefügt. Bei der welt.de im Mobilinterface hat es nicht funktioniert.
Naja, aber überhaupt, dass man in einer vernünftigen Textgröße und so mit einer vernünftigen Schrift mal so lesen kann, das finde ich ganz angenehm.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr wünschenswert. Und auch diese Twitter-Integration finde ich in der Hinsicht gut, als dass ich viel twittere. Ob das nun für jedermann so toll ist. Ich glaube, die meisten Leute hätten sich eher so eine Facebook-Integration gewünscht dieser Art.
Ja, aber die Twitter-Anmeldungen haben sich verdreifacht, habe ich jetzt gehört, seit iOS 5.
Die Twitter-Anmeldung pro Tag. Auf iOS-Geräten hat sich verdreifacht.
Auf iOS-Geräten oder generell? Ich glaube generell. Also ich konnte da eine Einschränkung nicht rauslesen.
Ja, sind wir denn Journalisten, dass wir ja immer alles genau recherchieren müssen?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Na gut.
Wofür haben wir Hörer?
Dann bin ich ja beruhigt. Ich hatte mir irgendwas notiert, was nicht funktioniert, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo.
Die Notizenfunktion. Was ich ja echt schade finde, sie hatten ja in den Betas irgendwann mal eine Umlauttastatur drinnen. Also eine deutsche mit Umlauten direkt als Tasten. Sowohl auf dem iPhone als auch auf dem iPad. Und nach einer gewissen Umgewöhnungszeit hatte ich mich da sehr dran gewöhnt, dass sie einfach so sang- und klanglos wieder rausgeflogen und es bis heute nicht wieder aufgetaucht. Finde ich ja sehr, sehr schade persönlich. Hoffe, dass die wiederkommt. Ja, du kannst das ignorieren, kannst dann trotzdem. Du kannst jetzt...
Aber wo soll auf die Tastatur denn jetzt hier bitte schön...
Na, da waren hier noch so rechts noch... Doch, da waren die halt ein bisschen schmaler, die ganzen Tasten, da waren dann noch dran. Finde ich ganz gut. Und beim iPad, da ist es überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Na ja, gut, also iOS auf jeden Fall auch eine riesen Enttäuschung.
Definitiv.
Und Newsstand ist ja auch so eine Enttäuschung. Nee, Newsstand finde ich ganz geil.
Ich kann nicht sagen, was so eine wirkliche Enttäuschung ist.
Was denn?
Also wo ich echt wirklich enttäusch bin. Und das ist einfach das Thema Podcasting auf dem iPhone, ist einfach weil... Also nicht nur, dass es nicht besser geworden ist, sondern es hält auch nicht Schritt mit der Entwicklung und deswegen wird es auch alles schlechter. Und manche Sachen sind sogar richtig furchtbar. zum Beispiel. Ich meine, es ist ja schön, dass man jetzt sein iPhone auch einrichten kann und sein iPad auch benutzen kann, ohne einen Computer zu haben.
Und updaten.
Und updaten und alles. Das heißt, kein iTunes verwenden. Jetzt würde man aber erwarten, dass unter iOS auch all diese Funktionalitäten dann stand-alone verfügbar sind, die du eben mit iTunes hast, oder zumindest die wichtigen. Aus Appes Sichtweise heraus sind die wichtigen wahrscheinlich auch dabei. Genau. Das heißt aber, Podcasts kommen mal wieder zu kurz. Also mir ist es zum Beispiel auf dem iPad nicht gelungen, da mal eine Kapitelmarkenliste bei Kapiteldateien zu bekommen. Also dieser merkwürdige Player mit dem Plasterholzrand. Ja, also der zeigt die Kapitelmarken gar nicht an. Ich hab den sehr selten benutzt, deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, wie das vorher war, aber Tatsache ist, dass Kapitelmarken auf dem iPad einfach gar nicht auftauchen. Und es gibt einfach keine Möglichkeit, innerhalb des normalen iPod-Interfaces Podcasts zu subscriben. Ich meine, bislang ging das halt alles über iTunes. Wenn du jetzt keine iTunes mehr hast, weil du eben dir so ein Telefon kaufst und einfach Standalone benutzt, wo ist die Funktionalität, Podcasts zu subscriben? Gibt es nicht. Und dazu kommt noch diese merkwürdige Trennung in Audio und Video, wo sie jetzt Podcasts auch noch auf beides verteilen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Podcast hast, wo sowohl Audio als auch Video kommt, was zugegebenermaßen jetzt nicht unbedingt das vorherrschende Format ist, aber was durchaus mal sein kann, dass du halt auch mal ein Video in deinen Podcast reinschmeißt, weil es eben für angemessen hältst, dann erscheint das jetzt eben in einer anderen Applikation.
Weil sie diese iPod-Applikation getrennt haben, was ja eigentlich auch, ehrlich gesagt, mal Sinn gemacht hat, langsam?
Weiß sie nicht, ob das so Sinn gemacht hat. Warum kann das nicht einfach alles Medien abspielen? Also für mich, ich bin immer in demselben Zustand, egal, ob ich jetzt gerade Audio oder Video sehen will. Das ist für mich immer dasselbe. Ja, ich blicke auf meinen Medienarchiv und dann wähle ich, ob ich mir was angucke oder anhöre. Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich erstmal in das entsprechende Programm reingehe.
Aber das ist bei mir total anders.
Das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob du einen unterschiedlichen Text in dir hast für deutsche und für englische Texte.
Nee, also ich habe zum Beispiel, ich habe, ich höre ja auf dem Rad sehr viele Podcasts und schaue Videos prinzipiell nie auf dem Rad, weil das die Verkehrssicherheit... Und wenn ich was sehen will, dann möchte ich was sehen. Dann möchte ich auch keinen Podcast hören.
Okay, ich habe nichts dagegen, dass man eine Möglichkeit schafft, Videos auszublenden und zu sagen, ich will jetzt nur alles, was Audio ist. Blenden wir das aus, aber doch nicht auf Basis eines Programms. Ich meine, derselbe Podcast-Feed, da tauchen die, manche Items tauchen nur in einem Programm auf und andere tauchen nur in dem anderen auf.
Geht's noch? Ja, aber es ist dieses ganze Thema Podcast, nicht nur bei Apple, sondern generell müsste das nochmal total überdacht werden. Ich finde, da fehlt so unglaublich viel. Das ist so überhaupt nicht 21. Jahrhundert, dieses ganze Zeug. Also zum Beispiel, was ich ja nach wie vor sehr, sehr schmerzlich vermisse, ist eine Möglichkeit, dass man einfach mal per Facebook oder per Twitter eine Stelle in einem Podcast sharen kann. Also ich sage kann, hier ab, also dass man nicht sagen muss, hier ladet euch mal den Podcast runter, spult vor zu 12738 und man kann sagen, ha ha, hier habe ich gelacht, schick's an meine Freunde weiter. Also so eine Späße. Also so Podcasts, da ist, wenn man sich mal eine halbe Stunde hinsetzt und so drüber nachdenkt, was geht denn, dann geht da noch eine ganze Masse. Gar keine Frage.
Aber ich meine, ich rede jetzt erst mal über die Basics. Ich rede jetzt erst mal nur über dieses, ich kann einen Podcast abonnieren, so wie das 2005 mal gedacht war.
Aber da finde ich, ja, die von Apple mitgelieferten Sachen, die sind eher nicht so doll, das stimmt schon, aber ladet ihr doch irgendwie sowas wie Podcaster oder Instacaster oder sowas?
Ja gut, aber damit ist es dann halt Second Class Citizen. Das ist nicht mehr Bestandteil der Default User Experience, was es halt eigentlich bei iTunes war. Und es täuscht ja auch immer noch so vor, das zu sein, bloß wie kriegst du halt Podcast abonniert ohne Computer.
Naja, ich kann mir vorstellen, was das ist.
Da hatte ich mal ein iPhone und ich sag ihm, ja hier abonniert doch den Podcast und dann schaut er auf sein Telefon und da ist dann nichts. Und dann sag ich, ja da musst du dann ein anderes Programm benutzen. Und dann geht das nächste Elend wieder los.
Aber wie ist das eigentlich mit Newsstand? Ist Newsstand, ist das?
Moment, ich bin ja noch nicht bei den Furchtbarkeiten vorbei. Habt ihr diesen Text gelesen von Marco Amendt über das automatische Löschen von Daten im Programm?
Achso, ja den hab ich gelesen.
So, das heißt, ist dein iPhone voll, dann löscht das OS selbstetig Daten von Programmen?
Naja, ganz so ist es nicht. Also es gibt, man hat zwei, also man hat mehr als zwei Orden, aber es gibt so prinzipiell zwei Orden, in die man als Programm seine Daten reinlegen kann. Das ist einmal der Documents-Folder, da legst du alles Wichtige rein. Das ist einmal der Cache- oder Temp-Folder. Da gibt es Cache und Temp und ist aber im Wesentlichen dasselbe. Und da legst du alles rein, was jetzt, ey, was kann ich nachladen, so nach dem Motto? Also so, so, so, irgendwelche Kartendaten oder so.
Also nicht nur kann ich nachladen, sondern kannst du jederzeit, on demand ist es zumutbar, dass du sie nachlädst.
So quasi, genau. Und jetzt ist es halt, bis iOS 4 machte das keinen großen Unterschied, außer dass bei einem, ich glaube nach einem Backup waren die gecashten Daten weg. Also die sind nicht mit gebackupt worden und sowas.
Was ja okay ist.
Was okay ist. Und jetzt ist es halt so, wenn der Speicher von deinem Telefon vollläuft oder von deinem iPad, dann...
Und nicht der Hauptspeicher, sondern eben das Flash.
Der Flash, genau. Das, ähm, die Festplatte. Die Festplatte, genau. Wenn die Festplatte voll ist, dann, dann werden diese Daten gelöscht, ohne dass du noch mal gefragt wirst. Das heißt, wenn dir die massenhaft Podcast folgen, für irgendwie einen Flug runter, also, genau, ähm, in den Documents-Order darfst du keine Podcasts reinlegen. Oder dergleichen, weil das wird ja mit iCloud gebackupt und verursacht Traffic. Da ist es ein Grund, aus dem App-Store abgelehnt zu werden. Und in diesem anderen Ordner ist es halt so, wenn du Pech hast, ist die Platte...
Fliegen dir halt deine Podcasts weg. Genau das, was du dir extra runtergeladen hast, für den langen Flug oder die Offline-Zeit von zwei Wochen.
Wenn du dir so richtig die Platte voll machst, weil du in den Urlaub fliegen willst, kann es sein, dass nachher gar nichts mehr von da ist.
Wir finden das suboptimal.
Verbesserungswürdig.
Ich finde das einfach mal scheiße.
Deutsch gesagt.
Ich finde, da muss noch ein Zwischenweg her.
Wenn Steve noch leben würde.
Ich glaube, da hat er noch gelebt, als es das gab.
Du meinst Hoffnung.
Hoffnung existiert.
Nee, aber ich kann die Logik dahinter schon verstehen. Sie müssen wahrscheinlich noch eine Zwischenebene einziehen.
Das müssen sie ändern. Ich meine, das ist ein vollkommen unzumutbarer Zustand. Also schon für Instapaper finde ich das vollkommen unzumutbar. Es muss einfach eine Möglichkeit geben, größere Datenmengen offline zu lagern. Hier Open Maps ist das nächste Beispiel. Ich will explizit richtig viel Kartendaten auf meinem Telefon haben und behalten. Ich lade mir, bevor ich nach Holland fahre, weil ich da nicht mit permanenter Datenversorgung rechnen kann, lade ich mir Holland in großer Auflösung runter, damit ich überall, wo ich da langgurke, weiß, wo ich bin.
Das geht übrigens mit wie heißt das?
Skopla 2 geht das super. Aber ich möchte mir nicht, dass er mir meine Karten löscht. Ich will das und ich will das auch nicht immer wieder runterladen. Dafür habe ich den Scheißspeicher. Dafür gebe ich so viel Geld aus, damit ich 32 oder 64 Gigabyte habe. Da möchte ich nicht, dass dieses US kommt und mir das einfach weghaut. Ich meine, was erlaube iOS? Das ist eine Enttäuschung.
Ich hab dieses Problem, mein iPhone war einfach noch nie voll, mein iPad auch nicht. Also ich glaube, bei mir wäre es noch nicht mal in die Situation gekommen, dass das notwendig gewesen wäre.
Was, dein iPod war nicht voll? Dein iPhone ist nicht voll?
Nee.
Ich kenne überhaupt keinen anderen Zustand als voll.
Das ist bei mir auch anders tatsächlich. Mein Telefon ist immer so ca. 10% nur voll, weil ich das gar nicht mit den Medien vollgehe.
Also bei mir ist die Hälfte voll.
Bei mir ist einfach immer alles voll. Also einfach am Anschlag. Das Einzige, was nicht am Anschlag voll ist, ist das iPad, was ich hier nur zu Testzwecken habe.
Und was passiert, wenn du, was passierte bisher, wenn du dann probiert hast, irgendwas zu tun, wenn es voll war?
Jetzt beim Sinken meinst du.
Ja, wobei auch immer. Also in welchem Zustand. Wenn du probiert hast, eine App runterzuladen oder sowas.
Na, er hat gesagt, es ist voll.
Pech. Was gelöscht. Dann lösche ich halt so einen Film, den ich jetzt zwar dabei habe, aber nicht gucken werde. Und dann habe ich einen Gigabyte frei und dann ist gut. Und dann kann ich auch wieder meine Apps updaten zum Beispiel.
Also ich finde.
Aber ich will nicht, dass er mir, ohne mich zu fragen und noch besser, ohne mir zu sagen, dass er es getan hat, offline Daten, die ich mühsam vorher gecached habe. Ich meine, da sitze ich da wirklich, wähle eine halbe Stunde lang die Kartenbereiche aus, die ich haben will, mit dem Zoom-Level und so weiter und opfere bewusst. Ich meine, dafür habe ich den Speicher gekauft, um genau so eine Sache zu machen. Ich habe maximal einen Speicher, damit ich 50 Prozent davon einfach mit Cashdaten vollhauen kann. Und das sind Podcasts und das sind Karten und mir würden wahrscheinlich auch noch ein paar andere Beispiele einfallen, nur jetzt nicht.
Gut, also ich finde den Ansatz, so dieses iOS soll dieses Betriebssystem sein, was das alles für dich total transparent macht, damit du gar nichts davon merkst und wenn da noch Platz drauf ist und einfach so ein paar Cash-Ordner lernen kann, finde ich im Ansatz ziemlich gut. Also ich finde es besser, als einfach so zu sagen, voll mach du, Idiot. Die Lösung dafür ist bloß noch nicht so gut. Es muss halt einen Ordner geben, in dem ich Daten reinschreiben kann, vielleicht auch eine Priorisierung, dass ich sagen kann, okay, das kannst du löschen. Also zum Beispiel jetzt bei Instapaper, wo ich dir ja die neue Version sehr gelungen finde, aber das ist vielleicht ein anderes Thema, könnte man ja sagen, okay, du hast da 500 Artikel drauf, dann lege ich doch die zehn neuesten von diesen Artikeln in den Documents-Folder, wo wahrscheinlich auch ein Problem reinpassen muss, weil soviel sind das ja nicht, das sind dann, sagen wir mal, zwei Media-Arbeit oder drei. Und die anderen 490, die packe ich in Cache. Und weil man vermutlich sowieso nicht auf die, also mir geht es zumindest so, mich würde das überhaupt nicht stören. Weil ich habe immer, ich sage dem, synchronisiere 500 Artikel und dann habe ich da immer 500 Artikel drinne, die werde ich niemals alle lesen. Ich höre sozusagen nur die nach oben offene Liste. Und insofern finde ich den Ansatz nicht verkehrt.
Der Ansatz ist nicht falsch, aber es muss als Recht die Möglichkeit geben, dass man das verhindern kann. Haben wir denn noch weitere Beiträge? Also ich finde die iOS-N5-Enttäuschung in Bezug auf Podcasts und überhaupt, also das geht jetzt einfach nicht. Das nächste Update muss definitiv eine Verbesserung im Bereich Podcasts machen. Für diese scheiß Hochglanz-Pornomagazine machen sie da sogar noch ein Icon drauf, was ich nicht löschen kann, was da so leer rumlungert, weil ich so einen Kack nicht kofe.
Aber den Justyn finde ich gut. Ich habe mir jetzt vom...
Jetzt das Gesicht verhandelt.
Ja, aber was...
Was erlauben Max?
Was lese Max?
Ich habe mir hier so eine Probe, aber gibt es drei Monate kostenlos vom Guardian geholt. Und das ist super. Guardian ist nicht die britische BZ?
Nee, das ist nicht die britische BZ. Nee, nee, nee. Guardian hat kein Äquivalent.
Schon eher Anspruch, oder?
Das ist schon...
Also es gibt Probe-Abo. Mit irgendwelchen...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es für iPhone gibt, für das iPad ist das auf jeden Fall. Und es ist eine sehr schick gemachte App. Und so diese Coverbildchen, die da sind und so, das macht eine Menge her. Also es ist, ich glaube nicht, dass ich es wirklich auf Dauer nutzen werde, aber ich glaube, dass es da viele Leute gibt, die das echt mögen werden. Und wie ist das eigentlich?
Ja, aber wenn ich das nicht benutze, dann will ich da auch nicht so ein blödes Algen rumliegen haben. Das hätte ich lieber für Podcasts.
Ja, aber jetzt haben sie halt erst mal andere Prioritäten gesetzt. Wundert mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Jetzt erst mal andere Prioritäten gesetzt.
Na ja, du hast halt, Tim, du hast halt nicht ganz so ein starkes Lobby, wie die Verlagsbranche hat. Aber um jetzt nochmal dieses Thema anzufangen, wie sehen da die Upstore-Richtlinien eigentlich aus? Was darf man denn da reinpacken in den Newsstand? Also technisch ist das ja eine total billige Sache.
Ich glaube, das bezieht sich auf alle die Ups, die halt dieses Subscription-Feature benutzen.
Nee, das musst du gar nicht machen. Nicht?
Man muss nur sagen, ich bin ein Magazin?
Du musst sagen, ich bin ein Magazin. Und du gibst eine URL. Ich hab darüber den entsprechenden WWDC...
Kann man doch darüber Podcasts machen?
Naja, sie schränkt natürlich die Inhalte ein. Du darfst ja nicht beliebige Inhalte draufpappen, sozusagen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie die Einschränkungen sind.
Muss man die sich abnehmen lassen?
Du musst nicht jeweils sie abnehmen lassen, sondern musst halt irgendwie Zeitschriften... Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie die Definition ist, ob das News-Inhalte sind oder... Also zum Beispiel darfst du nur einmal täglich ein Update durchschicken. Das geht aber im Wesentlichen per Push-Notification. Und...
Ich verstehe bloß nicht, warum man solche hunderte Megabytes Ups da aktualisiert im Hintergrund, aber das für Podcasts nicht gehen soll.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, vielleicht kommt man ja relativ einfach... Also ich meine, es ist keine perfekte Lösung, aber ich würde es eine ganz schöne Lösung finden, wenn dann legt man hier mal für Mobile Max oder weißt der Teufel was, schreibt man mal in eine App, macht da ein Artikel rein, nämlich mit der Themenzusammenfange vom neuesten Podcast, ist da ein Multimedia-Inhalt dabei, der einem die Podcasts abspielt. Und wenn da eine neue Folge von Mobile Max da ist, dann packt man da immer jeweils ein schönes Coverbildchen rein, das wird ein bisschen mehr Arbeit, aber dann stelle ich mir eigentlich ganz cool vor. Bits und so probiert es. Ja, wenn die das hinkriegen, das wäre doch echt mal geil.
Das wäre zumindest mal ein Grund, da abzuhaben. Das ist für uns echt keinen Sinn, darin gesehen.
Und bei diesem Newsstand, das ist dieses Icon, das ist ja, du musst auch sagen, also das ist wirklich extrem auf Print ausgelegt, du musst bei dem Icon sagen, wo das gefaltet ist. Also ob das eine Zeitung ist, die sozusagen, wo der Knick horizontal ist, weil die dann so aufklappt, oder wo die Falte so Magazinartig, dass die Falte links ist.
Warum ist der Tagesspiegel jetzt hier gratis? Ist der dann immer gratis oder wie?
Wenn die App gratis ist, dann musst du halt die einzelnen Ausgaben kaufen.
Okay, also ich hab jetzt...
Ich muss dir sozusagen nur sagen, wo ich den Podcast falten, wo man den falten kann.
Genau, das musst du ihm sagen.
Wollen wir jetzt mal so eine Faltmarke einfügen hier?
Wie falten Sie Ihren Podcast richtig?
Wir machen einfach so eine Sekunde Pause. Jetzt haben sie alle umgeblättert. Du hast schon so ein bisschen in den Knick hinein gelacht.
Das war ein Cliffhanger.
Blättern Sie auch das nächste Mal um, wenn Sie diese Hucke-Kichern hören.
So, na schön. Also die iOS-Enttäuschung hätten wir jetzt auch dann damit erst mal abgewirtschaftet.
Ich denke auch.
Wer hier wen abwirtschaftet, ist sowieso noch mal zu...
Ein einziges Apple-Thema habe ich jetzt hier noch auf meiner Liste. Na das Samsung und Apple-Thema.
Ach das Thema. Ja, du hast das aufgebracht. Ich hab das aufgebracht, ja. Wir haben uns da bisher immer so dringend...
Und jetzt wird es die Runde aufbringen wahrscheinlich.
Na mal gucken. Wie ihr wisst, hat Apple Samsung verklagt. Wegen Galaxy Tab und so. Und wegen Patenten. Ne, wegen Patenten gar nicht. Wegen Geschmacksmuster glaube ich in Deutschland zumindest bei der Klage, die ich so mitbekommen habe. Wo sich auch alle ganz furchtbar aufgeregt haben drüber. Und Samsung hat fröhlich zurückgekriegt. Na ja, haben doch alle so. Die sind sich immer aufregend.
Die sind sich immer aufregend.
Die hasst Prediger.
Die hasst Prediger auf Twitter.
Und wie kann es denn sein, dass eine Firma sich auf ein Recht beruft?
Naja, ich meine, das ist natürlich ein bisschen konkreter. Also diese Ähnlichkeit zwischen Galaxy Tab, rechteckig mit abgerundeten Ecken, das ist jetzt zugegebenermaßen ein Formfaktor, der auf erstaunlich viele Tablets zutrifft.
Aber das war ja geil. Sie haben ja bei der einen Anhörung im Gericht haben Sie halt in Richtung Samsung Zeug die beiden nebeneinander hochgehalten. Und die sollten halt sagen, welches ihres ist. Das hat halt so einige Momente gedauert, bis sie dann irgendwie...
Also Sie haben es dann schon richtig identifiziert bekommen, oder?
Aber ich meine auch so, es geht ja auch bis ins UI teilweise.
Nee, es geht sogar auch in die Verpackung.
Ich meine, sie haben sogar die Verpackung komplett geklonet.
Also das ist halt bei Samsung wirklich... Ich bin kein Freund von so Patenten und ich meine diese Geschmacksmuster und so. Aber bei Samsung ist da wirklich extrem... Also es ist die Verpackung, es ist die Form, es sind die Icons, die sehr ähnlich aussehen. Ich hab mal hier... Da hingen so O2-Plakatwerbung rum. Und da hab ich gesagt, ach guck mal, O2 bewirbt jetzt das 3GS. Und das war kein... Also es sah aus wie ein iPhone 3GS und dann musste ich noch mal hingucken und ich hab nun diverse Male so ein iPhone 3GS gesehen. Und ich hab's dann noch mal gegoogelt, das ist ein Samsung Defy oder D-E-F-Y. Und das ist... Das kann mir keiner sagen, da ist jemand hingegangen bei Samsung zu seinen Produktentwicklern, hat das 3GS hingelegt und hat gesagt, das will ich. Und macht das so, dass es... Genau so ist. Dass es genau so ist, ohne dass die uns verklagen können. Und...
ja.
Das finde ich ist... Also ich kann App-Bilder verstehen.
Ja, und ich meine, das ist nun mal so. Ich meine, wenn du da ein Plagiat machst, was einfach genauso aussieht... Gut, Plagiat würde bedeuten, sie nennen es auch noch iPad. Das ist nicht die richtige Bezeichnung. Aber es ist nun mal sehr offensichtlich, dass sie versucht haben, verdammt nah an exakt genau demselben Design zu landen.
Viele der Produkte sind darauf angelegt, verwechselt zu werden. Sag ich jetzt mal. Oder was ich auch sehr oft gehört habe, ist jetzt schon eine Weile her bei Kollegen, der sich zusammen so ein Galaxy irgendwas gekauft haben. Galaxy. Und die Aussage war, ja, ist wie beim iPhone. Und darum hab ich mir geholt, weil es ist wie ein iPhone. Und das ist natürlich so, das ist durchaus von Samsung erwünscht. Und hat ihr das bei Gruber gelesen, der hat da noch den schönen Screenshot, dass jetzt Samsung hat einen neuen Media Player vorgestellt auf Android-Basis und hat einen Screenshot und hat tatsächlich einen Screenshot, also hat diesen Samsung-Player und dann ist da ein Maps-Screenshot drinne, und zwar von der iOS-Maps-Version.
Die wissen einfach überhaupt nicht, was sie da tun.
Und diesen Screenshot haben sie nicht selber gemacht, sondern haben sie auch von irgendeiner Webseite geklaut und von Flickr geklaut. Das ist irgendwie von 2008 ein Screenshot, den irgendein User gemacht hat gewesen.
Da gibt es halt viele Beispiele. Ich meine, hier im Chat geht ja das neurotische irgendwie Schwarz-Weiß-Denken genauso weiter hier. Ich sage ja jetzt für Patente, solange es um Patente geht, wir reden erst mal gar nicht über Patente, sondern wir reden hier über Geschmacksmuster. Schutz, ja, also man hat halt ein Produkt, was eben ein gewisses öffentliches Erscheinungsbild hat, sag ich mal, oder ein Produkt-Erscheinungsbild. Und das ist halt geschützt. Und wenn jemand anderes das eben kopiert und du nachweisen kannst, dass eben Verwechslungsgefahr besteht, dann wird das eben einfach zurückgenommen von Gerichten. So ist das einfach. Das halte ich auch vollkommen zulässig. Ich meine, angenommen Apple würde jetzt ein Produkt rausbringen, was genauso aussieht, wie das eines Competitors. Wie groß wäre das Geschrei dann? Und auch zu Recht. Ja, also ich meine, zu Recht. Von daher ist es schon so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Also hier, was Samsung da so trägt.
Okay, es heißt nicht Samsung Defi, ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt. Es war kein Galaxy, weil es hatte nämlich, es sah anders aus, es hatte nämlich so einen silbernen Rand auch, wie das 3GS. Also es sah wirklich extrem aus, wie das 3GS. Diese Samsung-Ladegeräte, habt ihr das gesehen? Auch, genau. Diese, die wirklich aussehen, nimm dein iPhone, lade Würfel und male ihn schwarz an und schreib Samsung drauf und du hast das Gerät. Beim Galaxy Tab hier, das Kabel, von dem ich mir überhaupt sagen lassen, dass es pinn-kompatibel sei. Also du kannst das Samsung-Kabel auch nehmen, um dein iPad zu laden. Wo ich ja prinzipiell, hey, ist eigentlich eine gute Sache, aber dann wundert euch nicht, dass Apple euch verklagt.
Ja, eben.
Das sind sehr, sehr viele Sachen, die da auf einmal kommen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Ich meine, diese Auseinandersetzung, die an anderen Ländern auf Patentbasis gefahren wird, was soll man dazu sagen? Ich meine, Software-Patente bin ich definitiv kein Freund von. Und das ist einfach generell ein extrem schwieriges Feld, auf dem ich glaube, dass einfach die allermeisten Patente einfach Quatsch beschreiben. Und das ist mittlerweile so weit ist, dass da einfach nur noch Quatsch rausgehauen wird und die Gerichte die ganze Zeit auf Basis von Quatsch entscheiden und man sich einfach eine Menge Freude erarbeiten würde. Allgemein würde man das einfach generell weglassen. Nur derzeit ist es halt einfach die Auseinandersetzung und vieles basiert eben auch, Businessmodelle basieren auch darauf, dass es eben dieses Patentsystem gibt. Interessant finde ich in dieser ganzen Auseinandersetzung, ich will das auch gar nicht werten, aber interessant finde ich, dass es eigentlich, mal kurz nochmal nachdenken, also Apple, wenn ich das richtig verfolge, klagt, wenn es auf Patentbasis geht, eigentlich immer auf Unterlassung.
Nie auf Schadensersatz?
Genau. Die Patente, die Apple hat, sind ja in der Regel keine, die sie gekauft haben, zumindest kenne ich einen solchen Fall nicht. Es ist nicht so, dass sie ein Patentportfolio erworben haben und dann Lizenzzahlungen einklagen. Bei Apple geht es mit den Patenten darum, dass sie eben ein bestimmtes Feature haben, von dem sie eben nicht möchten, dass es ihre Mitbewerber so schnell kopieren. Und das versuchen sie dann eben auch durchzusetzen.
Der wädert schon wieder, der Dennis, ne?
Naja, der wädert so ein bisschen rum, ne?
Gar nicht.
Bist du eigentlich mein Vater, Dennis? So, dieses Ding mit Google und Motorola, wo sie sich dann irgendwie durch die Motorola kauft, die jetzt Patente erworben haben.
Und die erstmal HTC in die Hand drücken?
Genau, die sie dann HTC in die Hand drücken, die sie dann HTC benutzt, um dann Apple zu verklagen.
Und da man endlich mal durchkommt...
Ist das irgendwie schon entschieden worden?
Das ist jetzt abgewiesen worden, weil nicht eins der Patente gültig war. Oder nicht auf eins dazutrifft.
Ja, okay, hab ich gar nicht so verfolgt, aber da frag ich mich halt wirklich, was...
Ich find, gerade auch bei diesen Klagen haben ja auch alle gesagt, ja, Apple hat nie ne Chance damit. Was müssen das für Richter sein hier in Deutschland? Die haben ja von Blut und Blasen keine Ahnung. Das ist jetzt mittlerweile in Niederlanden ist ein Ähnliche. Da hat Apple gegen Samsung geklagt, ist ähnlich gelaufen. In Australien ist der Vertrieb eingestellt von dem Galaxy Tab aufgrund dessen, weil Apple dagegen geklagt hat. Und umgekehrt hat ja auch Samsung Apple in diversen Punkten verklagt und bisher mit nicht allzu großem Erfolg, wie ich das Gefühl habe. Also entweder hat Apple fantastisch viel bessere Anwälte als Samsung, was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann. Oder Apple hat einfach mehr in den Händen als Samsung, was ich mir auch gut vorstellen kann. Ja, wir werden es sehen.
Macht so den Eindruck. Also mein Gefühl sagt mir, Samsung wird sich da nicht sehr viel erarbeiten können. Die, die sich auch geben. Also ich finde die wirklich extrem unangenehm. Jungs, gab es da neulich irgendwie so eine, was war das letzte Woche, irgendein Foto oder wo sie dann irgendwie, ja, wir werden die größte, die führende Hardware und Software, führende Hardware und Software-Unternehmen der nächsten Zeit werden. So behaupten die so von sich.
Ja, ich meine.
Find ich jetzt auch.
Software, Samsung, was machen die denn selber?
Bada.
Stimmt.
Ja, alles eine Frage der Perspektive.
Ja, die sind halt, ich meine, die, meine Fingern sollen sie sich haben, wie sie wollen.
Also, auf dem App, auf dem Microsoft Campus hat sich der Zune, glaube ich, auch relativ gut verkauft.
Ja, aber Steve Baumer jeden, den iPod hat es halt geschlagen. Ach, aber wenn wir schon mal bei dem Thema sind, gestern ist ja, oder heute Nacht, heute Nacht ist es vorgestellt worden, ne? Android 4.0 mit dem Nexus irgendwas. Nexus, wie heißt das? Nexus? Galaxy Nexus. Nexos Galaxy. Das ist irgendwie bekloppt, aber ich meine, die eine Hälfte nennen sie Galaxy, die andere Nennen sie Nexus und jetzt packen wir beides in Einnahmen. Und, ähm, ich bin ja mal gespannt auf dieses auf dieses Android 4.0.
Also es ist, ähm, Was ist denn da überhaupt neu?
Ach, da ist schon, was ist denn da neu?
Also es ruckelt angeblich immer noch.
Das fand ich auch, das hab ich gelesen. Bei This Is My Next hier, die haben so ein Review geschrieben und der ist eigentlich im Allgemeinen relativ positiv. Aber sie meinten halt, ja, ist ja alles noch Beta-Software und man muss auch Google lassen, dass sie hier das Ding war mit Software vollgeladen. Aber es hat schon noch geruckelt. Und zwar deutlich. Und das finde ich wirklich hart. Das ist ein 1,2 Gigahertz Dual Core Prozessor mit einem Gigabyte RAM. Also es ist, sagen wir mal, so roundabout, doppelt so schnell und doppelt so viel RAM wie so ein iPhone 4S. Und viermal so schnell wie ein iPhone 4. Oder vielleicht nicht ganz, dreimal so schnell. Und dann immer noch zu ruckeln, das ist schon hart. Aber ansonsten, was haben sie? Sie haben jetzt so weltbewegende Sachen wie Audioplayer-Steuern im Log-Screen. Notifications haben sie ein bisschen überarbeitet. Ein bisschen gefälligeres Aussehen hat das ganze Ding. Sieht jetzt halt aus wie dieses Honeycomb.
Aber sag mal, bist du bei Android 4 oder bist du noch bei dem Galaxy Nexus?
Ist ja im Augenblick sozusagen noch beides dasselbe. Es ist so wie dieses Android 3.0.
Android 4.0 sieht aus wie Android 3.0, sagst du.
Na ja, es ist jetzt fürs Telefon, sieht jetzt so aus wie vorher fürs Tablet. Genau.
Aber dieses Galaxy Nexus ist ja auch größer, oder?
Das ist ziemlich groß, ja.
Ich hab versucht, das in Relation zu meinem iPhone zu... Aber das gibt's irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Ich hab Fotos gesehen davon.
Aber auch im Vergleich.
Da standen die so nebeneinander, oder?
Ich fand's offen.
Weil es ist ja, hat ja einen viel größeren Bildschirm, hat ja auch eine megamäßige Auflösung von 1280, mal, weiß ich nicht, wie viel.
720.
Ja, das ist schon ziemlich fett, aber wenn du halt so einen riesen... Warte, ich hab zwischendurch...
War das nicht beim Gruber verlinkt?
Die Nähte von deiner Tasche platzen, bin ich zu laut, oder zu leise?
Die Nähte von deiner Tasche platzen?
Also was ich ja ein hübsches Argument fand, das war ja, es gab ja so diese Enttäuschung, nachdem iPhone 4s hat kein größeres Display und dann hat Gruber ewig lange drauf rumgedroschen und gemeint, ne, also... Und er hat ein paar ganz sinnhafte Argumente, wie ich finde, zum einen, Apple hätte schon 2007 nichts davon abgehalten, einfach ein iPhone mit 4 Zoll Display rauszubringen, wenn sie 4 Zoll für eine bessere Größe gehalten hätten. Sie haben sich aber dafür diese 3,5 Zoll entschieden. Und warum sollten sie jetzt davon abweichen? Es gibt keine Notwendigkeit dazu. Es gibt keine technische Entwicklung, die ein größeres Display notwendig macht. Was ich aber eigentlich noch viel besser finde, ist, dieses 3,5 Zoll Display, das kann man mit einer Hand bedienen, bequem. Also so in einer Hand halten und mit dem Daumen dann swipen, was sicherlich sehr viele Leute sehr oft machen. Bei Android ist das dann, bei diesem 4,5 Zoll Display wird es langsam kompliziert. Oder was sind's? 4,6 Zoll? Und insbesondere wenn man sich bedenkt, dass die Toolbars und so, die sind ja bei Android immer oben, dann muss man doch schon ganz schön übers Display greifen, ist meine Vermutung. Insofern finde ich ein 3,5 Zoll Display wesentlich besser als ein 4,5 Zoll Display. Aber das mag jeder für sich entscheiden.
Manche fahren halt auch Hammer, ne?
Ich wäre auf jeden Fall enttäuscht gewesen, wenn sie die Displaygröße geändert haben. Das würde bedeuten, dass einfach ganz viele Apps nicht mehr funktionieren.
Also entweder hätten sie sich die Pixel vergrößert, davon habe ich nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Oder sie hätten halt die Displayauflösung nochmal geändert, was jetzt für ein...
Das ist halt einfach nie zur Debatte.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch, was da sowieso immer die ganze Zeit schon das Problem ist, nur dass sie einfach so unendlich viele unterschiedliche Größen und Formate und Hass nicht gesehen haben und dann die armen Applikationsentwickler da fleißig am Anpassen immer sind.
Also, um es zusammenzufassen, ein größeres Display oder was heißt, also physikalisch größer, weiß nicht, ob das so cool ist, weil wir eben in der Hand liegen und so, aber mehr Pixel ist natürlich nie schlechter, aber der größere Vorteil ist natürlich, dass man über Jahre, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber über lange Zeit die gleichen Anforderungen oder die gleichen Grundlagen für die Programme hat, dass sich die Developer darauf verlassen können und die irgendwie schön alles immer läuft und nicht hier dieses Sammelsurium an verschiedenen Apps für verschiedene Android-Modelle hat wie bei der Android-Plattform. Aber irgendwann wird auch Apple dann mal nachziehen müssen, nur lassen sie sich halt immer mehr Zeit, aber das war bei Apple auch schon immer so.
Ja, nee, wieso müssen sie nachziehen? Womit müssen sie nachziehen?
Mit dem iPad auf jeden Fall.
Dass da ein Retina-Display rein muss beim iPad, ok, klar, aber beim iPhone die Auflösung reicht, also für mich wird das auf jeden Fall für immer reichen, weil meine Augen werden schlechter und ich brauch keine höhere Auflösung mehr, ist zumindest meine Vermutung. Die Displaygröße hat fort-, also ich meine, klar, dann hat man mehr Pixel, aber man hat auch mehr Gewicht, mehr Akkuverbrauch, mehr Zäubler-Ups.
Also in dem Moment, wo sie irgendein anderes Display rausbringen mit einer anderen Pixelzahl und Größe, handelt es sich wieder um eine komplett neue Generation und Art von Gerät, die nicht Telefon ist und die nicht iPad-artiges Tablet ist.
Das wird eher ein Paradigmenwechsel, als einfach ein größeres Display werden, ist auch meine Vermutung.
Vielleicht ist das nächste Display wirklich so ein 46 Zoll TV.
Oder direkt in die Augen eingelesert. Was ich aber noch mit Android 4.0 jetzt so krass finde, wo ich heute Morgen bei Spiegel online war, so ein Artikel darüber drinnen, dass Google das vorgestellt hat, was man sich von Apple gewünscht hätte und jetzt die wesentlichen Features.
Was haben wir uns von Apple gewünscht?
Ja, vor allen Dingen genau. Ich hab auch den Artikel gelesen, dachte mir, und jetzt?
Das sind Features, die sind, also zum Beispiel jetzt kann man die Musiksteuerung auch auf dem Log-Screen machen. Sie haben Ordner auf dem Home-Display, kenn ich auch, vergrößerbare Widgets, okay, von diesen Widgets halt ich tatsächlich nicht sonderlich viel, Kamera übers Log-Screen erreichbar, Rechtschreibkorrektur, verbesserte Tastatur, total neuer Font, Voice Recognition und ein total neuer Font, der aussieht wie Helvetica. Und schnellere Kamera.
Also es ist eigentlich, genau, Helvetica.
Und ein neuer Up-Switcher, genau, das haben sie.
Das ist legendär.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel Neues.
Und NFC-Beaming.
Das finde ich ja ganz cool.
Das hatte der Sohn auch.
Ja, wenn es ein zweites Gerät gäbe, das das hätte, dann wäre es echt cool.
Aber wenn du dann Siri fragst, wo ist denn der nächste mit NFC, dann sagt der ja noch zwei Kilometer und dann kommt vielleicht mal einer, wenn er es anhat, weil er ja eigentlich sein iPhone benutzt. Nee, nicht so fies sein, das ist schon alles ganz toll.
Was mich total verstört an diesem Release ist, ich meine dieses Telefon heißt Galaxy Nexus. Was wollen sie mir damit sagen?
Das sind halt zwei Marketing.
Vorher gab es eine ganze Serie von Geräten, die hieß Galaxy irgendwie. Noch davor gab es eine ganze Serie von Geräten, die hieß Nexus irgendwie.
Das sind zwei verschiedene Firmen.
Die haben sich zusammengetan und sie konnten sich nicht einigen.
Google hat immer alles Nexus. Also Google hat das Nexus One rausgebracht.
Aber was bedeutet das jetzt für dieses Telefon? Ist das irgendwie Google-Liga?
Ja, das ist mit reinen Google-Interfaces.
Ja, aber es gibt ja andere auch, die nicht Nexus heißen.
Na aber nicht so wahnsinnig viele. Was gibt es denn noch, das reines Google-Interface hat? Ich glaube nicht viel. Also Samsung hat normalerweise da die eigene Oberfläche drauf.
Na Motorola und seien sie klipp.
Motorola hat hier dieses, ich weiß nicht, Moto Blur, glaube ich. HTC hat HTC Sense. Also so reine, die puren Google-Android-Telefone, die gibt es eigentlich immer nur in dieser Nexus-Serie, die direkt von Google kommt.
Also meinst du, das Standard UI ist eigentlich nirgendswo vertreten?
Das ist nur auf diesen Demo-Geräten. Ja, das ist so. Na und dann halt, dass es diese Partnerschaft ist, also Nexus heißt auch, ist jetzt sozusagen, setzt jetzt den Standard für die Generation.
Das heißt jetzt kommt irgendwie Google raus und nachdem sie sich Motorola gekauft haben, gehen sie mit Samsung kuscheln.
Na damit sie den anderen zeigen, dass sie jetzt halt nicht ihre Motorola-Planeten ausmachen.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gemacht, aber wo ich ja auch in diesem Artikel... Einen Tag vorher stellt Motorola ihr neues Flagship-Telefon vor, also die Telefonsparte von Google stellt ihr neues Flagship-Telefon vor und es hat eine veraltete Android-Version drauf und sie können auch nicht mal sagen, ob jemals ein Update dafür kommt. Und diese neue Generation, die hat ja auch diese Tasten nicht mehr, dieses Android 4.0 und so. Und ich meine, es ist doch...
Da haben sie noch diese Tasten drauf dann.
Natürlich. Ist ja noch die alte Generation. Brauchst du ja. Und anstatt die schon mal ins Display zu packen oder sowas, und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich kann mir zum einen vorstellen, dass sie mit Samsung einfach schon die Verträge über diese Nexus-Serie, dass sie gleich so zwei oder drei Geräte vorher festgeschrieben haben. Weil das haben sie ja irgendwann gemacht, als sie noch lange nicht vorhatten, Motorola zu kaufen. Dann sind sie gesagt, ja, ja, ihr kriegt jetzt hier mal vier Geräte lang oder so, die nächste immer das Nexus-Teil. Oder dass es einfach bei Motorola so verpeilt ist, dass die es nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, da jetzt schon mal Android 4.0 drauf zu pappen, weil das ist ja schon seit achteinhalb Jahren in der Mache dieses Telefons oder beides. Ich vermute beides.
Ein Hühnerhaufen ist das.
Also ja.
Also Android 4.0 ist das, was man ungefähr 2013 dann auf jedem Android-Telefon finden wird.
Ja und der Source-Code soll ein Walrann rauskommen nächstes Jahr, wie kostet's Open?
Genau.
Also wir halten fest eine totale Erleichterung im Vergleich zu dieser totalen Enttäuschungs-Serie.
Ach und sie haben was so aussieht wie Fotoboos.
Ja ich will Fotoboos aus dem iPhone haben, warum gibt's das noch nicht? Das find ich doof, weil auf dem iPad macht das ja super Laune, aber das könnte doch auf dem iPhone genauso laufen.
Hätten sie mal iChat integrieren können.
Wobei wir müssen ja auch die positiven Samen von Android sagen, sie haben einen Log-Screen mit Gesichtserkennung. Das möchte ich gerne mal wirklich mal ausprobieren, das würde mich echt mal interessieren. Also dass du dein Gesicht irgendwie vor das Telefon halten musst, damit das anlockt und keinem Kunde mehr eingeben. Also sie haben, soll wohl schnell sein. Ich bin mal gespannt auf die Fehlerraten und wie gut es zum Beispiel im Dunkeln funktioniert oder auf dem Motorrad.
Es hat wohl bei der Demonstration nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe ein paar Videos gesehen, wo es super geklappt hat.
Wahrscheinlich weil das Telefon, das was sie da gerade hatten, keine Front-Facing-Kamera hatte oder was?
Na im Dunkeln wird es problematisch.
Das ist einfach die Antwort auf creepy. Das ist even more creepy.
Meinst du, die machen jetzt alles nach? Aber sie haben ja fast 6 Millionen Tablets angeblich verkauft. Geschätzte.
Wer hat das geschätzt?
Hier, wie heißt der Ruben? Nee, wie heißt denn der Android-Chef?
Wer muss das schätzen?
Der hat das geschätzt.
Wissen Leute, wie viele Dezensen von ihrem OS draußen sind?
Ich mach mal so ein bisschen Fenster auf.
Wie viele Aktivierungen da täglich per Software gemeldet werden? Also wenn es einer weiß, muss er es sein.
Also es gab ja diese andere Schätzung, die auf offiziellen Aktivierungszahlen basierte und auf OS-Verteilung, wo man ja relativ einfach raussehen kann. Mit Honeykamp gibt es ungefähr 3,6 Millionen aktive Nutzer. Und um auf 6 Millionen zu kommen, dann muss man ja schon so dann wahrscheinlich auch diese ganzen Asia-Shop-Geräte mit einziehen, diese 150 Euro, die nicht mal einen Market drauf haben. Und ich glaube, darüber kriegen sie einfach keine Rückmeldung. Und wahrscheinlich, da hat mir auch jemand drauf festgehalten, wenn es nachher nur 4,5 Millionen waren.
Ja, also ein wahnsinniger Erfolg.
Also Android wird Apple killen, das wissen wir jetzt.
Ja, es ist zumindest keine Enttäuschung.
Ja, der iPhone-Killer. Hat 4 Jahre gedauert, aber jetzt ist vorbei mit dem Spaß.
Und jetzt wird sich im Grab umdrehen.
Ich hab ein, das hat auch Gruber verlinkt, so ein Review von dem, da hat jemand 4 Monate lang ein Android-Telefon getestet. Gleich die erste Zeile, der Too Long Did Not Read war. Ich bin sehr froh, wieder ein iPhone 4S zu haben. Oder ein iPhone 4S zu haben. Der hatte vorher einen 3GS, hat dann irgendwie umgestiegen, jetzt hat er sich ein iPhone 4S geholt. Und der hat ein Video veröffentlicht, wo er einfach die beiden Browser nebeneinander zeigt. Auf dem 3GS und auf dem, was war es, dem Nexus...
Wobei ich mich ja wirklich frage, ob das echt auf jedem Android-Telefon ist.
Auf dem Nexus S? Und das hat so geruckelt, dass es quasi... Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Hier chat hier, da gibt es auch ein paar Android, die schon wieder kochen, weil wir irgendwie das alles scheiße finden.
Aber wäre mal spannend, wenn das jemand nachstellt. Er ist auf die Next-Seite gegangen und er meinte, sobald man viele Bilder oder Inhalte sieht, fängt es an zu ruckeln ohne Ende.
Also die Hörerzahlen steigen auch wieder ins Unermessliche hier. Es geht stark auf die 600 zu.
Siehst du mal, er zoppelt ein bisschen, nicht lustig. Ich müsste eigentlich immer noch so Pling machen.
Wenn mal wieder neue Höchststände verkündet werden.
Was war eigentlich hier bei diesem Blackberry-Unfall, dass sie eine Woche lang ihre importanten Funktionen dann nicht benutzen konnten? Sie haben ja dieses BBM, ich nehme mal an, das ist Blackberry-Messaging, also was iMessage ist. Wusste ich ja vorher nicht, dass die auch da irgendwie sowas haben, aber gut.
Das ist extrem erfolgreich.
Und war wie lange auf?
Zwei Tage.
Nee, nee, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich habe was von einer Woche oder sogar zwei.
Aber das war nur in Europa, das war nicht in Amerika, oder?
Nee, das trat dann auch irgendwie mit Verzögerung überall auf.
Also da hat er, also ehrlich gesagt, ich mag ja den Gruber nicht, weil der ist mir zu parteiisch ein bisschen, also egal. Jedenfalls, der meinte bei RIM irgendwann mal, also der berichtet ja auch immer grundsätzlich schlecht über die und lacht ja auch über alles, so richtig, ganz fies. Und meint da ja langsam, hätte er ja auch schon Mitleid. Also von denen hört man ja nicht mehr was, oder?
Also, gibt es hier noch?
Jaja, die gibt es schon noch.
Aber ich meine...
Ja, sie sind in die Kleinen. Also ich meine, ihr Marktanteil wächst nicht mehr auch nur im Ansatz, in dem Maße, wie der Gesamtmarkt, also wie das Wachstum des Gesamtmarktes es verlangen würde, wenn man sagen würde, sie sind noch ein starker Player. Ich glaube, er sinkt sogar. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich wüsste auch nicht, mit welchem Produkt die da jetzt in irgendeiner Form was da entgegensetzen.
Die ersten, die ein Tablet rausgebracht haben.
Das ist ja auch super verkauft.
Es sind fast 200.000 Geräte von verkauft worden. Aber da ist nicht nur dieser Blackberry-Messenger ausgefallen, sondern Mails werden ja auch über diese zentrale Infrastruktur zugestellt. Das heißt, die Blackberry-User haben auch alle keine Mails bekommen. Und das ist so, als ob da...
Und das ist gerade, ich meine, Blackberry haben dann schon früher, also die haben ja im Enterprise-Bereich losgelegt.
Wegen Mail. Das ist deren einziges Verkaufsargument bis heute.
Das heißt, die Leute, die dann sozusagen Blackberry haben, so Ackermann oder so wahrscheinlich. Und Merkel? Da ging denn gar nichts.
Ich glaube, Merkel hat kein Blackberry-Telefon.
Und Obama.
Genau.
Und das haben sie gemacht, als das iPhone 4 es vorgestellt wurde.
Das ist ein besseres Timing.
Kann man sich kaum aussuchen.
Das wird für Steve wahrscheinlich noch in so einem Sterben noch so das Kabel gezogen haben.
Es ist...
In der Cloud.
Es bleibt immer noch dasselbe Drama.
Los komm, wir geben dir jetzt noch 2-3 Minuten für Nokia. Dann hast du es hinter dir.
Also angeblich soll ja das Nokia OS nicht ruckeln hier, das Meebo und so im Vergleich zu Android.
Das was sie jetzt aufgegeben haben?
Deswegen haben sie es wahrscheinlich auch gegeben.
Ja, hier im CCC, da gibt es so ein paar Die Hard Nokia Fans.
Haben die alle ein N900?
Nein, nicht alle, aber ein paar.
Oh Gott, das N900 ist aber auch die totale Unterträgerin. Das behauptet ja auch niemand.
Das ist ein Nerd-Telefon, oder?
Das benutzen die, weil sie SSH machen wollen.
Ja, aber SSH kannst du auch auf dem iPhone machen.
Aber ohne Tastatur.
Das ist schon wirklich, da möchtest du schon tief rein. Da musst du schon eine hohe Leidensfähigkeit haben.
Ja, du, die benutzen das. Kann ich dir sagen, die sind auch glücklich damit, und die wollen auch nichts anderes benutzen. Also es gibt so, gibt's noch.
Also wenn ich mein Hauptanwendungsgebiet SSH wäre, würde ich mir da kein iPhone verkaufen.
Ernsthaft.
Also wenn ich jetzt so Admin wäre und das Überwachen von Systemen SSH wäre, wäre das wichtig. Dann kann ich das verstehen, dass man sich da so einen N900, so einen Teil da irgendwie zurechtzieht.
Ernsthaft? Also ich hab das in den Türen.
Aber ich find ja prompt eigentlich jetzt doch auch durchaus sehr angenehm, SSH klein auf dem Phone. Aber naja.
Ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile gute SSH klein fürs iPhone und fürs iPad.
Ja, ich sag ja noch, wenn es das wesentliche Ding ist, worum es geht, dann hast du da so einen SSH-Teil. Das ist einfach so dafür gemacht. Also für Terminal-Typing finde ich Tastatur dann auch. Das ist quasi so ein Miniatur-Laptop.
Aber, you're mileage may vary.
Sag ja nur, ich kann es nachvollziehen, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was Dennis jetzt noch zu Nokia sagen wollte.
Ich gar nicht.
Ich dachte, du kannst vielleicht noch, damit du besser schlafen kannst nachher nicht, dass du ins Bett gehst, ohne was gesagt zu haben. Das kann man auch schlecht einschlafen.
Was soll ich denn dazu sagen?
Nicht mehr.
Was soll ich denn dazu noch sagen? Ich hab das schon vor Jahren alles gesagt. Weckt mich, wenn sich irgendwas geändert hat.
Ich glaube, ich hörte mir jetzt noch hier mit Wendy Rubin dieses Interview bei der...
Also bisher lag ich nicht so falsch, oder?
Sie haben ja noch nicht ihr Windows... Dieses Jahr sollte es noch kommen, ihr Windows-Frauen. Und ich glaube, es wird das erste Windows-Frauen sein, was sich in einer okayen Zahl verkauft. Die Dinger von Nokia.
Was ist denn eine okaye Zahl?
2-3 Millionen.
Ich sehe nicht, dass der Windows-Frauen-Marktanteil nennenswert steigen wird. Egal, Nokia hin, Nokia her.
Aber finden sie nicht so eine Monokultur auch ein bisschen langweilig?
Ja, aber... Ich sage ja nicht, ich will, dass Apple 100% Marktanteil hat. Das ist überhaupt nicht der Punkt. Ich sage nur, ich beklage, dass die anderen auch einfach alle zu schlecht sind. Guck dir doch an, was Nokia sich da geleistet hat über die Jahre.
Setzt es bitte mit Tim, hau alles raus.
Ja, ich meine, sie waren Marktführer in ihren jeweiligen Segmenten. Und sie haben einfach nichts getan. Nichts.
Also bei Rimm ist schon erstaunlich, wie schnell die... Die haben sich ja so langsam nach oben geschlichen. In Europa hat man es ja nicht so gemerkt. Aber in Amerika war die ja da irgendwie eine Einheit. Und hier in Europa ging es dann auch so langsam los. Also voll fett da im Enterprise-Business. Und dann kommt Apple, alle lachen und plötzlich heulen.
Da ist gerade Walk-In.
Und ich meine Rimm, also klar, die verkaufen doch und so. Die machen nicht mal miese, die machen auch noch plus. Ist alles noch entspannt eigentlich so, wenn man es mal so betrachtet. Aber die Zukunft sieht schon nicht mehr so toll aus.
Gestern haben sie ja ein neues Betriebssystem vorgestellt. Also diese Mischung aus Blackberry, keine Ahnung, wie ist BB, irgendwas. Und QNX.
Man sieht schon, wie die trudeln. Das ist ja auch irgendwie so ein Android-Simulator, das auf Ihrem Blackberry oder Aster bringen, weil das so Android-Apps ausführen kannst, aber dann auch nur irgendwelche Minimum-Features. Also dass eigentlich fast gar keine Android-Apps irgendwie funktionieren werden so richtig, die ein bisschen mehr brauchen. Also da kann man ja schon sehen, dass wir auch gleich Android machen können. Die Eier in der Vor sich hin.
Die haben halt diesen Paradigmenwechsel nicht mitbekommen. Das war so, die waren vorher, da haben die Telefone gebaut, mit denen konntest du E-Mail, das konntest du sonst mit Keim. Man muss sich auch mal vorstellen, dass vor fünf Jahren war das höchste Feature, was man von einem Telefon erwarten konnte, dass man E-Mail senden und empfangen konnte. Und die hatten lange Akkulaufzeit und die hatten alles, was damals so als Top-Notch galt und die haben es einfach verpennt. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn jetzt, wenn mit Apple alles gut geht, dann geht mit denen alles gut, aber genauso. Ich meine, es ist eigentlich krass vor. So Apple, heute führt kein Weg mehr an ihnen vorbei und das ganze, zumindest dieses iPhone-Ding, das fing 2007 überhaupt erst an. Das sind jetzt gerade mal so vier Jahre her. So schnell, wie es nach oben geht, kannst du im Zweifelsfall auch wieder nach unten gehen.
Sie wären ihre Konkurrenz fünf Jahre voraus, meinte Steve Jobs, als sie das iPhone vorgestellt haben.
Und die sind langsam rum.
Nokia schafft es dann genau, fünf Jahre später ein Telefon dann rauszubringen, was so ähnlich ist.
Ich sag ja gar nicht, dass Nokia da die große Konkurrenz sein wird, aber so RIM hatte auch so einen kometenhaften Aufstieg. Und jetzt sieht man, wie es mit ihnen bergab geht.
Stimmt, da kam eine Firma, von der es keiner gedacht hat. Aber welche Firma sollte das jetzt sein, die da kommen könnte?
Irgendeine, von der es keiner gedacht hat. Und irgendwann kann halt auch Apple einen Fehler machen.
Das Problem ist, dass sich die Voraussetzungen grundlegend geändert haben. RIM ist noch zu einem Zeitpunkt groß geworden. Da gab es diesen ganzen Markt nicht. Der war noch zu erarbeiten. Und sie haben so eine Lösung gefunden für etwas, was eigentlich so gar nicht ging. Eben durch so eine Server-Infrastruktur und so eine Service-Konstellation. Dieses Angebot des Undockens und so weiter. Also sie haben quasi so einen Hack gemacht, um dann E-Mail doch zu ermöglichen und so Messages zu ermöglichen etc. Und dafür haben sie dann so Geräte gebaut, die mehr von ihren Fähigkeiten als von ihrem User-Interface-Kraft gekommen sind. Heutzutage erleben wir aber, dass eben auch solche mobilen Geräte generalistische Systeme sind. Also dass wir jetzt sozusagen so einen Computer haben und nicht ein Telefon. Und jetzt heißt es, du musst eben die Fähigkeit haben, ein komplettes Ökosystem von Developern und Betriebssystementwicklung voranzutreiben. Und da gibt es einfach nicht so viele Firmen auf diesem Planeten, die das hinkriegen.
Also ich sehe im Augenblick da auch niemanden, der das schaffen könnte, ohne Frage. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob man... Ich meine, Apple war ja auch nicht so, dass sie RIM und Palm und Nokia an den Punkten angegriffen haben, an denen sie gut waren. Sie sind total vorbeimarschiert. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sowas, wenn Apple trifft, kann sowas auch Apple passieren. Ist doch gar keine Frage. Wenn die das nächste große Ding verpennen, dann war's das. Also was ich zum Beispiel eine ganz spannende Sache fand, das ist...
Was ist das nächste große Ding?
Ich weiß noch nicht, was das nächste große Ding ist. Wer es auf jeden Fall nicht auf die Reihe kriegen wird, ist ein Prototyp von Microsoft Research. Sieht total bekloppt aus. Die haben hier so einen Mini-Nano-Biemer auf die Schulter gepappt. Und dann nimmst du deine Hand hoch und hast auf deiner Hand das User Interface. Und dann kannst du anfangen, zum Beispiel eine Telefonnummer zu tippen oder irgendwie SMS zu lesen oder sowas. Und wenn du irgendwie eine längere Mail hast, dann gehst du zur nächsten Wand und dann projizierst du dir das auf die Wand und dann kannst du auf der Wand ziehst du so ein kleines Feld auf und dann hast du so ein Fensterchen auf der Wand, wo du deine Texte lesen kannst. Das glaube ich nicht, dass das irgendwas Tolles wird. Aber, dass wir...
Ich dachte, alle Schlipsel laufen jetzt mit Kameras auf der Schulter durch die Gegend deswegen.
Nein, zum Beispiel nimm mal einen Displays User Interfaces, die in Brillen eingebaut sind.
Und wenn man keinen hat...
Dann setzt man sich halt einer auf. Was weiß ich? Heißt ja nicht, dass das jetzt zwangsläufig ist. Aber das wäre so ein Paradigmenwechsel, wo irgendjemand kommen könnte, aus dem Nichts, der da eine geile Technologie hat, das entsprechend entwickelt und alle finden das toll und wollen das haben und wollen dringend...
Was das Problem ist, heutzutage brauchst du einfach mehr. Und vor allem um Apple zu schlagen, musst du sie gleich in mehrere Bereichen schlagen. Du musst sie im Bereich Hardware Engineering schlagen. Das ist schon mal nicht so einfach. Du musst sie im Bereich Software Engineering schlagen.
Nee, du musst sie gar nicht in allen Bereichen schlagen. Doch.
Warum? Weil du sonst nicht besser bist.
Das erste iPhone, das hatte nicht mal 3G. Damals war UMTS ein absoluter Standard.
3G war nicht der entscheidende Punkt an der Stelle.
Genau, das meine ich ja. Und das kann eventuell auch da sein.
Trittens, du musst sie im Preis schlagen.
Das sollte machbar sein.
Also bei einem Telefon ist doch glaube ich noch Luft.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jemand billiger produziert als Apple.
Aber billiger verkauft.
Ja, aber Gewinn musst du auch noch machen, weil sonst kannst du diesen ganzen Scheiß nämlich nicht finanzieren. Der nächste Punkt ist, du musst Apple auch im Retail schlagen. Und im Retail sind sie ganz weit vorne. Die Präsenz von Apple als Marke weltweit durch ihre Retail-Expansion ist entscheidend vor allem für das iPad. Und ich glaube, dass das iPad einfach der Ort ist, wo man sie theoretisch schlagen müsste. Gar nicht mal mehr beim iPhone. Naja, das können wir so stehen lassen.
Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass die Schicht nicht halb so dick ist, wie sie sich vielleicht im Augenblick aussieht, der Vorsprung, den Apple hat. Und dass das im Zweifelsfall genauso schnell weg ist, wie es gekommen ist. Und klar, das wird so 4-5 Jahre dauern, aber wir sehen es bei RIM, wir sehen es bei Nokia, wir sehen es bei Ihnen allen. Wir sehen es bei Microsoft, die Zeit reicht.
Pfeifen im Walde. So Leute, haben wir noch was nennenswertes Beizutragen zu dieser Welt oder nicht? Ich glaube, das war's, oder? Wie?
Nicht zum Staatstreuern?
Achso, stimmt ja.
Hier ist noch ein Link zu diesem Handtouch-Teil.
Es gibt übrigens diese projizierten Tastaturen auf Tische auch schon, ne?
Ja, ja, weiß ich.
So in richtig klein und kompakt und so.
Ja, aber das war wirklich viel cooler.
Aber ich fand so irgendwie Telefon hinlegen in diesem kleinen Kasten daneben und dann es sah schon aus wie nach Future aus.
Das sieht sehr nach Future aus.
Da gibt's noch mal Staats-Trojaner-Video auch gleich mit ein bisschen Club-Display im Hintergrund, kommt sehr gut hier.
Mach mal hier Link auf.
Mach mal Link auf.
Es tut mir leid, ich konnte Ihre Anfrage leider nicht verstehen.
Nächstes Mal schweiß ich auf Tim raus und lass ihn in die Seriedesendung moderieren.
Der Chaos Computer Club hat am Sonntag in Berlin seine Erkenntnisse...
Das sieht ja auch Fefe übrigens, ja.
Wer es nicht weiß, das ist ein Nichts.
Das ist Peter...
.CCC-Sprecherin Constanze Kurz.
Sie glaubt, der entscheidende Punkt an dieser staatlichen Schnüffelsoftware ist die Tatsache, dass man weit über das gesetzlich Erlaubte hinausgegangen ist. Unsere Analyse zeigt das sehr deutlich. Es sollte eigentlich um das Abhören von Telekommunikation gehen, aber in Wahrheit ist tatsächlich ein Bundestrojaner installiert worden mit einer weit größeren Funktionalität. Vor allen Dingen aber mit der Möglichkeit, noch Fremden Schadgut innerhalb der Ermittlungsmaßnahmen nachzuladen. Insbesondere geht es zum Beispiel um die Frage, ob man Bildschirmfotos vom Browser des Betroffenen machen darf. Jeder kann sich heute vorstellen, wie viele verschiedene Dinge man heute mit dem Browser macht, wie E-Mail schreiben, chatten. Hier kann man faktisch in die Gedankengänge des Betroffenen hineinschauen, indem man in kurzen Abständen immer wieder seinen Bildschirm fotografiert und dadurch natürlich auch Texte, die er schreibt, die vielleicht nie seine Festplatte verlassen hätten, abfotografiert und die in Ermittlungsmaßnahmen eingehen. Und letztlich vielleicht auch Gedankengänge, die wirklich niemals Telekommunikation waren. Es geht darum, wie sicher die Software programmiert ist, also die Frage, ob nicht ein Dritter den Steuerungs-Server, der die Kommandos an diese Spieluntersprung verlehnt hat, oder selbst kommandosentfragt. Und hier hat sich herausgestellt, dass die Authentikisierung schwach ist, also dass der Kommandoserver, der die Befehle senden soll, nicht nochmal nachprüft, ob die Software tatsächlich auf einem infiltrierten Rechner ist oder vielleicht irgendeine andere oder fremde Software. Das heißt also, das dritte im Prinzip auf diesem Weg, wo die Daten ausgeleitet werden und die Kommandos gesendet werden, eingreifen können und ihrerseits Schadsoftware aufbringen können. Aber wir haben Hinweise darauf, dass es sich um ein Ermittlungsverfahren gehandelt hat. Wir haben aber vor allen Dingen auch technische Anhaltspunkte. Denn wenn man zum Beispiel vergleicht, wie üblicherweise solche Spionage-Software, wie man sie im Internet normalerweise trifft, gebaut ist, sind da doch einige technische Abweichungen, die uns zu dem Schluss gebracht haben, dass es sich hier um spezifischen Behördentroianer handelt. Es gibt da klare Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichts. Eine Quellentky muss rechtlich, aber auch technisch dagegen abgesichert sein, über das Abhören der Telekommunikation hinaus Daten zu sammeln. Das ist faktisch nicht geschehen. Das konnten wir sehr klar belegen. Das heißt natürlich, dass es entweder keine Quellentky ist oder aber, dass natürlich die Ermittler, die diese Software eingesetzt haben, einen Rechtsbruch begangen haben. Und wir haben Anhaltspunkte dafür in der Software gefunden, dass sie dies bewusst getan haben. Denn insbesondere das Nachladen von Schadcode ist in der Software verschleiert worden. Das heißt, man hat versucht, vor denjenigen, die die Software prüfen, zu vertuschen, dass ein Nachnadelmodul für weitere Funktionalitäten besteht. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht ein Skandal. Und ich glaube, die Öffentlichkeit hat auch ein Recht darauf zu erfahren, wie viele dieser Spionagesoftware-Versionen und zu welchen Zwecken eingesetzt wurden. Denn ganz offensichtlich für die Fälle haben wir Hinweise von der Software, die wir erhalten haben, dass es dem nicht tatsächlich um die Vorgaben des Verfassungsgerichts geht in Bezug auf schwerste Kriminalität. Und da würden wir doch gerne mal Auskunft haben, in welchen Fällen diese Spionagesoftware eigentlich tatsächlich eingesetzt wurde. Denn auch da gibt es ja klare Vorgaben aus Graz Ruhr.
Meine gute Bandformsetzer. Ich könnte das noch mal zusammenfassen. Einfachen, klar verständlichen Wort.
Weiß irgendjemand nicht, was der Bundestrojaner ist?
Heißt das jetzt eigentlich Bundestrojaner oder Staatsstrojaner?
Ich glaube, jetzt kann man wieder Bundestrojaner sagen.
Nachhaltig verstört. Na ja, jahrelang hat man sich bemüht, diesen Namen Bundestrojaner wurde aufgebaut, war endlich irgendwie verfangen und dann wurde die ganze Zeit vom Staatstrojaner geredet.
Das ist auch nicht wieso.
Ich glaube, weil das nicht der Bund war. Weil zwischendurch die Vermutung existierte. Moment mal, das ist der Freistaat Bayern, der diesen Trojaner installiert hat. Damit kann man das nicht mehr dem Bund in die Schuhe schieben, sondern es ist dann der Bayern-Trojaner oder Staatsstrojaner.
Das ist ja ein Landestrojaner.
Na ja, Freistaat.
Freistaatstrojaner.
Freistaatstrojaner sozusagen, aber frei passt ja nicht zusammen.
Ist ja auch egal, wie der nun heißt, oder?
Ich glaube, jetzt heißt er wieder Bundesstrojaner.
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich finde ja schon, ist ja gerade in der Außenkommunikation des Klubs schon immer auch ein wichtiger Punkt gewesen, dass man versucht, die Begriffe zu definieren und dann auch möglichst klar zu halten.
Ja, aber wenn du dich da so angreifbar machst, wenn das dann nachher nachweislich nicht vom Bund stammt, dieser Trojaner, sondern wenn der irgendwo andersherstammt, nachweislich, dann zu sagen, äh, dann hätte das überhaupt immer noch Bundestrojaner, dann hast du schon mal einen Minuspunkt.
Aber jetzt, wo er rausgekommen ist, dass im Prinzip alle Bundeslehrer den auch eingesetzt haben. Und der Bund auch?
Auch schon? Ne, und Brandburg, die haben doch gesagt, dass er nur, das ist eigentlich nur, ja, wir haben den einmal eingesetzt, weil wir haben doch nur vom BKA uns hier Rechtshilfe geben lassen. Und so eine Späße. Ich hab mir das heute mal wieder angeguckt. Ich hab mir heute diese entsprechende Stunde da im Bundestag, diese Fragestunde angeguckt und ich fand's ja, oh Gott, war das furchtbar. Und dieser Uhl, der ist, der war echt, also hier...
Ich würde ja mal so ein bisschen mehr so für Leute reden, die vielleicht noch nicht wissen, worum es geht, weil sonst...
Brauchen wir das?
Müssen wir hier für Leute reden, die es nicht wissen, was das ist? Na ja klar, ums reden wir ja hier.
Aber dazu gibts ja Chaos Radio dann morgen auch noch auf Radio Fritz wahrscheinlich. Also sehr wahrscheinlich übrigens.
Morgen!
Heute?
Nächste Woche.
So, 18.
27.
Kleiner Programmhinweis für alle, die im Sendegebiet von Radio Fritz...
Genau, da gibt es eine Alternativlos-Folge zu.
Oder die hinkriegen, den MP3-Link zu finden.
Die technisch glaube ich ganz gut ist. Alternativlos, die Alternativlos 19 zum Thema.
Achso, ja da war die Constanze auch.
Da war Constanze auch. Ich fand's so vom ganzen, wie es aufgezogen war, fand ich so mittel, aber inhaltlich wurde da schon ganz gut erklärt, warum es geht. Vor allen Dingen, was ich da kapiert habe erst, dass er, also ich, geht ja darum, dass dieser Trojaner existiert und dass der Skype-Gespräch abhören darf und dass er offensichtlich mehr kann. Unter anderem, weil er eine Update-Funktion hat, was dann natürlich nicht mehr rechtens ist und weil er auch Screenshots machen kann und weiß ja teufel was.
Das ist ja das, was sie meinen. Also von, wie war das, vom Verfassungsgericht? Ja, ich hab schon mal darüber gesagt, das muss so umgesetzt werden, dass es rechtlich und technisch halt nicht anders möglich ist als Telekommunikation überwachen. Da der Trojaner aber Screenshots machen kann. Also die meinten ja hier groß, überschriftlich so ein bisschen BZ-Style, dass halt der Trojaner keinen Gedanken lesen kann. Das dachte ich auch, was ist denn das für ein Blödsinn? Aber es kommt halt daher, wenn du halt da deine E-Mail schreibst und da schon Sachen hinschreibst und denkst, naja, das schreib ich aber so doch nicht und du löscht es wieder. Also durch die Screenshots kann man halt schon sehen, was getippt wurde, aber was vielleicht nie so dein Rechner verlassen hat oder hätte oder wie auch immer. Und da stoßen sie sich halt ran. Und klar mag das nur so eine Kleinigkeit sein, aber ich finde, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, hört mal zu Jungs, Überwachung kann ja alles schön und gut sein, aber macht das hier so, damit man auch da keinen Schindluder mit treiben kann.
Und die machen es halt nicht so, dann finde ich, ist das schon ein bisschen daneben, weil es ist halt nun mal das Höchste, die Verfassung, und da sollte man sich schon dran halten. Und da sind Politiker und BKA, tralala, sind da nicht ausgenommen.
Also... Dann ist ja noch diese Update-Funktion, die drinne ist, um sich selber auf den neuesten Stand zu bringen.
Sagen sie.
Ja klar, also auf jeden Fall ist es eine Möglichkeit, neuen Code nachzuladen. Und diese Funktion ist ja sogar verschleiert. Also offensichtlich im Gegensatz zu den anderen Funktionen. Wir machen Screenshot und wir hören Telefonate ab und sowas. Das sind alles Funktionen, die sind nicht so gut verschleiert. Oder sind gar nicht verschleiert, sondern sind einfach so drinne. Da hinten gegen diese Update-Funktion, da ist der einzige Punkt, an der so ein bisschen Aufwand getrieben ist, um auch mal, damit man die nicht sofort bei der ersten Analyse findet, wo man ja schon davon ausgehen könnte, da hatte wohl offensichtlich jemand ein schlechtes Gewissen, als er diesen Teil der Software gebaut hat.
Und man muss ja auch sagen, dass hier der so einfach easy programmiert wurde, dass es halt der Club geschafft hat, die Überwachungsseite sozusagen wieder nachzuprogrammieren, dass halt da ein Meckentosch, also wurde auf dem Mac gekodet, dass da auf dem Meckentosch eine App existiert, was halt den Trojaner sich die Screenshots holen kann und alles da so mitlesen kann. Und die haben nicht mal irgendwie die Schlüssel gewechselt, sie haben nicht mal irgendwie Public-Private-Keys benutzt, dass man halt da verschlüsselt ohne...
Also die Befehle zu übergaren?
Die Gegenstelle, um den Trojaner abzufragen.
Der CCC hat einen Server-Dummy programmiert, der die Funktionalität hatte.
Wo du alle die Screenshots kriegst und so weiter und so fort.
Ich dachte, es gibt jetzt irgendwelche Zeichen, dass das...
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber was ich ja in der ganzen Außenkommunikation...
Die sagen zwar, dass es das nur auf Windows gibt, aber hier so die Mac-User, ich würde mich ja da nicht drauf ausruhen, dass es so was für einen Mac ja nicht gibt. Also warum sollte es so was nicht auch für einen Mac geben? Der nutzt ja keine offenen Löcher, wenn die Mac-User der Meinung sind, ein bisschen überheblich, vielleicht, dass es da keine Lücken gibt, die gibt es auch, aber das ist halt ein Trauerner, der wurde halt irgendwie so eingespielt, da muss man ja gar nicht unbedingt irgendwas für offen haben, sondern zur Not die Guss ist halt am Flughafen und schieben es über Fireware, DMA direkt in den Speicher rein, zack, fertig. Wie auch immer. Also es könnte so ein Ding auch für einen Mac geben, wieso nicht?
Problemlos, weil die Prozesse, die gesigned sind, nicht so ohne weiteres Code injecten kannst?
Äh, brauchst ja gar nicht zu signieren. Das ist halt ein Programm, das war halt nichts weiter als ein Diemen, der im Hintergrund läuft.
Nein, ich meine, wenn du jetzt ein Programm, sowas wie iChat, da den Datenstrom abfangen willst.
Ja, guckst du einfach ins Transcription Log. Die fangen ja vielleicht gar nicht den Datenstrom ab. Das ist ja bei Windows bestimmt auch nicht, also die haben ja Zeug ja bestimmt auch, wird verschlüsselt gesendet und die haben auch wieder...
Also da gab es noch eine Liste von Access, die explizit da angegangen werden. Also geht doch explizit auf die Executables los. Ja, da gab es irgendwie so 12 Programme...
Also bei Skype gehen sie offensichtlich an die ganz offizielle Skype-API ran. Da gibt es eine eingebaute API, die hab ich bisher nur bei Übercaster nicht funktionierend gesehen, wo dann Skype nachfragt, so, hey, hier will Programm XY, möchte sich gern verbinden, möchtest du das? Und dann für immer Zusage. Und da musste wohl tatsächlich ein entsprechender Bundesbeamter davor gesessen haben und das einmal gar geklickt haben, damit das wirklich funktioniert. Also das würde auch bei Mac funktionieren. Ich glaube, mag jetzt sein, dass es vielleicht nicht ganz so trivial wäre oder sowas.
Anders auf jeden Fall. Ist egal.
Wobei gezeihnt ist, dass auch beim Klicks mittlerweile alles geht.
Ich würde mich nicht zurücklehnen als wer auch immer und denken, ja, auf Mac kann mir sowas nicht passieren. Also warum nicht? Gerade jetzt, wo es immer mehr Macs verkauft werden und gibt, wird auch da irgendwann der Bedarf kommen.
Gibt es Erkenntnisse, wie dieser Trojaner überhaupt ins Feld geführt wurde?
Aber in dem einen Fall haben sie jetzt inzwischen ja auch erzählt, der Typ ist halt außer Landes geflogen, haben sie bei der Zollkontrolle schon geguckt, was es für ein Rechner ist, haben sie schon vorbereitet, als der Typ zurückgeflogen ist, haben sie wieder eine Zollkontrolle gemacht, haben den Rechner im Nebenraum irgendwie angeschlossen, isoliert von dem Typen, genau, haben den da drauf gespielt und ihm den dann wiedergegeben. Also da gibt es ja viele Wege. Einmal sind sie ja wohl angeblich auch in irgendein Büro eingebrochen, würde ich jetzt mal nehmen, also eingedrungen, haben den dann halt da nachts irgendwie eingespielt.
Schon immer mit physical excess, es gibt jetzt keinen Beleg, dass sie jetzt über das Internet von außen in irgendeiner Form gezielt die Büchsen angegriffen hätten.
Da würden sie auch nie zugeben, weil dann ist ja der Exploit irgendwie im Arsch. Also, weiß schon, die wollen ja so lange nutzen wie möglich, also klar haben die das bestimmt auch gemacht. Ist ja auch nicht mehr neu, dass man diese Exploits irgendwie überall einkaufen kann, dann kaufst du den halt, den du brauchst und machst du das. Schiebst den halt da rein.
Na gut, aber du musst ja auch an die richtige Büchse irgendwie rankommen, also musst ja auch schon gezielt genau den Rechner und nicht irgendeinen Rechner, wie jetzt bei Botnetzen, kriegen.
Schon klar, ist schon ein bisschen schwerer als so einfach mit einer Schrotflinte in die Menge zu schießen, sondern du musst schon den richtigen treffen und am besten auch keinen anderen dabei.
Was heißt am besten? Also wenn sie verfassungsrechtlich einwandfrei sein wollen, dann dürfen sie...
Dann sind sie ja ähnlich.
Ja, aber ich meine, nehmen wir mal an, sie haben den Anspruch ursprünglich gehabt, das zu sein, dann dürfen sie keinen anderen erwischen.
Die Liste der Executables wird hier gesagt, ist für das Screenshot recht. Aber wenn Screen und Programme passen nicht zusammen, ich meine, der Screen ist der Screen. Dann sind doch alle drauf.
Nee, die haben ja nur, wenn bestimmte Programme entweder nur von... Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie einen kompletten Screenshot gemacht haben oder nur das Fenster fotografiert, aber auf jeden Fall nur, wenn das entsprechende Programm auch auf Vordergrund war. Und ich meine, du kannst ja gucken, von wo bis wo geht das Fenster und da...
Damit sie dich mehr Screenshots machen als nötig.
Ich weiß, sie haben schon ein bisschen Arbeit betrieben, um wirklich sich handwerks an die Vorgaben zu halten.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie doll der Trojaner jetzt schon reverse-ingeniert ist und wie öffentlich das gemacht wird. Oder ob sich den nur die Vollprofis irgendwie unter sich angucken, aber theoretisch könnte da demnächst auch einer kommen, könnte eine Mac-App schreiben, die auf die gleichen Commands reagiert und auch Screenshots von so Mac irgendwie an die Überwachungssoftware sendet. Vielleicht kann er nicht alle Features, aber Screenshot sollte ja nun relativ easy sein.
Schreib doch mal so einen kleinen. Schreib doch mal den Bundestrojaner für Mac.
Mit Steve wäre das nicht passiert.
Ja, aber mit Steve wäre das nicht passiert. Tim Cook hat jetzt auch mal einen Kunden angerufen direkt und sich für die Kritik bedankt und so.
Sogar angerufen?
Das furchtbare Apple-ID-iCloud-Desaster. Das haben wir ja noch überhaupt nicht...
Welches Desaster?
Das ist eine Enttäuschung.
Man kann irgendwie Apple-IDs nicht zusammenführen.
Ja, ja. Das ist... also ich frage mich... Das ist eigentlich schon eine Katastrophe. Dass sie das nicht gesehen haben.
Du hättest noch NetNews sein, oder was? Alter, was ist das von gestern? Mehr fällt ihm dazu auch nicht mehr ein. Was zeigst du hier? Das war feierabend.
Was war denn gegen irgendwas nicht?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass die Leute halt mehrere Apple-IDs haben.
Ach so.
Die verwenden eine bei iTunes. Da haben sie sich mal so einen Account gemacht. Dann haben sie sich einen.mec oder.me, also Mobile-Me-Account gemacht. Dann war es halt sowieso at.me.com. Früher konntest du dir Apple-IDs auch einrichten, die nicht eine E-Mail-Adresse sind, sondern irgendeinen Namen. So einen hatte ich auch noch mal. Und ganz früher, wenn du richtig oldschool bist, da konntest du dir ja auf allen möglichen Ebenen, was weiß ich, wenn du dich bei diesem Concierge angemeldet hast, bei dem Buck-Reporter, überall hattest du so Apple-Accounts, die dann alle für sich zu Apple-IDs geworden sind. Und ich hab auch so ein Portfolio von drei oder vier verschiedenen Apple-Accounts, die jetzt eigentlich alle Apple-IDs sind, die für unterschiedliche Dienste aktiviert sind, aber wo ja auch Sachen dranhängen. Da hängt irgendwie deine Musik, hängt an diesem ganzen iTunes-Kram dran, dann hängt jetzt dein ganzes Syncing, hängt irgendwie an dem Mobile-Mii dran. So. Und jetzt kommt Lion und sagt, ja hier iCloud, eine ID für alles. Ja, alles schön einfach. Und die Leute, die jetzt mit ihrem iTunes-Kram angefangen haben, haben ihr Mobile-Mii-Kram nicht. Und andere, die ihr Mobile-Mii genommen haben, die haben jetzt auf einmal ihre iTunes-Sachen nicht mehr. Und das ist alles ein großes Desaster. Und es muss einfach die Möglichkeit geben, die Sachen zusammenzuführen.
Es kommt ja keine Ahnung. Willst du durch irgendwie 50 Millionen IDs durchklicken, ob es den irgendwo doppelt gibt?
Wieso durchklicken? Was soll ich da durchklicken?
Ich brauch doch nur...
Ich weiß doch, welche ich habe. Ich kann auch einfach mich mit meiner primären Apple-ID einloggen und sagen, hier, ich hab noch eine andere, bitte merge alles rein.
Fertig.
Und dann kannst du auch die Passwörter zu den Apple-IDs weißt du ja nur, kannst da eingeben, dann wissen sie, dass du auch wirklich deine...
Also ich sehe da jetzt ehrlich gesagt kein großes Problem. Die müssen sich halt darüber im Klaren sein, was das für sie für Implikationen hat in Bezug auf, wenn dieselbe Information in beiden widersprüchlich ist oder keine Ahnung, wie das mit Lizenzen ist, wenn du jetzt mit zwei verschiedenen Apple-IDs iTunes-Kram gekauft hast und dann willst du es zusammenführen, erlauben die Verträge mit den Musikfirmen das... Also weiß ich nicht, aber sie müssen das Problem lösen. Und ehrlich gesagt, mich überrascht das, dass sie das jetzt erst hektisch angehen und nicht schon vor ein, zwei Jahren. Also ich hab auch deswegen schon mal beim Apple Support angerufen. Wie denn das so? Ja, geht nicht. Hast aber schon so ein bisschen bekloppt, oder? Ja, geht nicht.
Ich hab ja immer, schon immer, gebe ich einfach immer, wenn sie von mir sowas haben wollten, immer meine ursprüngliche erste Apple-ID an, egal wo ich mich damit anmelde, bei Developer oder sonst was. Das heißt, ich hab überall die gleiche. Allerdings, wer weiß, ob das nicht auch als unterschiedliche Entitäten irgendwo in ihrer Datenbank abgespeichert ist, aber prinzipiell hab ich da, glaub ich, dann noch gute Karten einfach immer die gleiche genommen.
Ja, das ist gut, aber für mich steht derzeit einfach die Transition zu iCloud. Vor allem, ich muss ja auch warten, bis alle Computer, die derzeit an meinem Kalendersharing teilnehmen, offline sind.
Ja, und dann sind sie ja nicht offline, wie ich sehe, da kommen ja noch hier die Bubble-Scrollbars.
Nee, ich hab mir einen Computer noch aufs Neulappertier gehalten.
Was hast du Angst? Jetzt mit 10.7.2 kannst du es doch riskieren. Bei den meisten ging es auch gut.
Ja, ich war hier, also weißt ja, wie das ist. Never change a running system.
Ja, wo ist denn da die Herausforderung?
Audio Software? Audio Treiber?
Ist bestimmt alles viel besser unter dem Line.
Ja, es sind schon so einige Updates hier und da gekommen mit und jetzt geht es auch mit Line und so. Also da warte ich ruhig noch ein bisschen. Außerdem hab ich Angst vor diesem Fullscreen-Modus.
Muss man ja nicht benutzen.
Nee, muss man nicht benutzen, aber es frustriert mich dann, wenn ich es dann ausprobiere.
Also auf dem Klein nutze ich ihn mittlerweile richtig gerne.
Ich hab immer Colonel Panics bei Lion, wenn ich meinen USB-Stacker rausziehe, weil mir dann immer Apple IO. Serial irgendwie Colonel panikt. Weil ich hab hier so USB-Serial und es bombt nicht mal im FTDI Treiber, sondern es bombt im Apple IO.
Service Pack 3. Noch lachen wir. Noch lachen wir. Bald gibt's auch Mac OS X64 Build Ultimate Enterprise Family Edition.
Zeit wird's.
Ich bin ja für...
Wie sollen die anderen sonst aufholen?
OS X Extreme bin ich ja.
iOS 360.
So, ihr Helden, haben wir's? Man muss sie immer so maßlos übertreiben. Schöne, schlanke, kompakte Sendung. Agil.
Raubkatzenartig. Podcasten wir uns durch den Äther.
Oh, wisst ihr schon, ich muss Schluss machen. Mal winken.
Ach, Dennis hier, guck mal, hier bist du nur aufgefordert. So ein kleines Statement. Nee, lass mal. Nein, jetzt hast du auch nicht das Wort.
Ja, es geht abwärts. Der Co singt täglich. Die Difficulty singt auch täglich, weil die passt sich ja an, aber der Co singt schneller.
Also Hyperinflation quasi.
Also immer schwerer, immer weniger Geld zu machen.
Es wird immer leichter, immer weniger Geld zu machen.
Das heißt, du generierst jetzt gerade auch Bitcoins wie nichts Gutes.
Wie es wird leichter?
Es wird leichter, Bitcoins zu erzeugen. Aber es wird schneller weniger wert, als es leichter wird.
Weil die Leute aussteigen, weil sie sich die Stromkosten nicht mehr leisten können.
Und umso mehr aussteigen, umso leichter wird es, damit möglichst gleich viel Bitcoins pro Zeit erstellt werden. Aber der Wert sinkt halt so rapide, dass...
sich das nicht lohnt.
Aber wenn er wieder steigt? Die Herstellungskosten für ein Bitcoin, wenn man zu Hause so einen Rechner mit Grafikkarte hat, die Herstellungskosten sind inzwischen höher, als das, was die Bitcoins dann wert sind. Obwohl ich auch mehr erzeuge, weil diese Schwierigkeit sinkt.
Da könntest du auch was anderes damit erzeugen, außer Bitcoins.
Ja, ich kann demnächst mir da Windows installieren und Raid Stand spielen, das ist nicht gerade rausgekommen. Mit schön fett drei Grafikkarten oder vier sogar in parallel geschaltet. Mit diesem Öl vergesst es Jungs, das war beim Kumpel, da war nie eine Grafikkarte drin, die Bitcoin rechnen konnte. Das war nur mal so zum Testen. Kleine Jungs am zocken.
Nur Show.
Es war nur für Twitter. Genau.
Also sagen wir jetzt Tschüss. Wir sagen auch Tschüss.
Aber nicht so wie Steve.
Noch nicht, nee.
Keiner sagt das so wie Steve.
Das war's für heute.
Danke fürs Kommen und wir sehen uns bald. Right now the new is you.
And that is as it should be.
Stay foolish.